WILL BEGIN MOMENTARILY.
WILL BEGIN MOMENTARILY OR.
WAITING FOR AT LEAST.
ONE REPUBLICAN MEMBER TO BE
HERE.
SO THEY CAN WATCH US
THAT'S WHY.
I THINK WE.
NOT JUST.
I ARE YOU READY.
A GOOD MORNING WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE ON WE
HAVE A VERY PACKED AGENDA.
ITS ALLIES WE. WOULD LOVE TO
WAIT FOR ALL THE MEMBERS TO GET
HERE.
IT JUST JUST IMPOSSIBLE FOR
BETTER BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
.
SO OFF CALENDAR TODAY.
BEING PULLED.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT CUNNINGHAM CALL BY
AUTHOR.
AB TWENTY FIVE BUT ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT MELENDEZ PULL BY
AUTHOR.
AND THE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT CARILLO
PULL BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO MR LOW YOU MAY BEGIN.
S. AS WE GET A QUORUM WILL BE
ABLE TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I UNDERSTAND THEY
HAVE A BUSY SCHEDULE. AND IS
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS HAS
ENJOYS AN AYE AYE WRECK SO ALLOW
ME TO BE VERY BRIEF AND
PRESENTATION JUST EIGHTY MISTER
QUIRK HAS.
MOVED A BILL. THAT I'M SECOND
UNIT. ADD THAT THIS BILL IS WITH
RESPECT TO A BALLISTIC IMAGES
AND ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
TYPE OF JIM WILLIAMS IN
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND.
WITH ME TODAY'S JAMES GIVEN
SHAPIRO ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
CLARA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S.
OFFICE AT IS ALSO SPEAKING
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME TODAY I'M JAMES GIVEN SHAPIRO
I'M AN ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AT THE SANTA CLARA
OFFICE I'VE BEEN A PROSECUTOR
FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS. I HAD OUR
HOMICIDE TEAM OUR VICTIM
SERVICES UNIT AND OUR CRIME
STRATEGIES UNIT SEVENTY ONE
PERCENT OF ALL
HOMICIDES IN THE STATE.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR
ARE VICTIMS OF AN AGGRAVATED
ASSAULT WITH A GUN THAT'S ABOUT
TWENTY PERCENT OF ALL AGGRAVATED
ASSAULTS.
IT IS SURPRISING THAT GUN
CURRENT GUN CRIMES ARE NOT
SOLVED MORE OFTEN. ONLY SIXTY
PERCENT OF HOMICIDES ARE SOLVE
ONLY FIFTY FIVE PERCENT OF
AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS. ARE SOLVED
BUT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO SOLVE
MORE OF THESE CRIMES AND KEEP
THE PUBLIC SAFE FOR BY GETTING
THE GUNS IN THE SHOOTERS OF
THESE GUNS OFF THE STREET.
BY TAKING GUNS FROM CRIME SCENES
AND TEST FIRING THEM WE CAN
DETERMINE THE MARKINGS THESE
GUNS LEAVE ON THE SHELL CASINGS
FROM BULLETS. BY TAKING SHELL
CASINGS FROM EVERY CRIME SCENE
AND TESTING THEM AND ANALYZING
THEM IT ENTERING THEM INTO THE
NATIONAL DATABASE RICANS LINKED
TO UNSOLVED CRIMES. AND USE THE
INFORMATION KNOWN IN THOSE TWO
INSTANCES TO BUILD A CASE THAT
SOLVES BOTH OF THEM.
WE KNOW THAT THIS KIND OF
TESTING WORKS TO LINK CRIMES
TOGETHER AND TO SOLVE THEM JUST
THIS YEAR IN PHOENIX POLICE USE
THE SHELL CASINGS FOUND AT THE
SCENES. OF EIGHT UNSOLVED
MURDERS WITH THE GUN OF A
SHOOTER TO LINK ALL OF THEM
TOGETHER AND TO DETERMINE THAT
HE IS A SERIAL KILLER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR HARD
WORK ON THIS AND I'LL BE HERE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU ARE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I DID YOU WITNESS ISN'T.
IN OPPOSITION.
ARE ANY.
UP THERE YOU GO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS IS HOW MUCH TIME BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CRIME LAB DIRECTORS. THE ONE I
THINK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE. ON TO WORK ON
THEM.
ON THE ISSUE OF WHETHER.
EVERY.
CRY FORENSIC LAB HAS ACCESS TO
THIS PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGY. ON
SOME CRIME LAST MISSION WILL
AREAS TO NOT HAVE ACCESS OR THEY
CANNOT CONTRACT OUT. WITH THEM
OTHER CRIME LABS DUE TO RESOURCE
SAYS SO WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS TO.
DO WHAT THAT THE SPONSOR HAS
EXPRESSED ON WITHOUT PUTTING ON
DO BURDEN ON OTHER AGENCIES THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
ISSUE IS RESOLVED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
CORSO'S ALONG TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION.
ARE WHO WERE CONCERNED ABOUT A
COUPLE THINGS FIRST.
MISSES AN UNFUNDED MANDATE THAT
PRIORITIZES THE COLLECTION AND
ANALYSIS OF CERTAIN TYPES OF
EVIDENCE PROBABLY AT THE EXPENSE
OF OTHER TYPES OF EVIDENCE OF A
GUN IS. A COLLECTED AT THE SCENE
OF A CRIME OR MAYBE EVEN JUST
TURNED IN.
.
THERE ARE BURDENSOME
REQUIREMENTS IN THIS BILL TO
TEST FIRE THAT WEAPON.
THERE'S NOT A WHOLE LOT OF
DETAIL INTO WHO DOESN'T HOW DOES
IT WHO PAYS FOR THAT SORT OF
THING. UP BUT THEN IT GETS
ENTERED INTO NIGHT AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID.
AND NOT EVERY AGENCY IN CRIME OF
HAS ACCESS TO A NIGHT AND
TERMINAL IF THEY DO IT'S NOT
INEXPENSIVE.
TO PROCURE THAT ACCESS.
THE I THINK WE ALSO HAVE A SORT
OF FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT WITH
THE WITH THE PROCESS HERE WHICH
IS THE. THE MANDATE THAT WE.
.
HOW POLICE UNDERTAKEN VESTED
HAITIANS HOW?
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS TAKE
EVIDENCE ANALYZE IT COLLECTED.
THE PRIORITIES WITH WHICH THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE CONDUCTED.
I OBVIOUSLY WANT TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS IN GUN CRIMES WANT TO
KNOW IF THE GUNS BEEN USED IN
ANOTHER CRIME THAT'S USEFUL
INFORMATION BUT AGAIN WITH THE
DETAILS. AND HOW WE ARE
LEGISLATIVE WE PRIORITIZE IN
THAT WE HAVE A DISAGREEMENT WITH
THAT SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK
YOU KNOW VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS
THE COURT YEAH I'LL BE VOTING
FOR THE BILL AND WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
BUT THE AYE AYE GIVE CRIME LABS
HAVE RAISED DE IN ISSUE OB I'M
JUST CURIOUS IF YOU.
WHAT DIRECTION SHE MIGHT
LOOKING AND IF?
IF IT'S TOO EARLY TO SAY YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BUT WHAT
DIRECTIONS YOU MIGHT BE LOOKING
AND. OUGHT TO SOLVE THE ISSUE
OF.
RURAL PLACES NOT HAVING.
ACCESS TO THE DATABASE
IT'S BETTER.
SURE WELL ACCORDING TO OUR SANTA
CLARA COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WE'VE CHECKED IN WITH THE
A TF DIRECTLY AT WITH RESPECT TO
THE OWN CRIME LAB AND. WE'VE
BEEN ADVISED THAT ORANGE COUNTY
FOR EXAMPLE.
SEEMS TO LACKS AT LACK ACCESS
TO THIS A DATABASE ON THE
CURRENTLY USE EVIL FINDER AND
THAT.
SOME OTHER CITIES USE HAVE
ACCESS TO THE DATABASE SO I AS
PREVIOUSLY HAS BEEN STATED WE
WILL BE WORKING.
WITH A OPPOSITION TO TRY AND
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS BUT
BEFORE. SO BUT IT'S THEIR
CONCERN AYE AYE ANDERSON YEAH.
LARGE COUNTY COULD SOLVE THE
PROBLEM
BUT WHAT ABOUT OUR RURAL AREAS.
AND THAT WAS WHAT THE CRIME LAB
DIRECTOR BROWN.
SURE AND AS JAMES STEVEN SHAPIRO
I THINK I CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION SIR CURRENTLY THERE ARE
TWENTY TWO NOT BEEN.
CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S EVERY.
MAJOR METROPOLITAN AREA MOST
MEDIUM SIZE METROPOLITAN AREAS
AND FOR RURAL AREAS WHAT THEY DO
NOW WHEN THEY WANT TO HAVE TEST
FIRE A GUN OR AND HAVE
BALLISTICS TESTING IS THE USE
ONE OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
THAT'S CLOSEST TO THEM AND THAT
WHAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO DO
SAYING.
AND WE CAN SOLVE MORE CRIMES WE
CAN MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER
BY DOING THAT.
ALL THE TIME SO IT'S NOT THAT
THE RULE AREAS DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO HAVE ACCESS TO REACH REGIONAL
CENTERS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
SO.
LET'S JUST GRABBED A QUORUM.
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY. PATIO
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK
AIR SANTIAGO.
HELLO YOU MAY CLOSE I RESPECT
AFTER I'VE.
BOB AND I AND I. I'M.
I'M GLAD YOU THE OPPOSITION
BROUGHT THIS UP THIS IS BEEN
SOMETHING I PROBABLY LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD. WHEN I SAY I
THINK IMPLEMENTATION.
PROBABLY JUST AS IMPORTANT MAYBE
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE ACTUAL
LEGISLATION AYE I DON'T.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO PUT WORD
ANY OPPOSITION FROM MOUTH BUT I
I THINK EVERYBODY AGREES WE
SHOULD HAVE.
AS MUCH TECHNOLOGY AS MUCH
RESOURCES WE CAN SO WE CAN
CURTAIL TRUE CRIME. IT IS A
VALID POINT THAT THE OPPOSITION
BROUGHT UP AND.
OF IF YOU COULD. IF YOU WORK ON
THAT AND IF
IT NEEDS MORE RESOURCES A MEMBER
UP SUB FIVE.
I'M WILLING TO BRING THAT
FORWARD AS FAR AS ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT MAY BE NEEDED AND
RURAL AREAS IF THEY DON'T HAVE
TO TECHNOLOGY OR TRY TO FIND A
WAY TO THIS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT.
TEACHERS RECOMMEND AND I VOTE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY I CARILLO CARILLO
AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSES GRADUATION.
UNDER PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR
ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
LACKEY OF ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT RODRIGUEZ
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE ARGUE ARE CURRY.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN COOLEY ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTEEN PATTERSON.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY THURMAN. I'M ELEMENT ITEM
OF THIRTEEN AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
NINE MAIENSCHEIN.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SIX CHEN.
I'M ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB.
TWENTY SIX SIXTY ONE ARAMBULA.
OF ITEM NUMBER TWENTY A. B.
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE LACKEY.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB
TWENTY SEVEN JONES SAWYER ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY THREE A. B.
THIRTY.
SEVENTY GALLAGHER AND I DON'T
WITH THIRTY SIX EIGHTY B. THIRTY
TWO TWENTY NINE BURKE THOSE
AREN'T CONSENT CALENDAR.
IT COULD PROVE SECOND.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR JONES
SAWYER AYE CANCER I LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY
QUIRK
AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE.
IS SET COUNTERS ADOPTED.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE. STONE CHIU
ACT COOLEY I DON'T SEE STE STONE
OR TO SET MEANS MISTER COOLEY
SNACKS.
CHILD IF.
THAT MORNING.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY NINE.
BURGER.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY NINE
REGARDING THE RELEASE OF
JUVENILE RECORDS IN CRIMINAL
CASES.
WHERE THEY MAY BE MADE WHERE
THEY MAY BE MATERIAL THE CASE AT
HAND?
I WANT TO THANK.
.
COUNSEL BURNLEY FOR HER ANALYSIS
OF THE BILL. DOES CONTEMPLATE
AMENDMENTS THERE'S A MOCK UP HAS
BEEN PREPARED.
HAS FOR A ONE OFF FOR THOSE OF
THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TODAY BUT
AGAIN I THINK FOR THE WORK
YOU'RE STAFF ON THIS MATTER.
.
CURRENTLY TO OBTAIN ACCESS TO
JUVENILE RECORDS EITHER
PROSECUTORS OR DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
IN CRIMINAL CASES.
NEED TO PETITION THE JUVENILE
COURT. TO ROOT FOR THE RELEASE
OF THE RECORDS THEY'RE SEEKING.
OF THE JUVENILE COURT JUDGE AND
MAKES A DECISION ON THEIR
RELEASE.
AND THEN A CRIMINAL COURT JUDGE
MAKES A DECISION REGARDING THEIR
RELEVANCY.
CASE WAS SORT OF A TWO STEP
PROBLEM PROCESS.
MORE OFTEN THEN NOT THE JUVENILE
COURT JUDGE WILL NOT RELEASE
RECORDS UNTIL THE CASE IS READY
TO GO TO TRIAL.
THIS CONSUMERS BE UP TO A YEAR
OR TWO AFTER AN ARREST IS MADE.
UPON THEIR RELEASE PROVIDER COME
A COURT JUDGE BELIEVES THEY ARE
RELEVANT TO THE PRECEDING.
THEIR MAY BE FURTHER DELAYS AS
A RECORD THEMSELVES.
ONCE RELEASED ONCE OF THE HANDS
OF THE RELEVANT LAWYERS.
REQUIRE FURTHER INVESTIGATION
AND BACK GROUNDWORK.
SO THAT LATE RELEASE ACTUALLY.
IMPEDES A EARLY JUSTICE FOR
FOLKS IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
.
PROLONG THE TRIAL COULD HAVE THE
DEVIL AFFECT ON A VICTIM WHOSE
RECORDS ARE LIKE IT WAS BEING
ACCESS ASK.
ACCESSED.
AND THE ACCUSED THEM FACES A
LONGER TRIAL.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY NINE AIMS
TO SPRING STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS FOR THE RELEASE OF THESE
RECORDS.
WHEN THEY MAY BE MATERIAL
EVIDENCE IN A CRIMINAL CASE.
THE BILL PROVIDES THE CRIMINAL
COURT JUDGE ACCESS TO THE
JUVENILE CASE FILE HAS BEEN
REQUESTED.
ALLOWING THE JUDGE TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION REGARDING THEIR
RELEVANCE TO THE TRIAL. AND
EXPERT IDEA RELEASE.
.
RECOGNIZING OF CONFIDENTIALITY
IN THE HAMLET OF JUVENILE
RECORDS.
THE BILL REQUIRES PARTIES
RECEIVING A CASE FILE TO SIGN A
COURT ORDER.
TO MAINTAIN CONFIDENTIALITY.
IN THIS WAY THE BILL BALANCES
THE NEED TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS FOR VICTIMS AND ACCUSED
ALIKE
WHILE MAINTAINING
CONFIDENTIALITY THE PERSONAL
JUVENILE RECORDS BEING.
ACCESSED.
I I CERTAINLY WANT TO SAY WELL I
AM GRATEFUL TO BE IN THIS
HEARING AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES.
AS A LAWYER MYSELF I KNOW THIS
IS THIS BILL GETS INTO DALLAS OR
THE WEEDS OF PROCESS.
AND PEOPLE CONTINUE TO READ THE
BILL A LOOK AT THE BILL AND
TRIED TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
FAIR OUTCOME AND A GOOD BALANCE
SEEN. AND OUT OF COURSE WORK
WITH ALL OF SUPPORTERS
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS.
.
TO THAT END.
I HAVE SHAUN HOPPIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
SEAN OFTEN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
I WITH UNFORTUNATE FREQUENCY THE
LIVES OF YOUNG VICTIMS OF
PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL ABUSE OFTEN
INTERSECT WITH CHILD PROTECTIVE
SERVICES AND OTHER SUPPORT
SERVICES. PRIOR TO A CRIMINAL
CASE IN COURT DOCUMENTS
GENERATED AS A RESULT OF THIS
INVOLVEMENT QUITE OFTEN BECOME
MATERIAL. TO THE PARTIES IN A
CRIMINAL CASE BOTH FOR THE
PROSECUTION AND FOR THE DEFENSE.
ARE THEY MAY ASSIST THE
PROSECUTION IN ESTABLISHING
PRIOR OCCASIONS OF ABUSE OR MAY
PROVIDE EXCULPATORY OR
IMPEACHMENT INFORMATION
NECESSARY TO THE DEFENSE OF THE
ACCUSED.
ULTIMATELY THOSE RECORDS BECOME
PART OF THE JUVENILE CASE FILE
WHICH CRIMINAL TRIAL JUDGE WILL
ULTIMATELY NEED REVIEW AND WHICH
PROSECUTORS DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
MAY NEED ACCESS.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
THE.
CURRENT. DUAL REVIEW PROCESS
THAT EXISTS IS.
.
IS.
SOMEWHAT INEFFICIENT.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY NINE WOULD
PROVIDE FOR DIRECT ACCESS OF A
JUVENILE CASE FILE TO CRIMINAL
TRIAL JUDGE.
TO BALANCE THOSE INTERESTS IN A
TIMELY MORE EFFICIENT FASHION.
MAINTAINING STRICT PROTECTIONS
THOSE RECORDS AND REQUIRING THE
SAME BALANCE OF INTERESTS THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS IN SECTION
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN OF THE
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE.
SO ALLOW TRIAL JUDGE TO MAKE
THAT DETERMINATION MUCH MORE
QUICKLY ALLOWING BUT THE
PROSECUTOR AND THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEY TO REQUEST AN
EXAMINATION. OF JUVENILE CASE
FILE DIRECTLY TO THE TRIAL
JUDGE.
AND AGAIN MAINTAINING THE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IN WHILE FOR INSTITUTIONS CODY
TWENTY SEVEN REQUIRING THE
BALANCING OF INTERESTS OF THE
MINOR WITH THE NEEDS OF THE
PROSECUTION TO INFORM THE JURY
AND THE NEEDS OF THE DEFENSE TO
DEFEND THE ACCUSED ADEQUATELY.
I'D ALSO BINDS BOTH THE
PROSECUTION THE DEFENSE WITH A
COURT ORDER LIMITING THE USE OF
THOSE RECORDS EXCLUSIVELY TO.
THE SPECIFIC CRIMINAL CASE AT
HAND HOW THAT MIND WE WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR I DON'T.
THANK YOU.
I'M MARGOT TORTURED CLOSER TO
THE MIKE PLEASE I'M SORRY.
I'M MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE ON
THIS INFORMATION SOMETIMES CAN
BE CRUCIAL. ALMOND EXAMPLE WAS
THE CHILD MOLEST CASE WHERE THE
CHILDREN WERE RESIDING IN
ANOTHER COUNTY.
THE DEPENDENCY RECORDS WHEN I
FINALLY GOT THEM SHOWED THAT THE
FATHER  NOT MY CLIENT WAS
THE ACTUAL PERPETRATOR OF THE
MOLEST.
SO THESE RECORDS ON THEM ARAB
ARE CRUCIAL TO OF BEING ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY DEFEND OUR CLIENTS
AND THE PROCESS NOW. IS EVEN
WITHIN THE SAME COUNTY IS
CUMBERSOME AND DIFFICULT. AND.
YOU DO NOT GET THEM IN A TIMELY
MANNER SO IT MEANS THAT THE
TWELVE GETS CONTINUED.
SO WE ALSO ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
IS NOT TOO OFTEN WE'RE ON THE
BOTH ON THE SAME SIDE YES I
WOULD CAN GRADUALLY TO OFFER
I'VE NEVER SEEN THIS BEFORE PUB.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME ARE ANY
OTHER.
ANYONE ELSE AND SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL.
AND ONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THERE.
SO.
IN THIS CASE ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT A TRIAL THAT THE JUVENILE
IS INVOLVED IN OR IS THIS
SOMEONE ELSE'S TRIAL WHERE THE
JUVENILE RECORD IS IMPORTANT.
SOMEONE ELSE'S TRIAL WHERE THEIR
INFORMATION JUNE RECORD MAY BE
RELEVANT TO THE PROCEEDING.
SO THAT'S WHY WE GET A RELEASE
AND THEN THE JUDGE.
THE CRIMINAL TRIAL LAST RETAINS
IS A MATERIAL IN THIS DOCUMENT
RELEVANT TO THE PROCEEDING.
AND IT'S JUST.
HOW DOES SOMEBODY KNOW TO EVEN
ASK FOR IT?
IT DEPENDS IF IN A CAN ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES SPEAK JAPANESE JUST
RICE FOR THE FACT PARA WHO THE
PARTIES ARE.
AND THE PERSONS INVOLVED.
IN SOME WAY IN THAT COMPLEX SET
OF FACTS HAVE A CONNECTION
NICOLA THAT GORE SYSTEM. AND IS
THIS REALLY THE BILL SUPPORTS
THE IDEA OF OR THE RECOGNIZES
YOU MESSAGES LA JUST YEAH YEAH
THAT'S RIGHT. AND THEN THE. THE
FINAL QUESTION IS.
HOW THIS IS EXACTLY SPEED THINGS
UP SO APPARENTLY IT CAN BE DONE
NOW AND THIS PROCEDURE MAKES IT
FASTER?
WHAT EXACTLY IS?
MAKING IT FASTER.
SO.
RIGHT NOW MOVES UP THE TIME
TABLE OF WHEN IT GETS EXAMINED
IT RECALLS A CORK IT REQUIRES
TWO REVIEWS.
DONE BY THE JUVENILE COURT JUDGE
IN A.
IN THE TRIAL COURT JUDGE
WOULDN'T THIS WOULD CREATE SORT
OF.
A MECHANISM BY WHICH WE WOULD
ONLY HAVE TO GO THROUGH ONE
LEVEL OF REVIEW STILL VESTED
WITHIN THAT JUDGE
PERFECT THANK YOU.
THINK I MOVED TO BE OUT.
THERE'S THERE'S A MOTION.
ARE ANY MORE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YOU MAY CLOSE
MISTER ARAFAT YOUR CLOTHES THANK
YOU VERY TIME I KNOW YOU HAVE
PLENTY WORK TODAY THANK YOU. OF
CHAIRS RECOMMEND I.
BUT SECRETARY CLITORAL. AB
TWENTY SIX IF DENIED THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY I CARILLO THAT
LEO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
THEY GRADUALLY.
SO.
STILL NO STONE NOTE.
NO CHAO.
AND I HAVE MISTER HARPER NEXT IS
HE HERE NO.
AND NEXT MISS BAKER.
BUT
YOU'RE NEXT.
AND THE EARLY BIRD BUT.
THE MORNING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I MATT VERY
UP HONORED TO PRESENT YOU TODAY
AB TWENTY THREE OH TO.
AB TWENTY THREE OH TWO WHICH
INCLUDE THE FAILURE TO REPORT
SEXUAL ASSAULT OF A CHILD.
AS A CONTINUING OFFENSE FOR
MANDATED REPORTERS.
I THIS MEANS AT THE ONE YEAR
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS DOES NOT
BEGIN UNTIL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS ARE CHILD WELFARE
ORGANIZATIONS DISCOVER ABUSE
THAT THE MANDATED REPORTER DID
NOT REPORT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A MANDATED
REPORTER WHO FEELS TO REPORTING
INSTEAD OF KNOWN OR REASONABLY
SUSPECTED CHILD ABUSE OR NEGLECT
IS GUILTY OF A MISDEMEANOR
PUNISHABLE BY UP TO SIX MONTHS
CONFINEMENT IN COUNTY JAIL. OR
BY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AB TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS THE
STATUE LIMITATION RIGHT NOW FOR
FAILING TO REPORT IS ONE YEAR
STARTING FROM WHEN THE MANDATED
REPORTER FIRST REALIZE YOU'RE
SUSPECTED THERE WAS A POTENTIAL.
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT OR CHILD ABUSE
OR NEGLECT.
THIS IS IN CONTRAST.
WITH.
OTHER PROVISIONS IN THE LAW
WHERE INTENTIONALLY CONCEALING
SUSPECTED ASSAULT OF A CHILD IS
A CONTINUING OFFENSE MEANING
THAT THE STATE'S IMITATIONS DOES
NOT KICK IN UNTIL A LAW
ENFORCEMENT DISCOVERS THAT THE.
INFORMATION WAS NOT REPORTED.
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
FAILURE TO REPORT SEXUAL ASSAULT
OF A CHILD IS A CONTINUING
OFFENSE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL FIXES.
THE PROBLEM THAT COMES FROM THIS
WAS ACTUALLY DISCOVERED DURING
THE LARRY NASSER CASE IN
MICHIGAN.
WHERE MANY MANY OF THE MANDATED
REPORTERS THAT THE CHILDREN WHO
WERE?
ABUSE BY NASSER DID NOT REPORT
AND THEY COULD NOT BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE THE STATUE
OF LIMITATIONS HAD LONG SINCE
TOLD.
AND I MEMBERS WE MET ON THE
FLOOR YESTERDAY FOUR OF THOSE
VICTIMS.
I THERE WERE WONDERFUL VERY
COURAGEOUS ATHLETES
OF WHO I VISITED WITH ABOUT THIS
BILL AND THEY EXPLAINED TO ME
THAT AGAIN AND AGAIN THERE WERE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO SUSPECTED THAT
SOMETHING WAS HAPPENING TO THEM
AND THEY DID NOTHING. WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS MAKE SURE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA WE FIX THAT PROBLEM
NOW INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR IT TO
HAPPEN AGAIN THE KIDS?
ME. I WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
THE BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE ONE
YOUR STATS LIMITATION IT'S STILL
ONE YEAR.
IT IS PROSPECT OF
CONSTITUTIONAL IT HAS TO BE SO
ANY WHO WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THIS
PROVISION ANY MANDATED
REPORTERS.
WOULD BE.
WELL AWARE THEY HAVE ON NOTICE
THAT THEY HAVE THIS OF THIS IS
JUST FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT OF A
CHILD SO THIS IS VERY NARROWLY
FOCUSED. I WHICH I THINK IT
DESERVES BEING TREATED THE SAME
AS INTENTIONALLY CONCEALING OF
SEXUAL ABUSE OF A CHILD. AND.
IT IS TO FIX A PROBLEM THAT WE
KNOW IS IN OUR CALIFORNIA LONG
NOW WE ARE ON NOTICE BECAUSE OF
WHAT HAPPENED IN MICHIGAN WE
DON'T WANT IT TO HAPPEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I'M VERY
PLEASED TODAY TO HAVE WITH ME IN
SUPPORT ALSO BRIAN TIERNEY FROM
THE CONTRA COSTA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. AND
LIEUTENANT BRIAN SOUTH FROM ROCK
POLICE DEPARTMENT ADJUST TO JOIN
FOR A MOMENT THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING FAILING MY NAME IS
BRIAN SOUTH ON POLICE LIEUTENANT
WITH THE MORAGA POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT DOES
ADDRESS A PROBLEM REGARDING THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
MANDATED REPORTING OF SEXUAL
ABUSE OF A CHILD.
AS THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN MENTIONED
THE CURRENT LAW IS THAT
MISDEMEANOR FOR MANDATED
REPORTERS WHO FAILED TO REPORT
CHILD ABUSE OR NEGLECT.
AND THAT ONE YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS STARTS WHEN THE
MANDATED REPORTER FAILS TO
REPORT THAT ABUSE.
THIS BILL WOULD INCLUDE FAILURE
OF MANDATED REPORTERS TO REPORT
SEXUAL ASSAULT OF A CHILD AS A
CONTINUING OFFENSE.
AS SHE INDICATED THIS MEANS OF
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS WOULD
START WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
CHILD WELFARE AGENCY LEARNS OF
THIS FAILURE TO REPORT.
THIS IS IMPORTANT FROM A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE
AT TIMES CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE
CASES ARE NOT DISCOVERED IT IS
CLOSED UNTIL.
SOMETIME LATER AND I'VE WORKED
WITH THOSE SURVIVORS THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH A POLICE
INVESTIGATION AND POTENTIAL
PROSECUTION OF THEIR ABUSER. AND
THAT THE REAL KEY IS THAT WE
KNOW THAT EARLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERVENTION IN THESE CASES
HELPS TO PREVENT FURTHER
VICTIMIZATION NOT ONLY OF THAT
SURVIVOR BUT OF ANY OTHER
VICTIMS.
IF WE GET INVOLVED WE CAN
INITIATE INVESTIGATION AND HOLD
THE OFFENDER ACCOUNTABLE.
SO WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO DO IS
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
SEXUAL ABUSE.
OKAY.
YOU CAN CLOSE IF YOU LIKED HIS
RANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE TO TURN IT SORRY
MONEY BRIAN TIERNEY.
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
BEEN AN ATTORNEY FOR NINETEEN
YEARS. I'VE BEEN A DEPUTY DA FOR
FOURTEEN. I'M CURRENTLY IN THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT UNIT WITH CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY THIS IS MY SECOND
TOUR.
I GUESS I'M HERE TO TO GIVE OF
REAL LIFE EXAMPLES OF HOW THIS
LAW THAT IN THE CURRENT.
STATE HAS FAILED WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO LOOK TO LARRY NASSER WE
CAN LOOK TO COUNTY OUR OWN CASES
WITHIN OUR COUNTY. TO REALIZE
THAT THE LAW IS COMING UP SHORT.
WHEN WE HAVE MANDATORY
REPORTERS IN THE LAW FORCES THEM
BECAUSE OF THE SITUATION THAT
THEY'RE IN AND THE CLOSE CONTACT
THAT THEY HAVE WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN. CAN SEE THINGS AND
NOTIFY AUTHORITIES WHEN THEY
KNOW SOMETHING IS GOING ON AND
THEY FAILED TO DO THAT.
AND THEN FIVE YEARS GOES BY AND
THAT PERSON WHO FAILED TO REPORT
THAT YOUNG CHILD CONTINUES TO BE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED IN MOLESTED
OVER AND OVER AND OVER. FOR
YEARS TO COME.
THAT PERSON SHOULD NOT BENEFIT
FROM THE CAR. AND CURRENT LAW.
A WEEK HAVE CASES THAT THAT HAS
EXACTLY OCCURRED AND WE CANNOT
PROSECUTE THAT PERSON.
NOW SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES ARE
UNIQUE IN A SITUATION.
IT IN A UNIQUE SITUATION
BECAUSE THEY CAN OCCUR OVER LONG
PERIODS OF TIME.
AND THE CURRENT LAW.
DOES NOT PROTECT THOSE KIDS IF
THE MOLESTATION STARTS IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL GOES TO JUNIOR
HIGH. GOES INTO HIGH SCHOOL.
WE MAY NOT FIND OUT FOR FIVE TEN
YEARS LATER AND WE CAN'T GO BACK
TO THAT PERSON WHO KNEW WHAT WAS
GOING ON. AND FAILED TO PROTECT
THAT CHILD BECAUSE THE MANDATORY
REPORTER LAWS ARE DESIGNED TO
PROTECT THE CHILDREN ALL WE'RE
ASKING YOU IS TO GIVE THE LAW
LITTLE BIT MORE TEETH. AND AND
ALLOW THOSE PEOPLE TO DO WHAT WE
WANNA DO IS.
FIND OUT WHEN YOU SEE SOMETHING
IN YOU KNOW SOMETHING EITHER YOU
THE NO REASON YOU SUSPECT.
TELL THE AUTHORITIES MIGHT NOT
TURN OUT TO ANYTHING BUT IF IT
DOES IT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
PREVENT THAT CHILD. FROM BEING A
VICTIM FOR YEARS ON END AND
RIGHT NOW THE LAWS IT IS NOT.
SUFFICIENT.
CANI ASKED YOU GUYS.
.
WITH CATHARINE BAKER HELP TO FIX
OUT LAW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OR ANY OF
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE THOMAS SHOP
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NEEDS HIM
ALLEN STRONG SUPPORT.
SHAWN HOP IN THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING ARE KATHY SURE HOW
THE HOUSE OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR ADVOCACY
AND POLICY.
PUMP STATUTES OF LIMITATIONS
EXIST FOR PRACTICAL MEANING FOR
PRACTICAL REASONS AND AS A
MATTER OF FUNDAMENTAL FAIRNESS.
FROM THE PRACTICAL STANDPOINT
STATURE DOES STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS ENCOURAGE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO INVESTIGATE IN
CHARGE CRIMES PROMPTLY. AND
ENSURE THAT CASES ARE HEARD
BEFORE EVIDENCE IS LOST MEMORIES
HAVE FADED IN WITNESSES BECOME
UNAVAILABLE. AS IS IMPORTANT TO
BOTH THE PROSECUTION AND THE
DEFENSE.
IN CASES REGARDING AN OMISSION
SUCH AS A FAILURE TO REPORT IT
CAN BE PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO
A DEFENDANT. TO BE ABLE TO
CONTEST THE CHARGES Y. MEMORIES
ARE STILL FRESH.
I ASK YOU TO THINK ABOUT JOBS
THAT YOU HELD FIVE YEARS AGO OR
TEN YEARS AGO.
THINKING ABOUT AN INCIDENT THAT.
TRYING TO REMEMBER WHAT KIND OF
INFORMATION YOU HAD WHAT YOU DID
ABOUT THAT INFORMATION CAN BE
VERY DIFFICULT AT THAT DISTANCE
YOU MAY HAVE MOVED ON TO ANOTHER
JOB. YOU MAY NOT HAVE THE
RECORDS FROM THAT FIRST JOB THAT
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PROSECUTING FOR
THEIR FAILURES TO REPORT I THINK
UP PUTS. MANDATED REPORTERS IN A
VERY DIFFICULT POSITION.
THE DEFENDANT MAY HAVE
DIFFICULTY REMEMBERING WHAT HE
OR SHE DID HIT DID OR DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT AN INCIDENT OF ABUSE.
OR WHAT THEY MAY HAVE DONE TO
TRY TO REPORT THEIR THERE ARE
CASES IN WHICH PEOPLE DO DO
SOMETHING TO REPORT THE ABUSE
AND.
PROBE FOR WHATEVER REASON THAT
REPORT GETS GETS LOST IN IN
COMMUNICATION.
.
THAT PUTS THE PERSON IN THE
POSITION WHERE IT ALL BUT
IMPOSSIBLE TO CONTEST THE
PROSECUTION'S VERSION OF EVENTS.
FROM A FAIRNESS STANDPOINT AT
SOME POINT INDIVIDUAL SHOULD BE
ABLE TO BE SECURE IN THE
EXPECTATION THAT THEY WILL NOT
BE SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION FOR SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED. UP MANY MANY YEARS
AGO.
MANDATE REPORTERS OF PEOPLE IN
HELPING PROFESSIONS PEOPLE SUCH
AS TEACHERS WHO HAVE DEVOTED
THEIR LIVES TO HELPING CHILDREN.
I THINK SUBJECTING THEM TO
POTENTIAL CRIMINAL PROSECUTION
FOR A FAILURE TO REPORT AND WE
ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT.
INTENTIONAL CONCEALMENT THAT
ALREADY IS A CONTINUING OFFENSE.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
FAILURE TO REPORT.
I IT IT MAKES THOSE JOBS HARDER
AND IT PUTS THOSE PEOPLE IN A
POSITION WHERE.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO WANT TO
KNOW ABOUT THINGS THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO REPORT BECAUSE OF
THIS
CONTINUING DANGER THAT THAT THEY
WILL BE SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
WE ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OKAY HEARING NONE. MIKLOS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK
YOU FOR. THAT TESTIMONY OBSERVE
A SUITCASE IF I COULD ROBERT
PLANT.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE THE PENALTIES
FOR MANDATE REPORTERS OUT RIGHT
THAT'S CORRECT IT'S STILL A
MISDEMEANOR.
CORRECT THINKING.
THANK YOU.
AS I APPRECIATE THE GOOD
QUESTION AND.
ALSO THE TESTIMONY OF MY MOM IS
A RETIRED TEACHER GET TO BRAG
ABOUT OUR AWARD WINNING PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER IN CALIFORNIA. I
WAS MINDFUL OF HOW THEY SHOULD
BE ON FAIR NOTICE THIS BILL IS
PERSPECTIVE SO GOING BACK TWENTY
YEARS WILL NOT HAPPEN IT'S THAT
MEMBERS OF THOSE PROFESSIONS
WILL HAVE NOTICED THAT GOING
FORWARD.
THEY HAVE THIS AND AND I JUST
THINK MORE OF TEACHERS THAT THEY
WON'T TRY NOT TO KNOW. ABOUT HOW
TO PROTECT KIDS. TEACHERS WANT
TO PROTECT KIDS THIS IS WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO THEY THEY DON'T
WANT TO TURN A BLIND EYE THEY. I
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT IS AN
ATTITUDE THAT WOULD KEEP PEOPLE
FROM ENTERING THE PROFESSION OR
EVEN DOING THE PROFESSION TO THE
BEST THEIR ABILITY IN PROTECTING
CHILDREN.
AND FINALLY I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT REMEMBER THIS IS A ONE
YEAR STATURE LIMITATIONS WERE
NOT CHANGING THAT. THE
SIGNIFICANCE IS IN MANY OF THOSE
CASES WHERE THERE'S CONCERN
ABOUT STALE EVIDENCE THERE'S A
THREE YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
AND THIS ONE WILL KICK IN WHEN A
LAW ENFORCEMENT FINDS OUT TO
THEY STILL HAVE TO GET IT DONE
WITHIN ONE YEAR.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE FOCUS THIS BILL THIS WAY
AND BALANCED IT THIS WAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
THE FIRST AND SECOND MICHAEL
WORLD.
AB TWENTY THREE OH TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NOT VOTING LACKEY
LACKEY AYE CARILLO. CAMEO AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSES
CONGRADULATIONS.
SO.
WHAT IS THAT SO?
SUCH. AS.
PLUS SOME STUFF HARPER.
TODAY'S PURPLE TIE DAISY.
MR LOW HAD A PURPLE TIE ON
EARLIER.
I.
BUT ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY TWO.
OF MISCHIEF I'M IT WILL SAY IT
IS ENOUGH RECOGNITION OF OUR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AWARENESS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY TWO. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE A JUDGE OR
MAGISTRATE TO CONSIDER WHETHER A
VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
HAS BEEN STRANGLED OR SUFFOCATED
BEFORE ALLOWING THEIR AGGRESSOR
TO POST BAIL.
APPROXIMATELY FORTY PERCENT OF
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA WILL BE A
VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AT
SOME POINT WITHIN THEIR LIVES.
THAT IS NEARLY EIGHT MILLION
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA WHO WILL BE
ASSAULTED BY SOMEONE THAT THEY
MAY LOVE OR TRUST.
ONE OF THE MOST FEET SERIOUS
FORMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
STRANGULATION.
THIS IS DUE THE FACT THAT MANY
MORE PRESSURE ON THE NECK CAN
RESTRICT BLOOD FLOW AND PREVENT
OXYGEN FROM GETTING TO THE
BRAIN.
WITHIN TEN SECONDS OF BEING
STRANGLED
A PERSON CAN LOSE CONSCIOUSNESS.
EVEN WORSE WITHIN FOUR MINUTES
A PERSON CAN BECOME BRAINDEAD.
UNFORTUNATELY STRANGULATION MAY
LEAVE LITTLE EVIDENCE
ON THE SKIN.
STUDY BY THE SAN DIEGO CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE OF THREE
HUNDRED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES
INVOLVING STRANGULATION REVEALED
THAT UP TO FIFTY PERCENT OF
VICTIMS HAD NO VISIBLE. INJURIES
THIS BILL IS NEEDED BECAUSE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS WHO'VE
BEEN STRANGLED ARE A GREATER
RISK OF BEING MURDERED.
ACCORDING TO THE TRAINING
INSTITUTE ON STRANGLED
STRANGULATION PREVENTION THE
ODDS FOR HOMICIDE INCREASE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY PERCENT
FOR VICTIMS WHO'VE PREVIOUSLY
BEEN STRANGLED.
WHEN PERPETRATORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CAN POST BAIL WITHOUT
SEEING THE JUDGE FIRST VICTIMS
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO SEEK
HELP. BEFORE THEIR AGGRESSOR IS
RELEASED.
ON ONE DAY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN IN
CALIFORNIA THERE WERE MORE THAN
ONE THOUSAND HELP REQUESTS
STATE SERVICES BY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS THAT WENT UNMET
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
CENSUS.
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICES
MOST OF THESE REQUESTS WERE FOR
ASSISTING FINDING. TEMPORARY
HOUSING.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOR SIXTY
TWO IS NEEDED PREVENT TO PROVIDE
FOR VICTIMS OF STRANGULATION AND
SUFFOCATION WITH THE TIME THAT
THEY NEED TO GATHER THEIR
BELONGINGS.
SEEK PHYSICAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
SUPPORT AND DISTANCE THEMSELVES
FROM THEIR ABUSER.
WITH ME TODAY. IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS KIRK MICHELLE'S OF
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND GERALD
FEYNMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR HOPE INTERNATIONAL.
AND THE TRAINING INSTITUTE ON
STRANGULATION PREVENT.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MY. GUESTS PREDICTING
HERE RIGHT.
MY NAME IS KURT KNUCKLES AND I
AM A PROSECUTOR WITH THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND I DO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY TWO.
WHY MEANT THE PENAL CODE SECTION
TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE?
WHEN IT ALREADY REQUIRES
CRIMINAL COURT JUDGES TO
CONSIDER AMONG OTHER THINGS THE
SERIOUSNESS OF AN OFFENCE AND
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC WHEN
SETTING BAIL. ALSO WHY MODIFY IT
WHEN THAT STATUTE ALREADY
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES JUDGES TO.
CONSIDER INJURIES TO THE VICTIM.
THREATS TO VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES.
A DURING THE CRIME AND THE USE
OF FIREARMS OR OTHER DEADLY
WEAPONS DURING THE COMMISSION OF
THE CRIME.
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION OF
THOSE QUESTIONS IS THAT TRULY
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC.
REQUIRES JUDGES TO FIRST TRULY
APPRECIATE THE DANGER PRESENTED
BY A DEFENDANT.
ASSESSING THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE
CRIME SIMILARLY REQUIRES A JUDGE
TO TRULY APPRECIATE HOW SERIOUS
THE CRIME ACTUALLY IS.
BROKEN BONES BLOODY WOUNDS.
SWOLLEN A DISFIGURED BODY PARTS
ARE OBVIOUSLY SERIOUS.
USE OF GUNS AND OTHER DEADLY
WEAPONS IN THE COMMISSION OF A
CRIME REQUIRE NO FURTHER
EMPHASIS.
THREATS TO KILL OR HARM VICTIMS
AND WITNESSES.
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
IN THE STRANGULATION CONTEXT
HOWEVER.
SERIOUS LIFE THREATENING
STRANGULATION EVENTS.
AS OFTEN AS NOT LEAVE NO VISIBLE
INJURIES WHATSOEVER.
I HAVE PERSONALLY PROSECUTED
HOMICIDE CASES IN WHICH ARE TOPS
WE AUTOPSIES WERE REQUIRED
BEFORE THE CRIME COULD EVEN BE
DETECTED OR THE INJURIES COULD
BE DETECTED BECAUSE OF DEATH.
THREATS USED IN STRANGULATION
CASES CASES ARE OFTEN UNSPOKEN.
BUT PERFECTLY CLEAR IN THE EYES
OF THE PERPETRATOR AS HIS FACE
TO FACE WITH HIS HANDS CLENCHED
AROUND THE VICTIM'S NECK.
SQUEEZING THE LIFE OUT OVER.
HANDS ARE THE WEAPONS OF CHOICE
FOR PEOPLE WHO STRANGLED OTHER
PEOPLE NOT WHAT WE THINK OF AS
TRADITIONAL. ARE DEADLY WEAPONS.
THAT DV VICTIMS WHO SURVIVE JUST
ONE.
OKAY SURVIVE JUST ONE
STRANGULATION EVENT ARE MANY
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BECOME A
HOMICIDE VICTIM.
IS NOT COMMON KNOWLEDGE.
UNTIL IT IS COMMON KNOWLEDGE IN
THE OTHER STATISTICS THAT HAVE
BEEN SHARED OR WILL BE SHARED
WITH YOU TODAY ARE COMMON
KNOWLEDGE BILLS LIKE THIS ARE
REQUIRED AND THEY WILL SAVE
LIVES.
JUST ONE MEASURE WE HAVE TIME
HERE FROM THE OTHER WITNESS BUT
YOU TWO MINUTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
COMMITTEE GERALD PINE AND.
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR HOPE INTERNATIONAL
AND THE TRAINING INSTITUTE ON
STRANGULATION PREVENTION WHICH
WAS FOUNDED IN TWENTYELEVEN.
FROM FUNDING FROM THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE I'M ALSO A
PROSECUTOR WITH RIVERSIDE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE I'M
GONNA PROSECUTOR FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS. AND THE SHORT
ANSWER IS THAT STRANGULATION IS
DIFFERENT.
IT IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF INJURY
AND IT SAYS A DIFFERENT THING
ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO INFLICT
STRANGULATION. WE'VE ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT THE STUDIES OF THIS
STUDY ALTHOUGH WAS THAT STARTED
THE CDA OR CDA ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
IT WAS ACTUALLY PUBLISHED IN THE
JOURNAL OF EMERGENCY MEDICINE.
SO TO PEER REVIEWED STUDY WE
TALK ABOUT STUDIES WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE ALTHOUGH FIFTY PERCENT
OF VICTIMS HAD NO VISIBLE
EXTERNAL INJURY THAT IN ME THEY
DIDN'T HAVE INTERNAL INJURY. AND
IT DIDN'T. MEAN THAT THERE WERE
OTHER INJURIES THAT COULDN'T BE
PHOTOGRAPHED.
.
THESE PERPETRATORS ARE NOT ONLY
A DANGER TO THE VICTIM THEY ARE
A DANGER TO THE PUBLIC
THEMSELVES. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THIRTY THREE OF THE FORTY SIX
OFFICERS WHO WERE MURDERED BY
HANDGUN VIOLENCE DIED AT THE
HANDS OF INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
STRANGULATION HISTORY.
THOSE PEOPLE REPRESENT NOT ONLY
A THREAT TO OFFICERS BUT TO THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE IF YOU LOOK
AT OUR MASS KILLERS. YOU LOOK AT
PEOPLE LIKE OMAR MARTINE IN
ORLANDO AYE ESTEBAN SANTIAGO
IMPORT LAUDERDALE FLORIDA THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAD STRANGULATION
HISTORIES ARE SCHOOL SHOOTERS
CEDRIC A.
SAID RICK ANDERSON IN SAN
BERNARDINO. HAD A STRANGULATION
HISTORY
THIS ALLOWS THE COURT TO PUT AT
ITS FOREFRONT THE ISSUE THAT
TELLS US MORE DIRECTLY THAN ANY
OTHER ISSUE. ABOUT THE LEGALITY
OF AN OFFENDER AND FOR THAT
REASON AYE ARCHER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YES COME.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
I THOUGHT.
SO. ARE WE HEARING IS YOUR NAME.
I AM AN OFFICIAL WELL LINGO
LISTS AND YOU SUPPORT THE BILL
I'M A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR
OKAY I'M THAT'S THAT'S IT THAT'S
ALL WE'VE HAD OUR TESTIMONY I'M
SORRY. WE DON'T WE HAVE A LOT OF
BILLS TODAY SITE.
HERE DIS WERE HIS TWO WITNESSES
AND THEY USED UP ALL THE FOUR
MINUTES SO.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ANY OTHER.
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
OKAY ANYONE.
DR ALEXANDRA CORONADO ORANGE
COUNTY INTO THANK YOU.
UP ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL
.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN I'M MARCO
GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. ARMED WE
BELIEVE THAT AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY TWO IS WELL INTENTIONED
BUT UNNECESSARY. AS THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY I BELIEVE FROM SAN
DIEGO POINTED OUT THE COURT CAN
ALREADY CONSIDER WHETHER VICTIM
WAS STRANGLED OR SUFFOCATED. SO
THE BILL IS UNNECESSARY.
HOWEVER ON PERHAPS EVEN MORE
COMPELLING THE LEGISLATURE IS
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING
COMPREHENSIVE BAIL REFORM. ARE
UNDER S. B. TEN.
AND.
IN TERMS OF SP TENET REQUIRES
THE COURT TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE NATURE AND
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE OFFENSE
CHARGED AND THE ALLEGED AND
INJURY TO THE VICTIM. IT GOES
FURTHER THAN AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY TWO.
IT ALSO REQUIRES THAT.
.
THE COURT CAN CONSIDER NON
FINANCIAL CONDITIONS OF RELEASE
ON GPS MONITORING EXCITED.
AND IT PROVIDES FOR RISK
ASSESSMENT AND PRE TRIAL
SERVICES WHICH DEAL WITH SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT.
THE PROPONENTS OF AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY TWO OR TALKING ABOUT
SO IN CONCLUSION WE WOULD ASK
YOU NOT TO ON A VOTE FOR THIS
BILL. BUT TO CONSIDER.
S. B. TEN ON THE OVER.
ARCHING CONSIDERATION OF THE
BELL SYSTEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I MAY NOT IBM'S HAD OPPOSITION
SORRY. A ARE THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MISTER LACKEY YEAH I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ASK THE WITNESS WITH
THIS BILL. HAVE HELPED YOU IN
YOUR SITUATION.
I WAS.
MY HUSBAND STRANGLED ME HE WAS
OUT OF JAIL IN THREE HOURS.
I WAS AT THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT THAT WOULD TAKE A
PICTURE SOME IN THAT.
HE WAS CALLED IN LOOKING FOR ME.
HE WAITED FOR ME TO HOLD
HOSPITAL.
I COULDN'T IT TOOK ME.
I HAD TO SNEAK INTO A HOSPITAL
IN THE BACK DOOR TICKET TREATED.
I BLOOD KIM A LIFE SIR
IT WAS A FIRST OFFENSE HE NEVER
WON A FRONT OF A JUDGE.
THE OFFICERS WERE SO KIND AND
HUNTING BEACH THEY TALK ABOUT.
YOU SAID MA'AM WE CAN'T GUARD
CHIU IT'S JUST A PIECE OF PAPER.
PLEASE LEAVE YOUR HOME.
PLEASE GO TO THE SHERIFF.
THE OFFICER EVEN KEEPING HIS
PERSONAL CELL PHONE NUMBER.
FOR ME TO CALL HIM.
MY HUSBAND STOPPED BEING.
FOR FIVE WEEKS.
HE STOLE A GUN.
HE SAID HE WAS GONNA MURDER ANY
COP
THE GARDEN BETWEEN ME AND HIM.
I WAS HIDDEN Y. BODYGUARD WITH A
BULLET PROOF VEST ON.
SHE WENT FINE OF A JUDGE
I WOULD NEVER.
SPIRITS THIS.
NO WOMAN.
EVER.
SPIRITS WHAT I EXPERIENCE.
NOT YOUR DAUGHTER YOUNG BOB
USES.
IT'S A MIRACLE I'M ALIVE.
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THOSE WHO SPOKE UP BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE. ON WOULD LIKE
PARTICULARLY THINK.
PATRICIA WILD WOMAN GOMEZ AND
ALEXANDER CORONADO FOR BRING
THIS IDEA I IN THIS ISSUE TO ME
IN MY OFFICE
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GIVE
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AMPLE TIME TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO
GET AWAY FROM THEIR ABUSERS.
WITHOUT THIS CRUCIAL PERIOD OF
TIME VICTIMS ARE AT HIGHER RISK
OF BEING TRAPPED IN THE SAME
AGONIZING CYCLE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ALL OVER AGAIN. I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE HELP.
TO PROTECT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIMS AND SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU.
BECAUSE. NO YOUR WAY DOWN.
MOTION TO APPROVE.
THAT'S SECOND.
OKAY.
.
AND MA'AM YOU YOU WERE HURT.
I HEARD EVERY WORD SHE SAID.
AND AND IN IT ARM.
OF.
NOT ONLY DO IT.
IT IS COMMITTEE EMPATHIZES WHICH
YOU.
IT BOTHERS ME THAT YOU DON'T
FEEL THAT THE SYSTEM.
HAD GIVEN YOU ENOUGH PROTECTIONS
WEATHER WAS.
JUDGE WHAT IS LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHETHER WAS PSALM DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROVIDERS.
IF WE.
AND SAW TO WIN EITHER REALLY
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
THAT WHOLE SYSTEM.
IT'S NOW EMBRACE YOU AND TAKE
CARE OF YOU ARE BETTER SO IT IT
EFFECTIVE.
ITEM.
THAT DATE TO CHALLENGE I HAVE
WITH THIS BILL WHY I'M
RECOMMENDING A NO IS BECAUSE THE
EXISTING SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
NOW.
SOUNDS LIKE IT FAILED YOU.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE EXISTING SYSTEM DOESN'T FAIL
YOU BECAUSE WE DO HAVE.
JUDGES WHO CAN MAKE THE
DETERMINATION.
KEEP.
YOUR HUSBAND AWAY FROM ME WE
HAVE DISTRIBUTE JOURNEY
TOURNEY'S WHO CAN ARGUE THE
DANGERS OF STRANGULATION.
IN THEIR.
AND THEN WHEN IT COMES TO BAIL.
AND WE DO HAVE THIS OVER ARCHING
DISCUSSION. ABOUT BAIL WOULD S.
B. TEN AND HOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FOR WITH IT.
I.
THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT.
YOU'VE DONE FOR US HERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND I THINK THAT THE
WHOLE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH UP TO
DISCUSSION ON BAIL I THINK
MISTER HARPER YOU'VE BROUGHT TO
LIGHT TO US.
THAT WE'VE GOT TO CONSIDER THE
PLIGHT OF INDIVIDUALS.
WHO? ARE ARE ARE WILL BE CURSED
WITH
THE PROBLEM OF.
WHAT IS NOT A STRANGULATION
PERSONALLY THREATEN YOU WITH
WEAPONS AND THINGS THAT NATURE
AND WE REALLY NEED TO? TO BEAR
DOWN ON THAT AND A BAIL SYSTEM
TO PROTECT.
ANYONE AND DIDN'T VESTED LINE
SITUATION.
AND SOUGHT UNFORTUNATELY
APPROVAL RECOMMENDED A NO VOTE
BUT I AM STE
I TELL YOU NOW IT DOESN'T STOP
HERE.
AND THAT WE WILL.
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN.
.
BIG IMPLEMENTATION PART WHICH I
TALK ABOUT ALL THE TIME THAT WE
STRENGTH AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE WERE IN SCHOOL WERE.
WHO DESIGNATED TO PROTECT US ARE
ACTUALLY DOING?
THANK YOU.
AGREEMENT FICKLE ROLE AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER. NO JONES
SAWYER NO LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE CARILLO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK KNOWS THAT IAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
IMAGES ARE CALM SHARPER
AND IF I MAY ASK IF THE MEASURE
DOES FEEL LIKE LIKE US FOR
RECONSIDERATION.
WITH OUT OBJECTION.
YOU MADE IT THROUGH WAS
CABALLERO.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO.
MR STONE IS CHAIRING JUDICIOUS
WIFE NOT HERE ON OVERSEE CHU IS.
AND MR DALY WE JUST SKIPPED YOU
SO.
AND THEN MISTER GIBSON IS.
NEXT IF THEY DON'T SHOW UP.
COULD NEVER YOU READY GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO. WHICH
WOULD PROHIBIT THE PROFILING OF
MOTORCYCLE RIDERS IN CALIFORNIA.
NOT WAS DOWN NOT WITHSTANDING
THE FACT THAT MOTORCYCLE
PROFILING IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
AND DESPITE MANY DECORATIONS
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THAT IT IS WRONG.
AND DOES NOT OCCUR THE PRACTICE
OF TARGETING INDIVIDUALS BASED
ON THE FACT THAT THEY'RE WRITING
MOTORCYCLE CONTINUES TO BE A
PROBLEM IN OUR STATE.
IN PROFILING INCIDENCES
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT JUST
SUBJECTED TO UNLAWFUL STOPS BUT
ARE ALSO QUESTION.
THANK YOU.
SEARCHED
VOTERS ARE TAKEN STOPS OUR GUN
POINT AND THEY'RE DETAINED. I'VE
HEARD FROM MANY CALIFORNIANS ON
THIS ISSUE INTO INCLUDING SOME
OF MY CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE.
FELT VICTIMIZED FROM SELECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT OF OR MOTORCYCLE
PROFILING. THIS INCLUDES A
GENTLEMAN WHO RECENTLY CONTACTED
MY OFFICE IN RELATIONS TO A
TRAFFIC STOP BY LOCAL SHERIFFS
WHICH OCCURRED IN LATE MARCH OF
THIS YEAR.
AFTER LOOKING.
HE AT THE BASICALLY HE WAS
STOPPED.
BUT CLOUT AND.
.
ASPERA'S LICENSE WHICH HE
PRODUCED ANY WAS ASKED IF HE WAS
USING MATH COACH COCAINE REPLIED
NO AND HE WAS ASKED TO.
EXIT.
THE MOTORCYCLE OR GET OFF THE
MOTORCYCLE. HE WAS.
ASKED TO ASK ME I'D ME WEAPONS
IN AGAIN IF YOU HAD USED ANY
MATH OR COCAINE.
HE WASN'T SUBMITTED TO A SERIES
OF ROADSIDE TESTS INCLUDING A
URINE TEST AT ROADSIDE.
THE RESULTS OF THE TEST SHOWED
NO SIGNS OF DRUG OR USE
IMPAIRMENT AND IS PROPERTY WAS
RETURNED AND HE WAS ALLOWED TO
GO.
HE WAS NEVER ASKED TO SHOW HIS
REGISTRATION PROOF OF INSURANCE
OR WAS HE ADVISES TO THE REASON
FOR THE INITIAL TRAFFIC STOP.
THE LEGAL STANDARD OF PROBABLE
CAUSE AND REASONABLE SUSPICION
ARE USED TO DECIDE WHEN IT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO STOP AN QUESTION A
PERSON.
THE BILL REAFFIRMS THE STANDARDS
DOESN'T CHANGE THEM.
AT ADDITIONALLY UP BASED ON A
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SURVEY OF
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE RIDERS
MORSE MORE THAN HALF OF THEM
RESPONDED. THAT THEY HAD
EXPERIENCE AND JUSTIFY TRAFFIC
STOPS.
AT ONE OR MORE TIMES THE BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT THE USE BY
OFFICERS A GENERALIZE
STEREOTYPES.
BASED ON THE FACT THAT A PERSON
RIGHT TO MOTORCYCLE ARE WARY
WEARS CERTAIN MOTORCYCLE
CLOTHING AND AND AS WE ALL KNOW
I'M OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE
SUBJECTED THAT TO THIS KIND OF A
TREATMENT. ARE A REALLY DIVERSE
COMMUNITY THAT REPRESENT ALL
WALKS OF LIFE THERE'S DOCTORS
THEIR LAWYERS THERE'S TEACHERS
BUSINESS OWNER OWNERS AND IN MY
COMMUNITY THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF. VIETNAM VETERANS.
ALL INDIVIDUALS DESERVE TO BE
JUDGED ON SPECIFIC ACTIONS OR
BEHAVIOR NOT SOLELY ON THEIR
PARENTS SO I EXPERIENCED IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BUT TODAY.
AND WITH ME TO TEST TRANSPORTER
NICHOLAS HARRIS WESTERN STATES
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE AMERICAN
MOTORCYCLE ASSOCIATION AND DAVID
DEVERAUX FROM THE MOTORCYCLE
PROFILING PROJECT.
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
VICE CHAIRMAN LACKEY AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
I'M NICHOLAS HARRIS I'M THE
WESTERN STATES REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE AMERICAN MOTORCYCLIST
ASSOCIATION.
AS I'M SURE MANY OF YOU KNOW
THE AMA HAS LONG ADVOCATED FOR
THE RIGHTS OF MOTORCYCLE RIDERS
AND MOTORCYCLISTS AND AND PART
OF WHAT I WANT TO JUST TALK
ABOUT TODAY A LITTLE BIT IS NOT
JUST RIDERS BUT. PEOPLE THAT ARE
SEEN AS MOTORCYCLE ENTHUSIASTS
MAYBE THEY'RE NOT EVEN ON A
MOTORCYCLE IN THE TIME THAT
THEY'RE. JUST PERCEIVED AS A
WRITER AND OR AS AS AN
ENTHUSIAST.
THEY MADE ITS MEMBERS ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT MOTORCYCLE
PROFILING ON OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS HAS PASSED IN A A VERY
SPECIFIC POSITION PAPER ON IT
LIKE WE DO ON MANY IMPORTANT
ISSUES.
WE FEEL LIKE.
THAT TARGETING OF MOTORCYCLISTS
IS IS SIMPLY UNFAIR AND IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS WE'VE SEEN A
NUMBER OF STATES PASSED SIMILAR
BILLS THERE'S THE LEGISLATION IN
WASHINGTON MARYLAND AND NEW
JERSEY.
IN ADDITION WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
OTHER EFFORTS
AND YOUR ADDRESSING CHECKPOINTS
AND OTHER OTHER THINGS THAT
SPECIFICALLY TARGET MOTORCYCLES
AGAIN.
I THE A MAY STRONGLY CONDEMNS
THE PROFILING MOTORCYCLES BY
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
AND FEELS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
RIDERS AND ENTHUSIASTS ARE
UPSTANDING LAW ABIDING CITIZENS.
MOTORCYCLIST MOTORCYCLE
ENTHUSIASTS REPRESENT THE FULL
GAMUT OF AMERICANS AND WE FEEL
THEY SHOULD BE JUDGED ON THEIR
SPECIFIC BEHAVIORS AND ACTIONS
AND NOT ON THEIR CHOSEN MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION OR ASSOCIATION
WITH OTHERS.
WE ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT.
I MY NAME IS DAVID DEVERAUX I'M
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF CLUBS AND ALSO
FOUNDER THE MOTORCYCLE PROFILING
PROJECT WHICH YOU TO EVER
ORGANIZATIONS DEDICATED TO
ADVANCING THE RIGHTS
MOTORCYCLISTS.
THE ISSUE BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
IS A SIMPLE ONE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOULD BE BASED ON AN
INDIVIDUAL'S BEHAVIOR NOT THE
INDIVIDUAL'S APPEARANCE OR THEIR
ASSOCIATIONS WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
THIS ISN'T TRIVIALIZING ISSUE
DISCRIMINATION THE FEDERAL COURT
SYSTEM INCLUDING THE NINTH
CIRCUIT HAS SPECIFICALLY
EXTENDED FIRST MEMBER PROTECTION
THE MOTORCYCLE CLUB COLORS AND
MOTORCYCLE CLUB ASSOCIATIONS.
THE BILL IN FRONT OF YOU IS A
SIMPLE SOLUTION THAT HAS ZERO
BUDGETARY IMPACT AND WOULD
IMMEDIATELY SOLVE PERVASIVE
PROBLEM CALIFORNIA. THE CHP
MAINTAINS THE PROFILING IS NOT
OCCURRING AND THEY POINT TO A
STATISTIC THAT SAYS ONLY A VERY
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
MOTORCYCLISTS IN CALIFORNIA OR
CITED EVERY YEAR. UNFORTUNATELY
THAT DOESN'T BEGIN TO REVEAL THE
PROFILING PROBLEM THE MAJORITY
OF PROFILING STOPS OCCUR AS
FISHING EXPEDITIONS OR
INVESTIGATORY STOPS AND THEY
DON'T RESULT IN A CITATION THAT
DON'T RESULT IN ARRESTS. AND IN
FACT THE SURVEY THAT WAS
REFERRED TO THE NATIONAL
MOTORCYCLE PROFOUND SURVEY SAYS
THAT FORTY SIX PERCENT OF
MOTORCYCLISTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
EXPERIENCED A PROFILING STOP
WITHIN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
WITHOUT RECEIVING A TICKET OR
CITATION THAT'S A FAR MORE
SUPERIOR STATISTIC THERE'S A ONE
POINT FOUR PERCENT DEVIATION IN
THAT STATISTIC IS THE MOST
ACCURATE STATISTIC THAT EXIST.
IN ADDITION TO THAT I THINK
THAT.
IN EVENT THAT HAPPENED A LITTLE
OVER A YEAR AGO DEMONSTRATES
WHAT HAPPENS FIFTY INDIVIDUAL
SOME OF WHICH WERE IN THIS ROOM.
GATHERED TO HAVE A MEETING ABOUT
ADVANCING THIS LEGISLATION IN
ALL FIFTY OF THEM WERE PULLED
OVER LEAVING THE MEETING IN
VENTURA COUNTY ALL FIFTY OF THEM
NOT A SINGLE CITATION GIVEN. NOT
A SINGLE PERSON ARRESTED PURELY
PULLED OVER FOR INVEST YOUR
STOPPED.
THAT'S NOT COLLEGE.
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
MAINTAINS THAT LANGUAGE IN THIS
BILL MAY MAKE IT DIFFICULT THE
PROPORTION MATCHES THE
DESCRIPTION LIKE PERSONA
MOTORCYCLE ROBS A BANK. THIS
BILL WOULD MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO
APPREHEND THAT PERSON NOT TRUE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE WENT TO
GREAT LENGTHS IN THE WORDING OF
THIS BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT
WOULDN'T HAPPEN. BY REQUIRING
THE INDIVIDUAL TO HAVE SO
PACIFIC IN PARTICULAR REASONABLE
SUSPICION ON THAT PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUAL AT THAT MATCHES
SUBJECT DESCRIPTION. THEY WOULD
ABSOLUTELY BE ABLE TO BE
APPREHENDED INDEPENDENT OF THAT
I THINK PRIVATE CAUSE OF ACTION
IS APPROPRIATE WHEN YOU ARE
DEALING WITH THE ISSUE OF
DISCRIMINATION THAT IS AFFECTING
FORTY SIX PERCENT. OF
MOTORCYCLISTS IN CALIFORNIA IN
THE POPULATION MOTORCYCLISTS
HERE'S A HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT
TOUCHES A MASSIVE POPULATION. IS
A SIMPLE COST FREE SOLUTION AND
IT'S A NATIONAL ISSUE
LEGISLATION UNANIMOUSLY PASSED
IN WASHINGTON MARYLAND AND THERE
CONCURRENT BILLS IN US CONGRESS
NOW THAT THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PENDING.
A CALIFORNIA.
WOULD BE AN EXCELLENT.
ADVANCEMENT OF THIS MOVEMENT
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ALRIGHTY OKAY.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION ONLY
THERE'S JUST.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT MAY
JAMES LOMBARDO ON BEHALF OF THE
BETA CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION WE SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU PERFECT.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SEVERAL ARTISTS REPURPOSE ANY
THE HERE ARE A COUNCIL OF.
CUT A CATHOLIC CLUBS OUT OF
MONTEREY BAY FOR EASTER.
AND NICK MANSON OF REPEAT
INNOVATIVE CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
DAVE ALLMAN BY SUPPORT THOUGH.
THANK YOU.
HAITIANS SPIKE CANCELED CLUBS
CONFEDERATION CLUBS AND.
THE NATIONAL.
THOUGH PR COMMITTEE FOR THE
CANCEL CLUBS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THE FREEDOM ALLOWS GUESTS.
LEGISLATOR TASK FORCE AND I'M IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
ALWAYS MORAL BUSINESS MANAGER
FOR THE MODIFIED MOTORCYCLE
ASSOCIATION. I SUPPORT THIS
PILL.
YOU.
JEAN HAMMER IT FURTHER ABATE OF
CALIFORNIA LOCAL SEVENTY AND I
SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING BOBBIE TO FOLLOW.
UNITED MOTORCYCLE CLUBS OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY BY BECAUSE LET'S
HER TOLERANCE AND MOTORCYCLE
CLUBS ARE NOT STREET GANGS
INCORPORATED THANK YOU AND I
WHOLLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAMES AARON MARTINEZ
OUTSIDERS MOTORCYCLE AB SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RICHARD NEELY HORRORS
OF LIBERTY AND SUPPORT.
DAVID SEAL SERGEANT AT ARMS
MODIFIED MOTORCYCLE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S MINUTE BOYKIN AND I'M
THE POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
BIKERS RIGHTS ORGANIZATION OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. AND I'M
ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
EXTREME VIXENS MOTORCYCLE CLUB
AND I'M ALSO A BUSINESS OWNER
AND I SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
BRIDGER ROBERT ANDERSON ON THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD FOR COCOA
COUNTY* Y. SOCIALIZATION OF
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SIR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME ISSUES AGO
A CAR FONG OF EXTREME VIXENS
MORE CYCLE CLUB AND I'M IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MORNING
KATHLEEN BUTCHER. A BIT
OF CALIFORNIA LOCAL THREE
THIRTEEN IN THOUSAND OAKS I
SUPPORT THE BILL.
EDU.
CHUCK PETERSON STATE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR A BETA CALIFORNIA
THOUSAND OAKS AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
USER.
TOMORROW ODGERS OF BIKERS OF
LESSER TOLERANCE OF CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LARRY HAVEN BIKERS LISTA
TOLERANCE I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ROB BROWN MESSENGERS MC I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I MARK HENRY WHAT THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONFESSION CLOTHING I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DARCY TORN SIPHON I
RUBY WEBER LIAISON FOR MMA AND A
BIT OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. IQ NAM.
LINDA EDEN. MOTORCYCLE DRIVER
AND VICTIM OF MOTORCYCLE
PROFILING AND I DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M THERESA HOWEVER WHERE SEVEN
A BAIT AND SACRAMENTO AND THEN
ALSO I'M A MEMBER OF THE
SACRAMENTO OUT RIDER MOTORCYCLE
ASSOCIATION. AND WANT TO SAY
PLEASE PASS THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JERRY HELLER.
RETIRED SENIOR CITIZEN MEMBER
OF ABATE MY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
LEAVE MY MIKE.
AT THAT
I'M TO UNIVERSITY ALSO JUST AN
INDIVIDUAL WRITER AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
NO SOLVING JUST AS MOTORCYCLE
CLUB I'M ALSO THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE COALITION OF CLUBS ARE
STARTING CALIFORNIA AND A REAL
TURN I SUPPORT THIS BILL. NIKKI.
FRANK FREIGHTER. A STOCKING JUST
POSE MOTORCYCLE CLUB.
AND I'M A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
AND A SPORTS BILL. THANK YOU.
THINGS LESS NIXON A MONSTER
AVERAGE CITIZEN CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MOVE DAVID MARINO WAS PAID OF
CALIFORNIA SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT
THE BILL.
YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS ROBERT ANDERSON I'M
THE VICE CHAIRMAN OF BIKERS
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION OUT OF NAPA
SOLANO COUNTY. AND ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF SAKS AND CREATE MC.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S RIDING EARLIER.
CONCERNED CITIZEN ALSO
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
MODIFIED MOTORCYCLE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA MYSELF AND MIKE
ORGANIZATION.
HOPE FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE SIX
WEEK MOVE OVER THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR.
DID THE CHAMBERS DIVISION TEN
MANAGER OF MMA AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL WHOLEHEARTEDLY THANK
YOU.
JOSH SERVICE PRESIDENT WAR CRY
CONCERNED CITIZEN I SUPPORT THE
BILL AND THANK YOU.
BRANDY THREATENED I SUPPORT THE
BILL.
TRAVIS THEN THE PROSPECT WORKER
AND THE SUPPORT THE BILL.
LINDEN SLOW SO THE FEW EAST BAY
SUPPORT BILL.
WILL YOU ONLY A STOP AT A
PRESIDENT.
HOLLISTER CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
SU MCFADDEN'S BIKE RIDER.
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT I SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
UNDER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CORY.
MORNING MIXTURE FELL STILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
.
WE HEAR ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION COURSE
ALSO.
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS
YOU NOW CSUS.
I THINK CORRECTLY POINTS OUT.
PROFILING IS THIS NOTION IS
BEING DESCRIBED IS ALREADY
PROHIBITED.
IF NOT BY STATUTE CERTAINLY BY
CASE LAW.
THERE'S A LONG LINE OF CASE LAW
THAT INDICATES THAT AN OFFICER
MUST BE ABLE TO ARTICULATE.
SPECIFIC FACTS TO JUSTIFY A
STOPPER TENSION. UM DESSES NOT
NEW OR.
MYSTIFYING CONCEPT.
IT SO IT'S UNCLEAR HOW.
MAKING SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY
LEGAL. MORE ILLEGAL WILL STOP
ANY SORT OF PERCEIVED BEHAVIOR
THAT'S GOING ON.
A I THINK WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THIS BILL GOES FURTHER THAN
THAT.
AND AS ONE OF THE WITNESSES DID
POINT OUT IT CREATES A SITUATION
WHERE.
YOU HAVE AN AMBIGUOUS SORT OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT COULD PREVENT
AN OFFICER FROM ENGAGING WITH A
POTENTIAL SUSPECT.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT JUST
PULLING SOMEONE OVER ON A
MOTORCYCLE BECAUSE THEY'RE ON A
MOTORCYCLE BUT IN A SITUATION.
WHERE AN OFFICER IS PATROLLING
NEIGHBORHOOD AND GETS A CALL?
AGAIN AS THE WITNESS POINTED
OUT.
THAT A BANK HAS BEEN ROBBED AND
THAT THE SUSPECT WAS SEEN
FLEEING ON A MOTORCYCLE.
IN THIS CONTEXT IT'S UNCLEAR
WHAT ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALIZED
SUSPICION WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
IF YOU SAW A MOTORCYCLE SPEEDING
AWAY FROM THIS LOCATION.
MATCHING THE DESCRIPTION IS THAT
ENOUGH INDIVIDUALIZED SUSPICION
TO JUSTIFY A STOP AND IF IT'S
NOT THEN YOU HAVE AN OFFICER
SECOND GUESSING A SITUATION.
WHO KNOWS WHERE THAT PERSON IS
HEADING NEXT?
BUT AGAIN IT IT SUBJECTS AN
OFFICER TO AN AMBIGUOUS SORT OF
STANDARDS OUTSIDE OF WHAT
STATUTE CASE LAW AND THE STATE
AND FEDERAL CONSTITUTIONS
REQUIRE. A IN TERMS OF WAYS TO
DEAL WITH ANYTHING THAT COULD BE
PERCEIVED AS AN UNLAWFUL SEARCH.
IMPEDING POLICE WORK ON THE
FRONT AND WILL CREATE RISK TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WERE POSTED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
UP ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
LACKEY CERTAINLY.
FIRST OF ALL LIKE TO POINT OUT
THE FACT THAT OF THE BILLS IN
MARYLAND WASHED AND THEY'RE BOTH
TRAINING BILLS AND THEY HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH SUING LONG
FORSMAN OFFICERS.
SO SO MUCH DIFFERENT BILL IN
BOTH OF THOSE.
AND THEN THE OTHER THING I WOULD
LIKE TO CONFIRM IS THAT.
.
FOR ANY.
MISCONDUCT OR ANY UNFAIR
PROFILING. AS WAS POINTED OUT BY
THE OPPOSITION WITNESS.
IT'S NOT OKAY.
IT'S NOT OKAY AS IT CURRENTLY
STANDS.
AND AS A FORMER SUPERVISOR OF A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY FOR
EIGHTEEN IN MY TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS. I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE
TAKE THOSE ALLEGATIONS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
AND THEY ARE FULLY INVESTIGATED
AND THEY ARE. OF DIRT THERE'S
PUNITIVE ACTION TAKEN IF THERE
IS AN INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR ON
THE PART OF THE OFFICER.
SO.
I THINK THAT THIS BILL.
IS MISGUIDED AND I I THINK THAT
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT.
.
WE HAVE A ROAD IN OUR CONFIDENCE
BUT WE WE HAVE WORK TO DO IN
BUILDING. TRUST BETWEEN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND THOSE
WHO WERE.
FEELING THAT THEY'RE BEING
UNFAIRLY PROFILE.
THANK.
QUIRK SO WE CAN. I KNOW THIS
GOVERNOR.
HE WILL.
I THINK THERE'S IN NINETY EIGHT
PERCENT CHANCE TO VETO THE BILL
BECAUSE IT MAKES SOMETHING
ILLEGAL THE CHARTIER LEGAL
HOWEVER I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY.
BUT I THINK YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT A DIFFERENT APPROACH TO
THIS TRAINING WOULD BE ONE.
GATHERING STATISTICS ON HOW
OFTEN.
MOTORCYCLISTS ARE STOPPED
VERSUS HOW OFTEN THEIR CITED
COMPARED TO. AUTOS IS ANOTHER
APPROACH YOU MIGHT TAKE.
BUT THE IBM AGAIN I THINK THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE I
AGREE A HUNDRED PERCENT WITHOUT
THE SUPPORTERS THAT IT IS AN
ISSUE. I'M JUST NOT SURE THAT
ULTIMATELY YOU'LL BE ABLE TO GET
THIS PASSED INTO LAW.
TO GET NOW BE VOTING AYE.
THANK YOU.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY THAT CAME HERE TODAY
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE I PROBABLY HEAR
THIS. OUT IN MY DISTRICT OFFICE
I'M.
AT ITS ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT I
HEAR THE MOST ABOUT.
I HAD IT CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
FROM ONE OF THE CITIES IN MY
DISTRICT WHO SAYS THAT HALF OF
THE TIME HE GOES OUT ON HIS
MOTORCYCLE HE'S HE IS STOP THIS
IS A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER.
PEOPLE KNOW I'M IN THE
COMMUNITY AND STILL GETTING
STOPPED AND SO.
OBVIOUSLY IS IS AN ISSUE THAT
THAT NEEDS A RESOLUTION AND I
THINK THERE'S A WAY TO BE ABLE
TO GET TO YES AND.
I AM WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I APPRECIATE
THAT AND AND WE'LL SEE YOU KNOW
WHERE THEY WHERE THEY END UP
COMING DOWN ON THIS BUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU NAM.
AND.
HOPEFULLY YOU.
WE WORKED THROUGH THE CONCERNS
OF OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT CONCERNS.
REAL.
CRIMINALS AND THEIR ATTEMPT TO
EVADE AND THAT WE DAHLE BLENDED
TOURED GETTING CONFUSED.
AND WE DON'T.
THINK ENCOURAGE INDIVIDUALS
COULD YOU WANT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF THIS.
TO WHERE WE'D WE CAPTURE FEWER
AND FEWER AND I KNOW THAT'S NOT
YOUR TENT THAT'S WHY I'M.
SAME AS LIKE. HOPE TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH THEM.
I.
AS SOMEONE.
WHOSE PROFILE.
I MEAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I WANT ESSIEN HARVARD.
BUT WHEN I GO TO HIGH IN STORE I
GET FOLLOW.
NINE SO I NOTICE LIKE AND I CAN
TELL. PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT AFTER
AMERICAN A LATINO THAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO ME.
A LOT OF TIMES.
SINCE I DON'T SEE IT THEY DON'T
SEE IT.
AND SO I I AM.
SO WHEN I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT YOU BELIEVE YOU BE
IN PROFILE I THINK WE NEED TO
GET. WE NEVER HAVE A DISCUSSION
OF WHY DO YOU THINK THAT WAY AND
JUST TALK IT THROUGH AND I THINK
PART OF THIS IS WHAT MISTER
CORPORATE ST.
LET'S GET TO THE ROOT THIS AS
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO ROOT OF
RACIAL PROFILING WITH.
TRAINING BETTER TRAINING.
AS ETHNIC SENSITIVITY AND OF I
GUESS MOTORCYCLES AND TO TO BE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU WOULD CALL
IT.
BUT THAT YOU SEE SOMEONE.
AND YOU DON'T SEE THEM A CERTAIN
WAY.
BECAUSE STATE DRESSED A CERTAIN
WAY
AND ARE THEY HAVE CERTAIN.
THINGS HONOR JACKET SHOULD MAKE
CERTAIN ASSUMPTIONS.
AND SO I'M RECOMMENDED AYE BUT I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE. YOU.
YOU WALK TO THE CONCERNS THAT WE
WE DON'T CREATE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE THAT INHIBITS LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM DOING. THEIR
JOBS.
ABSOLUTELY.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO CARILLO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
I AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURES ON CALL.
VERY MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME.
DAVID.
TO.
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR YOU.
THE.
I WAS GONNA SAY.
SURE
YOUR HOUSE.
BUT.
I BARELY HAVE DRIVEN THEM ALL
OUT.
YEAH YEAH.
VOTE.
I THINK WE'RE CLOSE THE DOOR
RIGHT ABOUT.
NOW.
YOU CAN GO MISCHIEF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND TO
THE COMMITTEE AND LET ME JUST
START BY THANKING YOU FOR YOUR
IN DURRANCE.
AND APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTEEN TO ADDRESS THE RAPE KIT
BACKLOG.
I KNOW THIS COMMITTEE
APPRECIATES THE INJUSTICE OF THE
RAPE KIT BACKLOG BUT.
I WILL JUST
STATE SHORTLY OF WHAT WE ALL
KNOW THAT AFTER VICTIM HAS BEEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
A COLLECTION OF FORENSIC
EVIDENCE INVOLVES INCREDIBLY
INVASIVE PROCEDURES.
AND WE KNOW THAT WHEN A RAPE KIT
REMAINS UNTESTED IT DENIES
JUSTICE TO SURVIVORS.
IT.
RE TRAUMATIZE IS.
EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED IT
ALLOWS CRIMINALS ROAM FREE AND
THREATENS PUBLIC SAFETY.
AFTER YEARS A SET BACKS
CALIFORNIA'S FINALLY TAKING
STRIDES TO ADDRESS THE RAPE KIT
BACKLOG AND I WANT TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR SUPPORT. ARE
OF MY BILL LAST YEAR AB FORTY
ONE TO PROVIDE MORE TRANSPARENCY
FOR WHY SOME KIDS. ARE NOT BEING
TESTED AFTER GENERATE FIRST OF
THIS YEAR.
BUT WE KNOW THAT EVEN WITH.
THE BILLS OF THE PAST THERE'S
MUCH LEFT TO BE DONE IN
CALIFORNIA AND. THE NATIONAL
PRESS WILL TELL YOU THAT EVEN
STATES LIKE TEXAS AND KENTUCKY
OUR HEAD OF CALIFORNIAN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING. RAPE KIT BACKLOG
REFORM.
THIS BILL WILL TAKE US ONE STEP
CLOSER TO ELIMINATING THE
BACKLOG BY REQUIRING ALL
AGENCIES AND FACILITIES. THAT
RECEIVE MAINTAIN OR SUPPORT OR
OR STORE.
SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS TO
CONDUCT AN AUDIT OF KIDS IN
THEIR POSSESSION TO REPORT THIS
DATA TO DOJ WHO IN TURN IS
REQUIRED TO REPORT.
TO US IN THE PUBLIC ARE ON THE
DATA OF EXACTLY WHAT THE RAPE
KIT BACKLOG LOOKS LIKE.
WE DON'T KNOW THE EXTENT OF THE
BACKLOG IN OUR STATE. OUR THAT
IS NOT HOW THE MOST POPULOUS
STATE IN OUR COUNTRY SHOULD BE
HANDLING ARE RAPE. OF CRIME
EVIDENCE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S AMPLE
FEDERAL FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
ADDRESS BACKLOG KITS BUT TO
APPLY FOR THOSE FUNDS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS NEED TO KNOW THE
EXACT NUMBER OF THE KIDS A HALF
SITTING ON THEIR SHELVES.
ARE YOU OF THIS COMMITTEE CAN
CONTINUE TO DEMONSTRATE YOUR
COMMITMENT
BY SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY. I
WANT TO THANK THE SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL THE JOYFUL HEART
FOUNDATION AND THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DA'S OFFICE.
PARTICULAR ONE THANK DA
O'MALLEY AND REPRESENTING HER
TODAY IS JASON CHEN.
WHEN A MORTAR CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JASON CHAN I'M A
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY HERE
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY O'MALLEY
A CO SPONSOR OF AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTEEN.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE TOOK THE
FIRST STEP AND CONDUCTED AN
AUDIT OF ALL UNTESTED SEXUAL
ASSAULT KITS IN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES EVIDENCE
AND PROPERTY ROOMS.
THAT AUDIT UNCOVERED NEARLY TWO
THOUSAND UNTESTED KITS.
WE ARE PROUD TO REPORT THAT
WE'VE SENT SENT ALL UNTESTED
KITS TO BE TESTED IN THERE'S
CURRENTLY NO BACKLOG IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. WERE ALSO PROUD TO PUT
MEASURES IN PLACE TO ENSURE THAT
NO BACKLOGS FORM AGAIN AND THAT
ALL CONTEMPORANEA SKITS ARE
TESTED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BACKLOG THAT
WE UNCOVERED IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
WAS NOT UNIQUE NATIONALLY IT'S
BEEN ESTIMATED THAT THERE ARE
FOUR TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
UNTESTED KIDS SITTING ON
PROPERTY IN EVIDENCE ROOMS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. THAT
REPRESENTS FOUR TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT THAT HAD TO UNDERGO
INVASIVE AND INTRUSIVE
EXAMINATIONS OF THEIR BODIES
ONLY TO LATER FIND OUT THAT THAT
EVIDENCE WAS NEVER PROCESS.
DNA IS AN AMAZING FORENSIC TOOL.
THROUGH TESTING SEXUAL ASSAULT
KITS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY AND OTHER
COUNTIES ACROSS AMERICA SEXUAL
SOLVE CRIMES HAVE BEEN SOLVED
AND OFFENDERS HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
TO JUSTICE.
SERIAL OFFENDERS HAVE BEEN
LINKED TO CRIMES MANY DECADES
AND CROSSING STATE LINES INDIAN
A HAS EXONERATED THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN WRONGLY CONVICTED.
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE NANCY
O'MALLEY HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN ADVOCATING FOR AND SECURING
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TO TEST PREVIOUSLY UNTESTED
SEXUAL ASSAULT KITS. BUT.
STILL TOO MANY.
SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVORS IN OUR
STATE ARE NOT RECEIVING THE
JUSTICE THAT THEY DESERVE THE
FIRST STEP TO CORRECT THIS IS TO
CONDUCT A STATEWIDE AUDIT OF
UNTESTED KITS. AND A. B. THIRTY
ONE EIGHTEEN WILL ACCOMPLISH
THAT THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES.
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SHOPPING
WITH CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
AS CHAIR RYAN JIM OF THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT WE DON'T HAVE A
BACKLOG IN OUR COUNTY.
BUT WE'RE HOPING THAT THE ALONE
TO GET TAKEN CARE OF AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
.
BUT ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN PURSUE SHOW
MUCH ARE BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CRIME LAB
DIRECTORS I WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE WE ARE
CURRENTLY OPPOSED. AND ADD
THAT'S DUE TO THE FACT THAT.
DEAD BILL AS CURRENTLY BEEN
REQUESTED THE AUDIT BE DONE ON
ANALYZE KITS
NOT ONLY.
ON I TESTED KIDS SO I WE DON'T
SEE THE VALUE OF DOING AN AUDIT
ON ON BRAKE KITS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ANALYZED AND THIS
AUDIT RD AT THIS POSITION ON
THOSE CATS.
ON SO WE HAVE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE AUTHORED THAT IF YOU'D BE
WILLING TO REMOVE THAT PART OF
THE LANGUAGE AND ONLY
CONCENTRATE. ON THAT UNTESTED
KIDS I THINK THAT WILL BRING FAR
MORE VALUE TO WHAT THE INTENT OF
THE GOAL IS AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
AND CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE OFT AUTHORS OFFICE BUT FOR
NOW WE HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OF.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THERE QUIRK.
.
CHAU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU. BOB
DO YOU REALLY WANT AUDIT DUH
TESTED KITS.
WE'RE HAVING A CONVERSATION
RIGHT NOW WITH THE CRIME LABS
YOU KNOW WE THOUGHT IT WOULD
MAKE SENSE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE UNIVERSE LOOKS LIKE
PARTICULARLY. ARE IF THEIR
OFFICES.
THAT HAVE TESTED A LOT OF KIDS
BUT STILL HAVE UNTESTED GETS
THAT BEING SAID VERY OPEN TO THE
CONVERSATION AT THE CRIME LABS
AND IN FACT IN THIS ISSUE OUT
ALRIGHT WELL PERHAPS JUST
ACCOUNT OF THE TESTED KIDS MIGHT
BE ENOUGH. I'M JUST
SUGGEST YOU NAY WE ARE WHAT
WE'RE THINKING THROUGH US OR NOT
TODAY I KNOW YOU'LL.
I'VE I BELIEVE YOU COME TO A
GOOD TECH CONCLUSION ON THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND YOU MAY CLOSE TYPE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
JEFF RECOMMEND YA I CALLED
ROLLED.
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE WO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
A MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES.
MISTER DALY.
AND THEN.
IS EITHER MR STONE FOR MISTER
GIPSON AT CEMEX
IF MR STONE DOES SHOW UP IT'S
MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION ON POLICE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING TO CREATE
A COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING COURSE
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
FOCUSING ON HOW TO RESPOND TO
CHILD VICTIMS OF COMMERCIAL
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION.
ACCORDING TO NATIONAL TO US
STATISTICS AS OF A COUPLE YEARS
AGO THERE WERE OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY CASES OF SEX TRAFFICKING
OF MINORS.
ACCOUNTING FOR OVER THIRTY
PERCENT OF ALL THE SEX
TRAFFICKING CASES IN OUR STATE.
THESE NUMBERS ARE PRESUMED TO BE
LOW DUE TO UNDER IDENTIFYING IN
UNDER REPORTING.
POLICE OFFICER TRAINING SPECIFIC
TO COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED CHILDREN WILL HELP
INCREASE THE IDENTIFICATION AND
REPORTING. OF CHILD VICTIMS OF
SUCH SEXUAL EXPLOITATION TAKING
THE CHILD OUT OF ABUSIVE
SITUATIONS AND CONNECTING.
IN HER TO THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED.
CURRENTLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
ARE NOT AT OF FULLY TRAINED.
ON.
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED
CHILDREN.
I'M WORKING WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY IN HOPES
OF ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT THEY'VE RAISED
INCLUDING THE COST FACTORS.
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM SHOULD THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD TODAY.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OUR
JULIE MCCORMICK OF THE
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND.
HANA HAILEY FROM THE WEST COAST
CHILDREN'S CLINIC.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN JONES SAWYER
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THINK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY FOR
AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
A I AM JULIE MCCORMICK AN
ATTORNEY AND POLICY ASSOCIATE
WITH THE CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER
CALIFORNIA.
THE CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND CHILDREN UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE DEPENDENCY
COURT IN LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO
AND PLASTER COUNTIES.
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF HIM HAVE
BEEN SEXUALLY EXPLOITED. MY
COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE SEEN FIRST
HAND THE NEED FOR EFFECTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING ABOUT THE
CURSE COMMERCIAL SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION OF CHILDREN.
DECRIMINALIZATION ALONE IS NOT
SUFFICIENT AND MUST BE PAIRED
WITH AN ALTERNATE IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE AN ARRAY OF SERVICE
OPTIONS.
IN ORDER TO ROUTE TO REALIZE THE
FULL IMPACT OF RECENT POLICY
CHANGES LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
MUST UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANT
ROLE THEY PLAY. IN POSITIVELY
ALTERING THE COURSE OF
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED
CHILDREN'S LIVES.
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS AND
LOS ANGELES HAVE CONTINUALLY
STRESSED THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRAINING AND THE IMPACT TRAINING
HAS HAD AREN'T OFFICERS BEING
BETTER ABLE TO PROTECT VICTIMS.
WE SEEM FOR THE LOS ANGELES
FIRST RESPONDER PROTOCOL IS THAT
WHEN THESE CHILDREN INTERACT
WITH A TRAINED OFFICER WHO
UNDERSTANDS THEIR NEEDS AND
TRAUMA AND IS FOCUSED ON THEIR
SAFETY. IT RESULTS IN THE CHILD
BEING MORE RECEPTIVE TO SERVICES
AND INCREASES THE CHANCE THEY
WILL AVOID FURTHER ACTS.
EXPLOITATION.
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACKNOWLEDGES THE
TREMENDOUS VALUE IN THIS
APPROACH
THEY RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
MEETING THESE CHILDREN'S NEEDS.
AND ALSO THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BRING CASES AGAINST PROMINENT
TRAFFICKERS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REDUCE ADDITIONAL
VICTIMIZATION.
LASTLY A GROUP OF SURVIVOR
ADVOCATES WHO CONSULT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IDENTIFIED LACK OF
TRAINING AMONG LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS A SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT IN THE
STATE.
WE ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB
TWO NINE NINE TWO AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MY NAME
IS HANNAH HALEY ON THE POLICY
ASSOCIATED WEST COAST CHILDREN'S
CLINIC.
WEST COAST AS A CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH AGENCY BASED IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WE SERVE
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED USE PER YEAR
MOST OF WHOM ARE IN FOSTER CARE
AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE
WE'VE HAD A SPECIALIZED PROGRAM
FOR SEXUALLY EXPLOITED YOUTH.
WHICH HAS PROVIDED SERVICES TO
ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY USED EACH
YEAR.
INTO DOESN'T SIXTEEN WE ALSO
DEVELOPED INVALIDATED A
SCREENING TOOL TO IMPROVE
IDENTIFICATION OF SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED YOUTH WHICH IS NOW IN
USE IN NEARLY A HUNDRED AGENCIES
IN FIVE STATES.
AND WHICH WE'VE TRAINED OVER
FIVE THOUSAND PROFESSIONALS TO
USE.
MANY OF THE YOUTH THAT WE SERVE
DISTRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE
IN THE PAST INTERACTION WITH
BOND FORSTMANN OFTEN RESULTED IN
ARRESTS IN ON INCARCERATION. ONE
YOUNG YOUNG PERSON SAD BEING
ARRESTED REINFORCES THAT I'D BE
BETTER OFF STICKING WITH MY
EXPLOITER HE SAID THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN THAT I WOULD GO
TO JAIL IF I LEFT HIM AND THAT
NO ONE ELSE CARES.
BUT FROM OUR WORK PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO COUNTIES
TO CREATE INTER AGENCY PROTOCOLS
TO SERVE EXPLOITED YOUTH WE KNOW
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OUR
CRITICAL PARTNERS IN OUR EFFORTS
TO IDENTIFY AND PROTECT
EXPLOITED YOUTH.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS LAKE
NURSES SOCIAL WORKERS THERAPISTS
AND SCHOOL STAFF ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
ARE IN A PRIME POSITION TO
IDENTIFY EXPLOITED YOUTH AND GET
THEM HOW.
BUT THE EXISTING TRAINING IS TOO
BRIEF TO ADEQUATE ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS IDENTIFICATION
ENGAGEMENT AND PROTECTION OF
VICTIMS OF CHILD SEX
TRAFFICKING.
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION OCCURS IN
SHOWS UP VERY DIFFERENTLY FROM
WHAT WE TRADITIONALLY CONSIDER
SEXUAL ABUSE AND IT MERITS ITS
OWN TRAINING CONTENT.
WE HAVE NEW RESEARCH ON WHICH
INDICATORS BEST HELP US IDENTIFY
YOU TOUR EXPLOITER EXPLOITED AND
WE HAVE GROWING UNDERSTANDING
ABOUT EFFECTIVE INTERVENTIONS.
THE LAWS HAVE ALSO CHANGED AND
IT'S IMPORTANT THOSE BE
REFLECTED IN THE CURRENT
CURRICULA.
THIS BILL WOULD ADD TRAINING
TOPICS THAT FOCUS ON RECOGNIZING
THE SIGNS OF EXPLOITATION AND
GETTING USED HELP TO ENHANCE THE
EXISTING TRAINING.
AND TO FURTHER OUR COLLECTIVE
EFFORTS TO PROTECT YOU FROM
EXPLOITATION SO I RESPECTFULLY
URGE ARRIVAL AND APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUED ATTENTION ATTENTION TO
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE THINK THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YES CRISTINA CAVANAUGH PHONED
HER WAS SHARED HOPE
INTERNATIONAL IN SUPPORT ALSO
THE SACRAMENTO FRIENDS ANTI
TRAFFICKING GROUP SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WHEN THE WATER WITH CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANGELIQUE YORK WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DANIEL MAILLET CALIFORNIA LAND
TO CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY WITNESSES IN.
OPPOSITION.
CHAIR RYAN CHAIRMAN WITH THE
IRISH SUCH ASSOCIATION WE DON'T
HAVE A.
POSITION ON THIS WE SUPPORT THE
BILLING CONCEPT HOWEVER.
WORDS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FUNDING AND THE TIME THE WHOLE
TAKE TO TRAIN EVERYBODY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU HOPEFULLY TO SELF
SELECT THE SAME PICTURE.
ONE OF ANY THAT'S MISTER CHAIR
UP MISTER CHAIRMAN OF COURSE
ALSO ARAB OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE ARE
NOT IN OPPOSITION TO TRAINING.
WHERE NOT IN OPPOSITION TO
TRAINING ABOUT SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION OR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE FACT THIS IS ANOTHER
UNFUNDED MANDATE THAT REQUIRES
TRAINING?
WITHOUT ANY SORT OF.
AND NOTION OF WHAT IT COSTS NOT
ONLY TO THE COMMISSION ON POST.
TO DEVELOP THIS TRAINING.
BUT ALSO TO THE AGENCIES WHO
ARE.
GOING TO BE FORCED WITHOUT
FUNDING TO PAY FOR IT TO.
SEND OFFICERS.
TWO LOCATIONS TO TAKE THIS
TRAINING. TO HAVE OFFICERS
WORKED OVERTIME FOR THE BACKFILL
FOR THOSE OFFICERS WHO ARE OUT
DOING THE TRAINING. IT ALSO WILL
INCREASE THE MINIMUM LENGTH OF
THE BASIC ACADEMY WHICH ARE HE
STANDS AT SIX HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
HOURS AGAIN THAT'S A MINIMUM SO
WE'RE TALKING A MINIMUM SIXTEEN
WEEK ACADEMY ALREADY.
AND AND FRANKLY THERE IS
ALREADY TRAINING CONTEMPLATED.
IN THE EXISTING BASE ACADEMY
LEARNING DOMAINS NINE AND TEN
DEAL WITH.
SEX CRIMES AND CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN MAY REVERSE THE ORDER
THERE THERE ARE GUIDELINES BY
POST ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING
TRAINING. I'M SO THERE'S ALREADY
INFORMATION AND TRAINING
AVAILABLE.
THERE'S A VARYING DEGREE OF
MANDATES AS TO WHAT IS ALREADY
REQUIRED AND PERMITTED.
I I'M I'M HOPEFUL THAT THE
AUTHOR AND POST AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
FIND SOMETHING THAT.
.
COMES OUT OF THIS THAT IS NOT.
DUPLICATIVE AND.
HAS.
SOME RESPECT FOR THE NOTION
THAT THERE ARE UNFUNDED COST TO
THIS AND THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
SHOULD BE PROVIDING THAT
FUNDING BUT THAT ALWAYS SEEMS TO
BE AN AFTERTHOUGHT
UNFORTUNATELY.
SO I AGREE WITH YOUR CONCERNS
AS YOU HAVE STATED ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION.
THAT'S REALLY THE KEY HERE IS.
GETTING SOMETHING FUNDED AND
FORCING THE BILL AT THIS POINT
AS IT SITS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
DOES NOT CONTEMPLATE THAT SO WE
ASK YOU KNOW WHAT. THANK YOU.
BUT ANY.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS ARE.
TO QUIRK.
SAID THE OPPOSITION I'M. FIVE I
BELIEVE YOU REALIZE RAISES
IMPORTANT ISSUES. ARE YOU
WORKING WITH POST CURRENTLY YES
WE ARE WHERE WE'RE HAVING VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
POST.
WE'VE HAD CORDIAL PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE STATE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION.
AN I BELIEVE OUR GOALS ARE VERY
VERY SIMILAR WE'D LIKE TO
IMPROVE THE TRAINING.
WITHOUT ADDING SUBSTANTIAL COST
TO THE SYSTEM. AND THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND TRY TO FIND A
SWEET SPOT.
WHERE THAT CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED
OKAY SEAT WOULD YOU BE TRYING TO
KEEP THE SAME NUMBER OF HOURS
OPPOSE TRAINING THAT'S?
DEFINITELY THE BIGGEST COST
DRIVER I THINK POSSIBLY. ANSWER
QUIRK POSSIBLY.
I DON'T WANT TO MAKE A
COMMITMENT. TODAY ON THAT BUT I
I THINK THAT'S A A WORTHY GOAL
AND IT I BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
DOABLE.
SO ALSO POSSIBLE OKAY THANK YOU
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND YOU MAY CLOSE.
I I WILL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE AND.
AGAIN ALL REPEAT MY COMMITMENT
TO WORK WITH ALL THE PARTIES TO
TRY TO FIND THE BEST A.
THE BEST OF MY COMMON GROUND ON
THIS ON THIS BILL.
GREG I. BELIEVE MISTER QUIRK IS
GOING TO MOVE TO THE BILL UP
YET.
THANK OF BUT IT.
THIS IS AN AYE. AND IT.
BECAUSE THIS IS A POLICY
COMMITTEE.
OF I'M NOT OFF THE HOOK BECAUSE
I'M ON THE BUDGET SIDE BUT YOU
HAVE A FIVE YEAR AND SO IN THIS
GOES TO.
.
APPROPRIATIONS
YEAH WHICH YOU HAVE TO BE VERY
CONCERNED
WHEN YOU GET THERE THAT YOU HAVE
TO COME UP WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
FUNDING PLANET SOURCE.
SO THAT THAT'S ONE ASPECT OF SO
AYE WILL. OBVIOUSLY BE LOOKING.
AT HOW RISK IS FUNDED DONE BUT
EVERYTHING ON THE PROGRAM
ITSELF.
I WANT A BETTER PROGRAM I DON'T
WANT THIS PROGRAM VERSES THAT
PROGRAM LET'S.
COMBINE ALL THE BEST PRACTICES
INTO ONE PROGRAM ANIME EQUAL TO
THE NUMBER OF HOURS THERE WHAT
IS LEFT OUT. THAT YOU THINK
SHOULD BE AND THE ONE THAT'S
ALREADY GIVEN.
AT POST TRAINING. BAD BEFORE
FOR ME IS THE BEST
THE BEST TRAINING. NOT.
THIS ONE IS BETTER THAN THE
OTHER BUT WHAT ARE THE ON THE
PRINCIPLES AND THE POLICY IN THE
GUIDELINES THAT YOU NEED SO THAT
WHEN THEY GO OUT.
INTO THE FIELD ON DELTA BETTER
OFFICES PREDICTOR THEY'RE BETTER
WITH DEALING WITH TOM.
THIS THIS POPULATION AND SO. I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO HAVE A
REAL.
SKY XIN ABOUT WHAT THE ELEMENTS
ARE IN INDUSTRY PROGRAM.
SO THE CHURCH RECOMMEND AND I
GUARANTEE THAT'LL HAPPEN MISTER
CHAIR.
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TOO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I GOT A VIDEO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
MEASURES ON CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME.
AND NOW MISTER GIPSON.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR A. B.
THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN.
JAILS VOTER EDUCATION PROGRAM.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE.
FIFTEEN WHICH SEEKS TO INTRODUCE
THOSE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN COUNTY JAILS.
ON VOTER REGISTRATION AND
VOTERS RIGHTS IN HOPES THAT
HELPING THEM WILL FEEL MORE
CONNECTED TO THEIR COMMUNITY.
CALIFORNIA INCARCERATIONS EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN ITS JAILS AND
MORE THAN HALF OF THE PEOPLE
HAVE NOT BEEN CONVICTED OR ARE
ON THAT SENTENCE.
THIS IS A LARGE COMMUNITY THAT
HAS HISTORICALLY.
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND PARTICIPATION.
THERE IS OFTEN AN ASSUMPTION BY
MANY PEOPLE THAT IF YOU HAVE
BEEN INCARCERATED YOU HAVE LOST
YOUR RIGHT TO VOTE. ON DUE TO
EITHER.
MISINFORMATION OR LACK OF
INFORMATION MEDIA WHO ARE BEHIND
BARS DO NOT KNOW THEY CAN
REGISTER TO VOTE. CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES STATE AND LOCAL
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITIES TO
ASSIST IN VOTER REGISTRATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE AGE WHO ARE
WHO ARE OF AGE. AND ARE NOT
SERVING A FELONY SENTENCE THIS
BILL WILL.
ACTS SIMILAR PROVISIONS.
FOR ADULTS REQUIRING EACH
COUNTY JAIL TO ALLOW AT LEAST
ONE ORGANIZATION TO PROVIDE
VOTER EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THE
COUNTY JAIL. THE THE PROGRAMS
WOULD INCLUDE BUT NOT BE
LIMITED.
TO INFORMATION ABOUT VOTERS
RIGHTS PROVIDING A VOTER
REGISTRATION TO ELIGIBLE VOTERS
AND ASSISTING ELIGIBLE VOTERS IN
RETURNING A COMPLETED VOTER
REGISTRATION CARD ONTO THE
COUNTY OFFICIAL WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. IS
MISS ALICE HUFF BEEN OF THE
STATE PRESIDENT NWC P. AND ALSO
MISS ESTHER LIN.
WITH A CO YOU.
THANK YOU WHOEVER WANTS TO BE
FIRST HOME THAT MORNING THE
MOTORMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO.
BELOW MY HEADDRESS YOU ON
ASSEMBLY WILL CLOSER ANALOGIES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION THAT NAACP
CALIFORNIAN A CP AS FIFTY EIGHT
BRANCHES AND A WHOLE LOT A YOUTH
UNITS AND WE FUNCTION ACROSS THE
STATE. AND WE ALREADY ATTEMPT
TO DO SOME VOTER REGISTRATION
AND EDUCATION INSIDE OF LOCAL
JAILS.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE'S
INTEREST IN HAVING OUR MEMBERS
WHO ARE INCARCERATED LEARN A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
DEMOCRACY WHILE THEIR REQUESTS
WAITED MAYBE THEY'LL COME OUT
BETTER AND ABLE TO FUNCTION.
A ON THE OUTSIDE AND WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT WHILE THEY'RE
THERE THAT THEY STILL HAVE THEIR
RIGHTS.
GIVEN TO THEM TO PARTICIPATE
AND LEARN THAT DEMOCRACY IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND MAYBE IT'LL BE A
DETERRENT IN THE FUTURE AND THEY
WILL BE BETTER CITIZENS ON
OUTSIDE SO WE STRONGLY.
SPONSOR AND URGE AND I VOTE ON
THIS BILL WE THINK IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. AND THEM SO
WE ASK YOU TO VOTE ACT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TARA MEMBERS ESTHER
LIN DIRECTOR OF A SAY SO CAL
JAILS PROJECT BY MONITOR
CONDITIONS IN THE LA COUNTY
JAILS THE LARGEST JAIL IN THE
COUNTRY WITH OVER SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. OF WHICH FORTY
PERCENT ARE PRE TRIAL AND EIGHTY
PERCENT ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN OR
LATINO.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE RIGHT TO
REGISTERED INCARCERATED
COMMUNITIES LARGE EXCLUDED FROM
THE PROCESS DUE TO LACK OF
INFORMATION LIMITED ACCESS TO
VOTING MATERIALS. AND
INCONSISTENT AND BIG VOTING
POLICIES AND PRACTICES ALMOST
SIXTY TWO PERCENT INCARCERATED
POPULATIONS ELIGIBLE TO VOTE
WHICH MEANS AND LA COUNTY JAILS
ALONE THAT'S MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THE ACLU OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
UNLOCK THE BOW PROJECT WITH LA
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT THE
REGISTRAR'S OFFICE AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS WHO HAVE BEEN CLEARED
BY THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
HAVE REGISTERED OVER ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH MORE THAN
HALF BEING FIRST TIME
REGISTRANTS.
EDUCATION BEING A VITAL
COMPONENT TO INCREASING
ENGAGEMENT THAT'S WHY WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ONE
FIFTEEN. NOW BRIEFLY SHARED
THEIR EXPERIENCES FROM OUR
UNLOCK THE VOTE. AT MEN'S
CENTRAL JAIL WE FINISH
COMPLETING A YOUNG MAN'S
REGISTRATION PACKET FIRST TIME
WHEN HE RETURNED TO THE HOUSING
MAJEL HE WAS GREETED BY SOUNDS
OF CHEERS AND APPLAUSE BY STORM
MATES.
AT THE WOMEN'S FACILITY WE WERE
GREETED BY AUDIBLE YESES.
BECAUSE OF WHY WE TOLD THE
WONDER WHAT WHY WERE THERE AFTER
WE COMPLETED ONE WOMAN'S
REGISTRATION SHE HUGGED THE
VOTING MATERIALS CLOSER CHEST.
AND WITH THE BIG TO CSUS GRAN
AND TEARS IN HER EYES SHE SAID
YES I CAN FINALLY VOTE.
LASTLY AFTER A GIVEN UGLY
AFRICAN MAN TO UNLOCK THE VOTE
BROCHURE I STRETCHED OUT MY HAND
TO SHAKE HIS.
HINSON SHIRLEY TO BEND HIS WRIST
TOWARDS ME.
SO I COULD SEE HIS WRIST BAND
THEY DO THIS FREQUENTLY INSIDE
THE JAILS FOR COUNT TO GET THE
MEDICATIONS ARE VERIFY THEIR
NAME MATCHES OUR BOOKING NUMBER.
I TOLD MY DIDN'T TO SEE HAS
WRISTBAND I JUST WANT TO SHAKE
HIS HAND.
HE SAID.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT SUGAR HANDS
IT'S LIKE NO HUMAN CONTACT FOR
US IN HERE AFTER WE SHOOK HE
LOOKED AT ME AND SAID MISS
ESTHER. THANK YOU.
THESE ARE NOT UNIQUE OR EVEN
RARE OCCURRENCES AS THIS IS WHAT
WE SEE IN HERE EVERY DAY WHEN
WE'RE INSIDE THE JAILS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OF ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MARCO GEORGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT PAINTING IF YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S A SELF FILLER HERE PRETTY
BUSY DAY.
THOSE DAYS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CORSO'S ALONG BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION UP REGRETTABLY WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
WE'RE NOT AGAINST VOTER
EDUCATION OR.
.
ASSISTING PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE WITH VOTING I
THINK THIS BILL IDENTIFIES OR WE
WRITE EFFORT TO KEEP PROBLEMS
WITH THIS BILL ONE.
THE BILL DOES NOT RECOGNIZE ANY
INTERNAL EFFORTS AT VOTER
EDUCATION IN FROM IN INFORMING
INMATES ABOUT VOTING RIGHTS.
THAT MAY ALREADY EXIST AND SO
COUNTIES ARE ALREADY
UNDERTAKING.
PROGRAMS TO HELP IN MAKES VOTE
OFTENTIMES THEY WILL ASSIST WITH
GETTING REGISTRATION AFFIDAVIT
THEY WILL. TURN IT INTO THE
CLERK FOR THE INMATE THEY WILL
HAVE.
DAYS WHERE THE CLERK OF THE
COUNTY WILL COME TO THE FACILITY
AND GATHER REGISTRATION
AFFIDAVITS.
THEY WILL ALSO HAVE SIMILAR
EVENTS WHEN IT'S TIME TO VOTE SO
TO HELP RETURN A BALLOT BY MAIL
THEY'LL PAY FOR THE STAMP
SOMETIMES SOMETIMES IN MAY PAYS
FOR THE STAMP.
SOMETIMES THE CLERK WILL COME
DOWN TO COLLECT BALLOTS SO THEIR
RD EFFORTS ARE ON GOING ON THIS
IN THIS BILL SORT OF.
JUST GLOSSES OVER THE FACT THAT
THAT HAPPENS NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO.
THE BILL'S LANGUAGE I THINK IS A
LITTLE BIT TOO RESTRICTIVE IN.
THE CONTEXT OF MANDATING THAT A
GROUP BE ALLOWED ACCESS TO A
FACILITY SO THE SHERIFF HAS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CARE AND
CUSTODY OF THE INMATES. ARE BUT
ALSO FOR THE SAFETY OF THE
FACILITY AND STAFF AND THE BILL
SAYS IN ITS OWN WORDS BUT AT
LEAST ONE GROUP MAIN MUST BE
ALLOWED TO ENTER TO PERFORM THIS
VOTER EDUCATION. SO IN A STRICT
READING OF THE LANGUAGE OF ONLY
ONE GROUP WERE TO COME FORWARD
TO PROVIDE THAT SERVICE THE
SHERIFF IS OSTENSIBLY OBLIGATED
TO ALLOW THAT PARTICULAR GROUP
BEEN. IT DOESN'T TAKE ANY
ACCOUNT OF INSTITUTIONAL SAFETY
SO IF THERE'S AN ISSUE WITH THAT
PARTICULAR GROUP THAT SEEKING
ENTRY TO PROVIDE VOTER
EDUCATION.
THE BILL IS SILENT ON ANY SORT
OF AUTHORITY THAT THE SHERIFF
MIGHT HAVE.
PROTECT THE SECURITY OF THE
FACILITIES WE THINK AT THE VERY
LEAST THOSE TWO THINGS NEED TO
BE IDENTIFIED IN THE BILL OR
RELEASED REFERENCE.
.
AGAIN IT IT IT'S JUST I THINK
TOO STRICT IN THE LANGUAGE I
THINK THERE MIGHT BE A WAY
FORWARD BUT THE WAY THE BILL IS
TODAY WE'D ASK YOU KNOW WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY.
OTHER IN OPPOSITION OR ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE COURT.
UP CHAU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
.
I THINK YOU DO WELL TO RESPOND
TO THE SECURITY ISSUE. ARM.
THE AYE AND IF THEY WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT EFFORT TO BE DONE
ALREADY THAT'S EASY TO DO YOU
COULD PUT THAT IN THE FINDINGS.
BUT TO THE OPTICALLY TO THE
PROPONENTS WHAT SORT OF PROBLEMS
ARE YOU HAVING NOW GETTING INTO
JAILS WHAT EXACTLY IS THE NEED
FOR THE BELL.
MUSLIM.
SO IN LA ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND COALITION MEMBERS
ARE ACTUALLY TRAINED AND.
THERE'S A BACK ON CLEARANCE
PROCESS THAT THE LA SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT THEY CONDUCT
SO THEY DO A CUSTODY US SUPPORT
TRAINING THEY ALSO DO A A VERY
EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND. CHECK
PROCESS CONTRACTED TAKES BETWEEN
TWO WEEKS TO ONE AND A HALF
MONTHS FOR SOMETIMES A CLEARANCE
PROCESS TO BE DONE BUT ONCE THEY
ARE CLEAR THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
HAVE ENTRY INSIDE. TO THE JAIL
FACILITIES AND WE HAVE WORKED
VERY WELL WITH THE LA SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AT LEAST IN THAT
PROCESS. YET BUT SO. DO YOU HAVE
COUNTIES WHERE IT DOESN'T WORK
WELL WHAT IS THE NEED FOR THE
BILL BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S. IN
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO NECESSARILY
NAME NAMES BUT I THEIR HACK
COUNTIES WHERE YOU HAVE
DIFFICULTY. AND WHERE THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT YOU DO NOT
THINK IS DOING AN ADEQUATE JOB.
IN TERMS OF GETTING THE
REGISTRATION I I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT ISSUE
PARTICULARLY AS YOU GO TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
HE'S ALWAYS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT ISSUE THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION.
WE ARE SEEING VERY INCONSISTENT
PRACTICES ACROSS THE STATE IN
FACT JUST A AN ADJOINING.
COUNTY TO LA THEIR VERY
DIFFERING POLICIES IN FACT TWO
OF THE GOVERNMENT ENTITIES HAVE
OPPOSING POLICIES WHICH ADD TO
THE CONFUSION IN TERMS OF VOTING
RIGHTS AND VOTING ELIGIBILITY
BUT ALSO VOTING PROCESSES INSIDE
THE FACILITIES. SO THIS BILL I
THINK WOULD ALLOW FOR STANDARD
ACROSS THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT
YES THE RIGHT INFORMATION IS
BEING PROVIDED IN THE PROCESS
HE'S ARE CONSISTENT.
AND THAT'S BEEN AND SO I THINK
THE PURPOSE THAT THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THE OF THE BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'LL BE VOTING FOR
THE BELL.
MOVED THE BILL.
SECOND.
TO GIPSON YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M HAPPY TO
HEAR THAT THE SERB DEPARTMENT
IS.
A MASTERS PROGRAM THIS IS THIS
WILL COME ALONG ANY EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST I'M I THINK
IT'S IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
TRY TO HELP THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ONE. UNDERSTAND THOSE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ONE RICHARD
OPPONENT ALSO EXERCISE THEIR
VOTE.
WE DON'T WANT TO DO VOTER
SUPPRESSION THIS IS VOTER
EDUCATION.
OF THIS IS ALREADY WORKING
RIGHT NOW AND CERTAINLY THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AMID A FINE
ORGANIZATION NOT FIT TO COME IN
FOR SECURITY REASONS.
THEN WE WILL CERTAINLY LOOK FOR
ANOTHER ORGANIZATION THAT MEETS
THE CRITERIA AND MEETS
ACCEPTABILITY OF THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT BUT AGAIN IT THIS IS
I BELIEVE IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING
ON AND LOOKING FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO GET TO MAINSTREAM
THEM BACK INTO SOCIETY AND I
BELIEVE THIS IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO BY PROVIDING. WITH THEM
NOW TO THE VOTER EDUCATION BUT
ALSO VOTER REGISTRATION TO LET
THEM KNOW.
ONE THEIR SITTERS POSSIBILITIES
STILL THERE INTACT EXPRESSLY
BICU DON'T HAVE ANY FELONIES
YOU STILL ELIGIBLE TO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BOARD AYE VOTE.
AND THANK YOU AND JEFF
RECOMMENDING I AND I ALSO.
THINK AFTER YOU WERE EXPLAINING
WHAT THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
DOES.
I DON'T SPEAK FOR STATE SHERIFF
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY HAVE A
OF A PROCEDURE THAT MIGHT BE. AT
LEAST A START OF OF GIVING DE UM
LAW ENFORCEMENT SOME COMFORT
LEVEL.
ON ON HOW YOU IMPLEMENT THIS.
OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD MAKE SURE
THERE'S ENOUGH FUNDING AND WE WE
CAN GET THIS DONE. BUT ALSO I
WANNA REMIND.
THOSE OF US.
THAT GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS OF
GETTING ELECTED.
DIDN'T OVER OVER AGAIN YOU NEED
DIFFERENT GROUPS DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGIES TO GET PEOPLE NOW
AND TO REGISTER. BUT ACTUALLY
GET OUT
THE VOTE IS
IS A HERCULEAN TASK SOMETIMES
THAT'S WHY I'M IN THIS LAST
ELECTION GALECTIN PERCENT. OF
THE PEOPLE VOTING YOU HAD LIKE
PRECINCTS IN THE ASSEMBLY WHERE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
VOTED ON A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND REGISTERED.
WE NEED TO DO BETTER AND IN THE
MORE HANDS ADDED THAT THE
BETTER.
AND I I WILL TELL YOU IF I
DON'T. BELIEVE YOU'RE YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
IN A C. P. BUT THERE MAY BE SOME
GROUPS THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE DOWN. CAUSE MORE PROBLEMS
WHEN THEY COME IN.
VIA ESTABLISHMENT AND.
THEN BEFORE THEY CAME AND SO.
TO CHAIR SENSITIVE TO THAT AND
I BELIEVE THE AUTHOR IS VERY
SENSITIVE THAT.
AND I THINK YOU ARE TOGETHER YOU
CAN IRON OUT MOST OF WHAT YOU
WANT.
THE CHAIRS RECOMMEND AND I.
Q..
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO BE ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
CARILLO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
HIGHLY KNOW QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
THERE'S DON'T CALL.
THANK WAIT FOR THE MEMBERSHIP
IT.
THANK YOU.
I'M PATTERSON ARE AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY ONE.
I DON'T UNDER TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
AND MEMBERS.
I'M PRESENTING TODAY.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE.
WHICH WILL.
RESOLVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
OMISSIONS FROM LASH BE LAST
YEAR'S S. B. FIFTY FOUR.
THAT RESULTED IN SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT CRIMES BEING LEFT OUT OF
THE STATUTE THAT PERMITS
COMMUNICATION. BASED ON A
PERSON'S CRIMINAL HISTORY SECOND
THE BILL BY THE WAY A A. B.
THANK YOU A. B.. AT TWENTY NINE
THIRTY ONE.
WILL ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER TO COOPERATE.
WITH FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES IF.
AN INDIVIDUAL HAS BEEN
CONVICTED.
CERTAIN SERIOUS AND VIOLENT
CRIMES.
LIKE ASSAULTING A POLICE
OFFICER.
DOMESTIC.
BATTERY.
THE ANIMAL CRUELTY AND KNOWINGLY
VIOLATING
PROTECTIVE ORDERS.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO NOTIFY
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHEN SOMEONE IN THEIR CUSTODY
MEETS ONE OF THESE REQUIREMENTS
SO THAT IT WILL BE ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR WHEN OFFICERS ARE OR ARE
NOT AUTHORIZED.
TO COOPERATE WITH IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS.
AS IT STANDS TODAY SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT CRIMES WERE LEFT OUT OF
THAT STATUTE.
THAT PERMITS COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN AGENCIES BASED ON A
PERSON'S.
CRIMINAL HISTORY.
ESTABLISHING THE FULL HISTORY OF
A PERSON'S CRIMINAL BACKGROUND.
TO DETERMINE IF LOCAL AND STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT MAY COMMUNICATE
AND COOPERATE WITH FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
HAS BECOME AN AREA OF CONFUSION.
AND A. B. TWO NINE THREE ONE.
ATTEMPTS TO FIX THIS PROBLEM BY
CLARIFYING WHEN THIS
COMMUNICATION MAY OCCUR.
S. B. FIFTY FOUR HAS IMPEDED
COMMUNICATION COOPERATION AMONG
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
EVEN IN CASES WHEN SUCH
COMMUNICATION AND COOPERATION.
A BECAUSE OF THE CRIMINAL
HISTORY ARE CRUCIAL TO THE
SAFETY OF OUR OFFICERS.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND IN FACT
THE CRIMINAL SUSPECTS
THEMSELVES.
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES ARE NOT
GOING TO AND THEIR ATTEMPTS TO
REMOVE VIOLENT CRIMINALS WHO ARE
HERE ILLEGALLY SB FIFTY FOUR
CANNOT CHANGE THAT.
BUT THE QUESTION BEFORE US IS
WHETHER WE WOULD HAVE THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
WHEN THEY ARE KNOWN TO HAVE
COMMITTED SERIOUS OR VIOLENT
CRIMES.
APPREHENDED IN PROCESSED IN A
SECURED JAIL FACILITY.
OR OUT ON THE STREETS
WHERE VIOLENCE MAY HAPPEN.
AND THIS REALLY MEANS THAT THE
INSTEAD OF GOING TO THE SAFE
LOCALE.
AVE SECURE JAIL FACILITY.
THESE IMMIGRATION OFFICERS ARE
BEING FORCED INTO NEIGHBORHOODS
AND IN TWO. ABOUT CIRCUMSTANCES
IN WHICH THOSE WHO.
HAVE COMMITTED THESE CRIMINAL
ACTS.
DON'T WANT TO BE. CAUGHT.
AND THEY WILL BE ON THE RUN AND
THEY MAY VERY WELL BE AND
CIRCUMSTANCES AS WE HAVE SEEN
WHICH CREATES A. REAL SAFETY
ISSUES THAT ARE OUT
NEIGHBORHOODS THEMSELVES.
A AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE WILL
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER.
AND ALLOW OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO FULFILL. THEIR DUTY
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS IN THE
SAFE SECURED ENVIRONMENT OF A
JAIL FACILITY. IN WHICH WE HAVE
KNOWN.
.
A CRIMINALS HERE ILLEGALLY WHO
HAVE COMMITTED. THESE VERY
SPECIFIC CRIMES.
SO HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS COREY SALCEDO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION.
BUT I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CORSO'S OVER HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WITH THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
THIS BILL.
BUT LET ME FIRST START BY SAYING
THAT SHERIFF'S AND FROM MY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DO NOT ENGAGE IN
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT WE'VE
TRIED TO MAKE THAT POINT CLEAR
DURING THE PENDENCY OF S. B.
FIFTY FOUR. WE DON'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY OF THE RESOURCES TO DO
IT THERE'S NOT A WILL TO ENGAGE
IN IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
SO THE NOTION THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
PLUCKS THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PLUGS PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR HOMES ARE PLACES OF WORK.
BASED ON IMMIGRATION VIOLATIONS
JUST ISN'T THE FACT.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A MEASURED
AND THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED THAT WILL
JEOPARDIZE PUBLIC SAFETY.
AS WE KNOW IN ARE OPPOSITION TO
SB FIFTY FOUR THE LIST OF
CRIMES.
THAT ALLOWS US TO COMMUNICATE
HAS SIGNIFICANT OMISSIONS WE
THINK WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE ABOUT PERSONS IN OUR
JAILS WHO HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OF
CRIMES LIKE ASSAULTING A PEACE
OFFICER DOMESTIC BATTERY.
ANIMAL CRUELTY JUST TO NAME A
FEW.
WILL ALSO THINK WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
FROM KNOWN MS THIRTEEN GANG
MEMBERS WHO ARRESTED FOR WEAPONS
CHARGE BUT UNFORTUNATELY SB
FIFTY FOUR PRECLUDES THAT TYPE
OF COMMUNICATION AGAIN.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT HOLDING
ANYBODY WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
LENGTH IN THE PERIOD OF TIME WE
CAN HOLD SOMEBODY. WE DO NOT
HONOR DETAINEES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT ASK US TO HOLD A
PERSON PASSED WHEN THEY WOULD
OTHERWISE NORMALLY BE LAWFULLY
RELEASE.
BUT WHAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR IS
SOME.
I THINK NOTION THAT THERE ARE
OFFENSES THAT WERE OMITTED FROM
S. B. FIFTY FOUR THAT WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE ABOUT.
THIS BILL MERELY ADDS SERIOUS
AND VIOLENT OFFENSES THAT WERE
OMITTED.
IT ATTEMPTS TO GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOME HELP WHEN IT
COMES TO IDENTIFYING THE PEOPLE
IN JAILS WHO HAVE THE REQUISITE
CRIMINAL HISTORY.
OR ARREST.
WE WANT TO BE SURE WE
COMMUNICATE ABOUT DANGEROUS
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN OUR JAILS IT'S
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN OUR JAILS. WHO
HAVE BEEN ARRESTED FOR SPECIFIC
CRIMES OR WHO HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF
CRIMES?
ARE WE DON'T WANT TO COMMUNICATE
ABOUT PEOPLE THAT WE CAN'T
COMMUNICATE ABOUT RESPECT THE
LAW FOLLOW S. B. FIFTY FOUR. ARE
BUT WE ALSO THINK THAT THERE IS
A NEED TO.
GIVE US SOME HELP WHEN IT COMES
TO MAKING SURE WE DON'T UNDER OR
OVER COMMUNICATE WITH FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES.
WE THINK THIS IS A MODEST EFFORT
BASED ON SOUND POLICY.
THE KEEPS S. B. FIFTY FOUR
LARGELY INTACT WHILE ADDRESSING
THE I'D THE DEFICIENCIES WE'VE
IDENTIFIED. AND WE'RE CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
AND HOPE THAT THERE IS SOME
MIDDLE GROUND THAT.
GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MOVE FORWARD AND CONTINUE THIS
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION.
THIS COMMITTEE ROUTINELY.
LOOKS AT BILLS AND AND SAYS HEY
WE KNOW WE MAY NOT BE THERE YET
BUT LET'S LET'S TRY TO MOVE
FORWARD ON SOMETHING WHERE FOLKS
WE THINK WE CAN AGREE.
I THINK THAT'S THE OPPORTUNITY
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TODAY IS TO IS
TO HAVE SOME.
CONSIDERATION OF THE FACT THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE IN THAT AGAIN
WE'RE NOT SEEKING OUT RIGHT
REPEAL BUT BUT LOOKING TO
MODESTLY ADDRESS IDENTIFIED
CONCERNS AND SO WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IT'S MORE ABOUT GOD MISTER CHAIR
RIGHT CHEN WITH RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT WE HAVE NO
INTEREST AT ALL IN BEING.
INVOLVED IN IMMIGRATION.
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS HOWEVER WE
ARE VERY CONCERNED THAT SOME OF
THESE CRIMES THAT WERE OMITTED.
INVERT LEE FROM S. B. FIFTY
FOUR WE LOOK AT THIS IS IT'S
KIND OF A SIMPLE CLEAN UP BILL
AND WE HEARD YOUR SUPPORT
THINKING.
ANY WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
MY INGRAM LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY
WITH THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY HERO POSE AB TWENTY
NINE. THIRTY ONE BECAUSE IT
EXPANDS THE QUALIFYING
CONVICTIONS AND SETS UP A
PROCESS FOR DOJ TO COMMUNICATE
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ABOUT THE.
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
CAME TOGETHER LAST YEAR DOING
ACT SB FIFTY FOUR BECAUSE THE
CONTINUED ENTANGLEMENT OF LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT. WITH FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT WAS
UNDERMINING PUBLIC SAFETY. AND
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES WHERE FEEL
FOR ALL OF REPORTING CRIMES AS
DOCUMENTED IN THE ANALYSIS THERE
ARE STUDIES SHOWING THE DROP. IN
LATINO COMMUNITIES REPORTING
CRIMES AS A RESULT OF THIS
ENTANGLEMENT.
THERE WAS A ROBUST PUBLIC
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE QUALIFYING
CONVICTIONS SUCH BE INCLUDED IN
S. B. FIFTY FOUR THERE IS. IN
TENS PUBLIC DEBATE ABOUT IT AND
ROBUST DIALOGUE IN NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
BY ADDING THESE NEW QUALIFYING
CONVICTIONS THIS BILL UNDERMINES
THE CAREFUL BALANCE THAT WAS
STRUCK WITH THAT BILL LAST YEAR.
WE DON'T THINK THERE'S A
RATIONALE FOR REQUIRING THE DOJ
TO EXPEND RESOURCES. TO CREATE
THE SYSTEM TO NOTIFY AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES MAY
BOOK SOME OF QUALIFYING
CONVICTIONS THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
CRIMINAL HISTORY WHEN THAT BOOK
AND FINGERPRINT SOMEONE. THEY
ALSO THINK INDEMNIFICATION FOR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. IS
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE THE
COOPERATION AUTHORIZES
COMPLETELY DISCRETIONARY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THINK YOU. THINK.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ARE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS CHRISTOPHER GALIANO
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MIGRANT POLICY
CENTER.
PASSED SEVERAL YEARS AGO LOS
ANGELES RESIDENT WHOSE NAME I
WILL NOT BE SHARING FOR REASONS
RELATED TO PRIVACY CONCERNS CALL
NINE ONE ONE FREE HELP DURING A
DOMESTIC DISPUTE.
WHEN POLICE ARRIVED THEY
DEMANDED SHE SPEAKING ENGLISH
AND ASKED WHETHER SHE HAD A
GREEN CARD.
THEY ARRESTED HER RATHER THAN
HER ABUSIVE BOYFRIEND EVEN
THOUGH SHE HAD BRUISES ON HER
BODY DEMONSTRATING SHE HAD BEEN
ATTACKED FEELING OVERWHELMED SHE
FAINTED. AND AT THE TIME OF
ARREST AT THE HOSPITAL A DOCTOR
EXAMINED HER FOUND BRUISES AND
RELEASED HER WITH PAPERWORK
SAYING SHE WAS A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIM. BUT POLICE TOOK
HER INTO CUSTODY ANYWAY WHEN SHE
WAS BOOKED HER FINGERPRINTS
TRIGGERED AN ICE HOLE.
.
WHICH STORIES LIKE THESE IT IS
NOT A SURPRISE THAT AT TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN STUDY FOUND
THAT SEVENTY PERCENT OF
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WERE
LESS LIKELY TO CALL POLICE IF
THEY WERE VICTIMS OF A CRIME.
THESE AND SIMILAR EXPERIENCES
I'D NEEDLESSLY DAMAGED THE TRUST
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
HAVING LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PLACE
IMPERIL THE SAFETY OF COMMUNITY
AT THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
MOST LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AGREE THEY DON'T WANT TO SERVE
AS IMMIGRATION AGENTS YET
OPENING THE DOOR OF ENTANGLEMENT
BETWEEN POLICE AND SHERIFFS IN
THE DEPORTATION PROCESS AS THIS
BILL.
.
TRIES TO FURTHER DO PUTS ARE IN
JEOPARDY A CRIME SURVIVORS
WITNESSES AND OTHERS AT RISK AND
FURTHER UNDERMINES COMMUNITY
CONFIDENCE AND WASTE LIMITED
STATE AND LOCAL RESOURCES.
I THE REALIZE TRUST ACTING
CALIFORNIA VALLEY'S ACT ARE
IMPORTANT TOOLS IN BUILDING
TRUST AND COMMUNITIES AB TWO
NINE THREE ONE SEVERELY
UNDERMINES THESE TOOLS AND PUTS
OUR COMMUNITY SAFETY AT RISK.
I JUST FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
AND GIVEN ENOUGH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
JOHN OPPOSITION.
PAUL FOCUS IF JUSTICE COALITION
FROM THE OPPOSING.
ROSE CON IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER WE OPPOSE HIM
ALSO APPEARING ON BEHALF OF
TRAILER WHO ALSO OPPOSES.
MARCO GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
YOU.
ANY.
QUESTION FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MICHAEL.
WELL FIRST OF ALL.
.
THE THE IDEA THAT THIS
BODY.
UP PRODUCES COMPLETE AND PERFECT
LEGISLATION TIME AND TIME OUT.
IS EVIDENCE THAT.
TO BE FAULTY GIVEN THE LARGE
NUMBER OF TIMES THAT THERE ARE
FIX IT BILLS AND THAT THERE ARE.
CLEAN UP BILLS
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO DO HERE.
BUT THESE ARE CRIMES WERE. OF.
INTENTIONALLY OMITTED BECAUSE
THEY.
ROSE TO THE LEVEL OF CONCERNS
THAT WOULD WAS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION I THINK IS PATENTLY
WRONG.
IF THAT WERE THE CASE THAT
WOULD BE A WHOLE SERIES OF.
OF OF OCT. CRIMES INSIDE FIFTY
FOUR THAT OUGHT TO BE REMOVED
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ASSAULTING A POLICE OFFICER
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ANIMAL
CRUELTY.
THINGS OF THIS NATURE AND I
THINK THAT THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
THAT DEPICTED THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT WERE BROUGHT.
CLEARLY INDICATED WHAT THE BILL
ATTEMPTS TO DO AND WHAT IT IS IT
DOES NOT ATTEMPT TO DO.
AND SO I'M ASKING CONSIDERATION.
AND AYE VOTE HERE FOR THE CLEAR
AND OBVIOUS REASONS THAT THERE
WERE UNINTENTIONAL OMISSIONS
THAT SHOULD BE BUILT BACK.
BUT INTO SB FIFTY FOUR WE DO
THAT ON A REGULAR BASIS WITH
OTHER BILLS.
I DON'T THINK WE CAN SUGGEST
THAT EVERYTHING THAT COMES OUT
OF THIS LEGISLATURE IS PERFECT
THAT.
AFTER IT BECOMES LAW WE FIXED
THESE KINDS OF OVERSIGHTS.
REPEATEDLY.
AND ARE ALSO ONE THAT.
THAT AGAIN REITERATED THIS THIS
COMES FROM BEING A.
EIGHT YEARS MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF FRESNO APPEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE LONGTIME RESIDENTS
OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND
FRESNO.
THE DISRUPTION IN THE ABILITY.
FOR THE IMMIGRATION A
ENFORCEMENT.
TO.
GO TO THE JAIL AND TO PROCESS
AND TO DEAL WITH THESE WHO HAVE.
COMMITTED THESE KINDS OF CRIMES.
LITERALLY FORCES THE
IMMIGRATION.
PEOPLE TO GO OUT INTO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND DO THE KINDS OF
THINGS. THAT RESEMBLE AND LOOK
LIKE RATES
WE HAVE HAD.
LOTS OF OTHER EVIDENCE OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE GOTTEN.
OUT.
ICE IS GONE AFTER THEM. THEY
HAVE.
BRIAN.
A VIOLENCE HAD BEEN HAS ENSUED.
HIGH SPEED CHASES HAVE BEEN
SUED.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO BE
SAFE FOR EVERYBODY?
THOSE WHO HAVE.
THE CONVICTION.
THOSE WHO ARE PRESENTLY AT THE
JAIL AND SHOULD BE
APPROPRIATELY.
A PROCESSED IN THE JAIL
ENVIRONMENT SO THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE THE RISK TO SAFETY HEALTH.
IT IN THE COMMUNITIES OUT AS A
RESULT.
THESE ARE A CO EQUAL IN VALUE TO
THE OTHER.
A VIOLENT CRIMES THAT WERE.
IT IN INCLUDED IN.
.
AB FIFTY FOR SO FOR THESE
REASONS.
WERE ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
I THIS DOES NOT DAMAGE OR
DESTROY FIFTY FOUR AS AS IS
BEING SUGGESTED. IT DOES ADD A
FEW MORE BETTER OBVIOUSLY
VIOLENT. AND.
SETUP.
THEY'VE MUCH MORE SAFE AND AND.
.
POPE PROCESSING OF ALL OF THIS.
ARE IN ORG ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH.
EVERYONE IS SAFE.
TO DO OTHERWISE IS REALLY
PUTTING A LOT OF PEOPLE AT RISK
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS TO THESE
HIGH SPEED CHASES INTO THE
REACTION.
THAT SOME WOULD HAVE WITH WITH
BEING. OF.
BUT.
IT HAVING DIFFICULTY WITH
IMMIGRATION AND AND AND HAVE
SOME ISA.
.
WHAT INTO THE?
APPREHENDED. AT
AGAIN IT DOESN'T NOTHING.
A.
TO UNDO FIFTY FOUR.
I'M SURPRISED THAT.
THE OTHERS DON'T RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE ARE. VIOLENT ACTS THAT FIT
WELL WITH ALL OF THE OTHERS THAT
WERE IN.
FIFTY FOUR AS WELL SO I THINK.
TO SAY NOTED THIS BILL IS TO
BASICALLY SAY NO TO.
.
TO WHAT TO A SELECTIVE.
NOTION THAT.
WE GET IT RIGHT THE FIRST TIME
AND THAT THESE.
CRIMINAL ACTS
A RELATIVELY MEANINGLESS I DON'T
THINK THEY'RE MEANINGLESS
WHATSOEVER.
FOR THOSE REASON I'M ASKING FOR
A AND I VOTE. THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
FOR FOR BRINGING THIS TO OUR
ATTENTION AND LET ME. MAYBE
QUICKLY TRY TO EXPLAIN WHAT
DION.
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS WERE
WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER DO
WISH. THERE WAS A BILL ON DNA
AND DNA TESTING AND RIGHT NOW WE
DO IT FOR FELONIES.
AND SOMEONE CAME A MEMBER CAME
TO.
OPEN IT UP DNA FOR EVERYONE.
INCLUDING SOME OF THE.
OFFENSES THAT YOU HAVE IN YOUR
BILL.
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
ACTUALLY LOOKED AT SERIOUS
MISDEMEANORS.
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT THOSE
SERIOUS MISDEMEANORS TERRIFIC
DIRECT CORRELATION THAT THEIR
NEXT STEP WOULD BE A FELONY.
AND THIS COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED
PUTTING THOSE.
AND THERE
UNFORTUNATELY THE AUTHOR DID NOT
MOVE FORWARD WITH THOSE
SUGGESTIONS
AND THE BUILDING MOVE FORWARD.
AND SO.
BUT PETTY THEFT.
.
JUMPING FROM SHOPLIFTING TO BUT.
THIS IS.
SERIOUS.
VIOLENT CRIME THAT AND THAT THAT
WILL THE FLOW MUCH.
.
DRUNK DRIVING YES YOU COULD YOU
COULD INJURE SOMEONE BUT.
DRUNK DRIVING ISN'T AND A SERIES
OF VIOLENT.
BUT STRANGULATION MURDER.
I WOULD EVEN CONSIDER.
LOOKING AT OUR ASSAULTING A
POLICE OFFICER AS SOMETHING VERY
SERIOUS THAT WE PROBABLY SHOULD.
LOOK AT AND WOULD HAVE PROBABLY
WORKED WITH YOU ON ON THAT OR
EVEN THE CHEMICAL AGENT PART OF
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S.
THAT COULD BE VERY SERIOUS BUT
AS IT IS WRITTEN NOW ON I HAVE
TO RECOMMEND NO. AND AND I'M
JUST TRYING TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF HOW.
WE DO BOMB.
I USE OR COMPROMISE WE DO TRY TO
FIND.
AREAS WHERE IT ACTUALLY MAKES
SENSE OF WHY YOU WANT TO DO THAT
ALL THE THINGS YOU LISTED IN
HERE.
DON'T.
I DON'T MAKE SENSE AND ACTUALLY.
ARE AGAINST WHAT. SB FIFTY FOUR
BUT ABOUT AND IN FACT IT THINK
IT MAKES IT EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
FOR.
IMMIGRANTS AND OTHERS SIMON HAD
THE BILL. THAT IF YOU BROUGHT A
CRIME.
TO.
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT YOU
COULD NOT HAVE YOU IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
QUESTION AND HOPEFULLY AND
STUFF LIKE HOPEFULLY SUCH SEE
TRENDING UP OF IMMIGRANTS
REPORTING CRIMES NOW AGAINST
THEM BUT OTHERS.
SO THERE'S THERE'S JUST BALLOTS
WE NEED TO GET TO AND I AGREE
WITH YOU THERE IS A BALANCE WE
NEED TO GET TO.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY.
THE ITEMS THAT YOU NAMED.
DON'T GET US THERE SO
UNFORTUNATE CHAIRS RECOMMENDING
AND A NO VOTE.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY. LACKEY I
GOT REAL.
CAMBIADO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURES DON'T CALL.
NOW MR STONE.
OBSERVERS TO STONE WITH FIRST
ANY NEEDS.
THE NAME OF AT THE TOP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND.
MEMBERS EVERY INMATE AT CDC ARE
HAS AN INMATE TRUST ACCOUNT AND
CURRENTLY THE WAY THE LAWS ARE
WRITTEN IS THEY ARE CONSIDERED
INDIGENT IF THEY HAVE LESS THAN
A DOLLAR. IN THAT ACCOUNT FOR
THIRTY DAY PERIOD. ONCE THEY
BECOME INDIGENT UNDER THAT
DEFINITION THEY HAVE ACCESS TO.
SUNDRIES TOILETRIES BASIC
SUPPLIES THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
TO PURCHASE THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
AND ALL IS WELL AS POSTAGE OTHER
WAYS OF COMMUNICATING OUTSIDE
BOTH THE COURTS TO FAMILY
MEMBERS AND TO OTHERS WHAT THIS
BILL DOES WOULD DO WOULD RAISE.
THAT ONE DOLLAR TO TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS SO THAT IF AN INMATE
HAS.
LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS IN
THEIR ACCOUNT FOR PERIOD OF
THIRTY DAYS THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO BE DECLARED INDIGENT AND HAVE
ACCESS TO THOSE BENEFITS WITHIN
CDC ARE. THIS IS.
UPDATING WHAT'S BEEN ARE A LONG
STANDING POLICY AND IT'S PART OF
GIVING INMATES ACCESS TO
RESOURCES WHILE THEY'RE ON THE
INSIDE AND HOPEFULLY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. GIVE THEM THE
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE. AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THINK OF THE BILL SECOND.
WE HAVE WITNESSES YUP WITNESSES.
I'M.
MORNING CHAIR MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DEAR
JOE WILSON.
I REPRESENT CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR WOMEN PRISONERS COSPONSORED
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY THREE THE
DIGNITY AND CARE ACT AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE.
I WAS INCARCERATED MY SELF IN
THE CDC OUR SYSTEM FROM TWO
THOUSAND TO TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
I'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF CCW FEEL
THE LAST DECADE.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU FROM MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS
FROM WHAT WE LEARNED FROM
VISITING SEVERAL HUNDRED WOMEN
AND TRANSGENDER PRISONERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S PRISON EVERY
TWO TO THREE MONTHS?
IS THAT LIFE AS A PRISONER IS A
DEEPLY DEHUMANIZING EXPERIENCE.
RAISING THE INDIGENT SEE
THRESHOLD FROM ONE DOLLAR TO
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS INSURES THAT
PEOPLE WITH MINIMAL FUNDS CAN
ACCESS MEDICAL CARE DENTAL CARE.
MENTAL HEALTH CARE HYGIENE
SUPPLIES AND MATERIALS FOR
ACCESSING THE COURTS WHO ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO
SURVIVE.
IT ALSO ADDRESSES THE SHAME AND
DEPRIVATION THAT MANY PEOPLE
FEEL FOR RELYING ON OUTSIDE
SUPPORT.
ON OR HAVING TO FOREGO BASIC
NEEDS ALL TOGETHER.
BY RAISING THE THRESHOLD OF
IMAGES FROM ONE DOLLAR TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS TWENTY THOUSAND
PRISONERS WILL NO LONGER. HAVE
TO MAKE CHOICES LIKE.
I HAVE FIVE DOLLARS ON MY BOOKS.
WHICH MAKES ME TOO RICH.
TO QUALIFY FOR ENERGY SUPPLIES.
OF BASIC HYGIENE PRODUCTS AND
LOOKS AND STAMPS.
SO DO I WRITE MY CHILDREN.
OR DONE BY A BAR OF SOAP TO KEEP
CLEAN WITH.
OR DO I KEEP THAT FIVE DOLLARS.
AVAILABLE IN CASE I NEED TO SEE
A DOCTOR AND PAY A FIVE DOLLAR
COPAY.
THE INCREASE IN THE INDIGENTS
THRESHOLD ALLOWS REASONABLE AND
FAIR AMOUNT OF BREATHING ROOM.
FOR THE TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WOULD AFFECT.
TO MANAGE ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT
BURNING FAMILIES ARE HEADED FOR
WILL BASIC NEEDS ALTOGETHER.
WE RECEIVED THIS LETTER IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
THREE FROM A WOMAN AT CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION.
FOR WOMEN.
IT'S BILLS OUT THE REALITY ONE
LESS THAN IN TO CHET AND
YOU CAN'T BUY ANYTHING WITH A
DOLLAR INSIDE OR OUTSIDE.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO READ JUST
A COUPLE OF STATEMENTS FROM
FOLKS. INSIDE OF THEM.
THIS ONE I THOUGHT WAS
REALLY INTERESTING THAT SHE
WRITES AT THIS ONE DOLLAR LESS
RESULTS IN POTENTIAL VIOLENCE.
AND DAMAGE TO WOMEN'S SELF
ESTEEM BECAUSE YOUR TEASE THE TO
SMELL SO TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
ALSO FACE INSIDE IS.
THE FACT THAT THE MATERIALS VOTE
THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY'RE GIVEN
TO CHOOSE FROM MORE OFTEN AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE NOT QUALITY
PRODUCTS.
SO FOR SOME OF THE WOMEN IN THE
ROOM YOU GUYS CAN PROBABLY
RELATE TO USING A KOTEX OR
TAMPON THAT'S THAT'S REALLY NOT
ANY GOOD FOR YOU AND THEN YOU'D
YOU'VE GOT. PIECES OF IT COMING
OUT OF YOU ALONG WITH BLOOD
CLOTS BECAUSE YOU CAN'T AFFORD
TO BUY ANY CALL PRODUCTS SO THIS
IS OUTSIDE.
INSIDE IT'S WORSE IT REALLY IS
WORSE I'M NOT A FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PERSON THAT I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH PEOPLE IN THE
PRESENTS FOR TEN YEARS WOMEN
SPECIFICALLY. AND ALL OF THIS IS
JUST REALLY NOT OKAY WE EXPECT
THESE PEOPLE TO COME OUT AND
HAVE SOME KIND OF SENSE OF
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY WHERE.
THEY'VE HAD TO FIGHT OR
OTHERWISE JOCKEY AROUND FOR
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS A BAR
SOAP OR TOOTHPASTE OR A RECALL
THAT YOUR CREAM. ARM AND I AM
GONNA IF IT'S OKAY TO WRITE HER
UP A COUPLE SECONDS OKAY.
I THIS IS JUST SOMETHING THAT
WAS WRITTEN BY SOMEONE INSIDE AS
SHE WRITES INMATES.
WORKING FOR EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR
THIS IS NOT AN EXAGGERATION. I
NOT EVEN ENOUGH TO BUY FLOUR
DOLLAR IN MY TRUST MAKES ME TOO
RICH INDIGENT KIT IS OUT OF MY
REACH.
GET TO BUY MY OWN TOOTHBRUSH A
WHERE MOST PRISONS HAVE TO
PAY ALMOST FIFTY PERCENT. OF
WHATEVER THEY MAKING RESTITUTION
AND IF YOUR IF YOUR INCOME IS
TWENTY SIX DOLLARS A MONTH OR
LESS.
AND WE'RE ASKING THAT IT BE NO
AND I.
YOU KNOW WHAT DO YOU WHAT DO YOU
EXPECT.
KEEPING THE LOCKER INTO BEER
ENCOURAGES EVERYONE TO DO SOME
KIND OF HUSTLE.
REGARDLESS IF IT ENDS IN SOME
TYPE OF TUSSLE SHE WRITES TUSSLE
WE KNOW THERE'S VIOLENCE IN THE
PRISONS AND SO I WOULD JUST SAY
TO BE RESPONSIBLE.
THANK YOU TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
NOT A LOT OF MONEY.
THANK YOU THAT EARLIER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARGOT ADLER PRICES TO GO UP.
YEAH.
I'M MARGO GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THINK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE QUESTION FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISTER QUIRK.
GERMAN INFLATION ADJUSTER ON
THIS.
NO I WOULD SUGGEST YOU DO
OTHERWISE KILL SOMEBODY ELSE'S
GOING TO COME IN AND TEN YEARS
IN WANNA. MAKE IT FIFTY DOLLARS
WHATEVER. SO I I JUST SUGGEST
YOU ADD THAT.
THE OTHER THING IS THIS ISN'T
AWFUL SYSTEM.
I SUPPOSE THERE'S THERE'S SOME
REASON THAT YOU HAVE TO BUY
AROUND SO BUT.
.
MAYBE THERE WERE. WORRIED ABOUT
PEOPLE EATING IT I DON'T HOW.
.
THIS JUST SOUNDS AWFUL ARMED
GUARDS PRISON IS BUT.
YOU KNOW.
THAT THE BASICS ARE NOT PROVIDED
TO YOU.
YOU WOULD THINK FOR EXAMPLE THAT
YOU KNOW THE AVERAGE PERSON
COULD GET AT LEAST.
ONE BAR OF SOAP A MONTH GIVEN
HOW LITTLE THEY EARN.
AND MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
TWO OF US COULD WORK ON NEXT
YEAR.
I THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS THAT
THINGS LIKE.
TOOTHBRUSHES.
SO AT CETERA HAVE TO BE
PURCHASED.
YOU KNOW.
I THINK THERE OUGHT TO BE. SOME
SORT OF.
.
A MONTHLY ALLOWANCE FOR. THINGS
LIKE SOAP AND.
TOOTHBRUSHES ETCETERA THANK YOU.
THEY'RE NOT IN IRAQ QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE WITH SYSTEM
THANK YOU ED AND I COMPLETELY
AGREE IF YOU'RE A WEALTHY IN MAY
WHICH MEANS YOU HAVE A DOLLAR OR
MORE IN YOUR ACCOUNT. THEN YOU
ARE IN FACT RESPONSIBLE TO BUY
YOUR OWN SUNDRIES. IF YOU HAVE
LESS THAN.
YOU GET IT FROM THE STATE. AND
YOU HAVE TO REQUEST FOR YOU HAVE
TO REQUESTED.
YEAH IT'S A CHALLENGE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING THE CDC ARE ON THIS WILL
CERTAINLY TALK I'M VERY
INTERESTED IN AN ESCALATOR OR
SEEING IF THERE'S A MORE HUMANE
WAY. TO GO ABOUT THIS
ESPECIALLY FOR THE ACCESS TO
THIS REPRESENTS THE
COMMUNICATIONS THAT REPRESENTS
AND HYGIENE. THAT IT REPRESENTS
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THAT IN MY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARCHERS RECOMMEND AYE VOTE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE CARILLO
CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
A MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU.
AND.
THANK YOU MISTER FLOOR FOR
LETTING MS EGGMAN COME NEXT.
ITEM TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR THINK YOU'RE
SECURE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU TO
MY NEIGHBOR FROM THE SOUTH FOR
LETTING ME. COME IN FRONT OF HIM
TODAY.
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE HERE
WITH YOU TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
AND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS. AND THE CHAIR FOR HIS WORK
AND WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS TODAY AS PRESENTED.
EVERY DAY.
EVERY DAY EVERY MONTH CBO CDC
ARE.
RELEASES ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS FROM PRISON BACK
INTO SOCIETY.
OFTENTIMES AS PEOPLE WE WE
DON'T WANT TO COME BACK IN A
PRISON WE WANT THEM TO STAY OUT
TO BE SUCCESSFUL TO GET JOBS TO
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES AND THEN
TAKE THEIR RIGHTFUL PLACE IN
SOCIETY. OF ONE OF THE BARRIERS
TO THAT IS BEING ABLE TO GET A
LICENSE TO GET A JOB.
AND BE ABLE TO THEM PAYOFF FINE
SO THIS BILL NARROWLY FOCUS IS
TO BE ABLE TO SAY THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HAD A LICENSE.
OR AND THEIR LICENSES SUSPENDED
BECAUSE OF FINDER WHATEVER WHEN
THEY GO TO PRISON THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO BE ISSUED A LICENSE TO
GET BACK AND FORTH TO WORK.
BEGIN TO PAY OFF THOSE FINES
WITH THE NEW YEAR'S TIME TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEIR LIVES
RESTARTED I HAVE WITH ME
WITNESSES HERE FROM. PARTISAN
FAMILY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS YOU
HAVE ON A BROUGH ON THE
FAMILIES.
STRENGTHENING CASE MANAGER. AND
RESOURCE SPECIALIST FOR FATHERS
OF FAMILIES OF SAN WHO CHEAT ON
YOUR BASED IN STOCKTON.
AND I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR. OUR
SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
SO LITTLE ABOUT OUR ORGANIZATION
IS FATHERS OF FAMILIES OF SAN
JOAQUIN WORKS TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF MEN WOMEN YOUTH AND
FAMILIES AND STOCKTON
PREDOMINATELY SUPPORTING. LOW
INCOME FATHERS AND MEN OF COLOR
AND PROVIDE CASE MANAGEMENT TO
CONNECT FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO RESOURCES FOR
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
MANY FORMERLY INCARCERATED
CALIFORNIANS FEE SIGNIFICANT
HALOGENS WHEN THEY RETURNED BACK
INTO THE COMMUNITIES AND BEGIN
TO REBUILD THEIR LIVES AND
FAMILIES.
THE ABILITY TO EARN A LIVING AS
A NECESSITY FOR THEM AS IT IS
FOR ALL PEOPLE IN ORDER TO MEET
THE DEMANDS OF DAILY LIFE
INCLUDING PROVIDING SAFE.
SAVE HOUSING FOOD AND CLOTHING
IN ORDER TO SEEK OBTAIN RETAIN
EMPLOYMENT AND WAGES OFTENTIMES
ABILITY TO DRIVE IS A NECESSITY
PARTICULARLY IN AREAS WHERE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. MAY NOT
BE FAR REACHING OR ABLE TO MEET%
DEMANDS OF LATE NIGHT SHIFTS.
OBSTACLES SUCH AS I BELIEVE YOU
DRIVE FREAK ONLY RELATING TO
SUSPENDED LICENSING.
FOR THE FOR THINGS SUCH AS
PREVIOUS A TRAFFIC INFRACTIONS
AND BACK TO PAYMENTS.
OUR RELATED FINES AND FEES
OFTEN.
AND KEYED ON ONE'S ABILITY TO
GET EMPLOYMENT.
WE MUST UP WE MUST ENSURE THAT
SYSTEM IMPACTED INDIVIDUALS HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REBUILD THEIR
LIVES AND DEVELOP A FOUNDATION.
AND CREATE A NEW CRIME FREE.
CRIME FREE LIFE BACK AND BACK IN
THE COMMUNITY.
AS ONE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL SEATED. NOT HAVING
YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE IS A HUGE
ENTRY HINDRANCE WHEN IT COMES.
TO BEING ABLE TO GET TO AND FROM
APPOINTMENTS
WORK.
SCHOOLS AND JOB INTERVIEWS
ALL THESE BASIC NECESSITIES
BECOME ILLEGAL WHEN YOU CANNOT
OBTAIN DRIVER'S LICENSE.
AND THE SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR WE VOICE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND URGE
YOU FOR. A VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS SO I LIKE TO PRESENT THIS
TO FIX THE HOUSE.
A HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY IMPACTED
BY THEIR INABILITY TO GET
DRIVER'S LICENSE.
MORNING IMPOSSIBLE TO YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION.
SO TO MAKE IT BRIEF. YOU KNOW
WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN MY MY SINGLE
PAYER FATHER PASSED AWAY AND I
THOUGHT ON THE PENINSULA STEM OF
THE SCHOOL PUSH OUT WHEN I WAS
LOOKING FOR RESOURCES AND HELP.
IT TOLD ME TO GO TO A PACKET
SCHOOL.
BUT I WANT ADMIN ASSISTANT
BEING TRIED AS AN ADULT GOT
TWENTY FOUR YEAR TERM BASICALLY.
ALMOND WHEN S. B. TO SEIZE CAME
TO ALSO ON THE FIRST IF YOU NON
FIRST ACTUALLY PRO SUITABLY.
BUT FOR JUST PICKED BY
IMMIGRATION BUT IN ANY CASE.
ON THAT TIME OF BEING OUT YOU
KNOW HAVE A LOT OF THINGS TO DO
ANY TRAVIS LICENSE WAS
ESSENTIAL.
I LIVE YOU HAVE TO GO ME MAKE MY
POINT OF PRO I HAVE TO MAKE MY
POINT TO IMMIGRATION.
AND WHILE I WAS LIVING IN A
TRANSITIONAL HOME ALSO SAW THAT
EVERYBODY ELSE HAD THE SAME
PREDICAMENT.
WE CANNOT GET TO APPOINTMENTS ON
TIME TO COULD DO ANYTHING. AND
SOMETIMES JOB OFFERS ARE COMING
WHEN THE JOB OFFERS TO COME DAY
WE NEED TO GO GET A LICENSE BUT
BY TIME THEY GOT THE LICENSE.
THAT DABABNEH FIELD.
AND SOMETIMES IT TOOK MONTHS TO
TO GET AT THE TRACK DOWN
DOCUMENTS
DIFFICULT GETS. NAM ENTERED THE
PEOPLE COMING HOME YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY COME HOME FROM STATE PRISON
WITHOUT INCOME WITHOUT SAVINGS
THIRTY FIVE ALSO CHARGE LICENSE.
THAT'S A REALLY TOUGH BURDEN.
THAT'S A REALLY TOUGH BURDEN ARM
A LITTLE THOUSANDS OF HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FAILED
FINE.
ON THESE ARE VERY SECOND LEAD TO
FINES OR YOU INCARCERATION IN ON
THAT IS ATTACHMENT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
RESULT BUT ME PERSONALLY HAVING
HAD A LICENSE.
IT WAS A BOOK I WAS ABLE TO GET
MY LICENSE RETURNED RESTORED AS
ALWAYS IT WAS FAIRLY EASY. ARM
ONCE I GOT MY SO THEY WOULD
TRAVEL. AS OUR VOLUNTEERING ARMS
DIED IN A LOT THINGS AND SINCE
THEN I'VE BEEN PART OF YOU SAID
COALITION BEEN ENGAGING ARE YOU.
AND DO A LOT OF THINGS ARM INTO
SELF AND COMMUNITY. ARM BUT WHAT
FOLKS WILL BE DOING WHEN YOU
GIVE SOMEBODY A HELPING HAND.
TO GIVE THEM NOW LICENSE YOUR
BASIS AND WE HAVE FAITH IN YOU
WE TRUST YOU.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU WHICH
ANNIE.
SO FOR THESE REASONS SPREE SO
YES AND AB POINT SEVENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL JENSEN I AM
HERE WITH FATHERS AND FAMILIES.
SAN JOAQUIN OF IN STOCKTON.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF B TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS WRITTEN
RODRIGUEZ.
I'M HERE TODAY WITH FOND OF ITS
FOUNDING FAMILIES FOLLOW THE
FAMILIES.
.
OF SEVENTEEN SOGHAN.
WE VOICE OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY DON'T REFORM AND VERGE
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE FOR OUR
CLIENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ROSE CON IMMIGRANT LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAURICE GOINGS FATHER THE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE FROM SATAN UP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU FOR THAT
COMPELLING TESTIMONY PEOPLE OF
DONE THEIR TIME WE SHOULD
REPLENISHED THEM WHEN THEY GET
OUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. DOCUMENTS EGGMAN FOR WORK
WHERE ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
ON ON THE AMENDMENTS AND.
AT LEAST ENJOY SUCH AYE
RECOMMENDATION FROM A CHAIR.
CULTURAL AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. RELATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER AYE AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
CARILLO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
MEASURES ON CALL YOU VERY MUCH
WHAT.
THERE FLORA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
WEBER.
CHIU.
BOTH CHIU NOT WHETHER.
CHOOSE PRESENTING ON HER BEHALF
OF MISS WEBER.
AND MR TING
WAITING FOR EDUARDO.
GARCIA.
CHIU.
TING.
TRAVIS ALLEN.
MISTER SANTIAGO OBERNOLTE.
SO MISTER LACKEY PRESENTED FOR
MISTER OBERNOLTE
WE GO INTO PAT ON QUIRK.
I QUIRK I.
THANK YOU.
YEAH
.
YES MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA
TESTIMONY ONLY THANK YOU FOR.
FOR.
SO YOU HEARD ME. YEAH. YEAH SO
AT AT AT A BIG YOU A MISTER
CHAIR FOR PATIENTS AND AND
COLLEAGUES.
AB TWENTY FOURTEEN IS A BILL
THAT THAT WE'VE.
TITLE JUSTICE FOR AVERY GLOVER.
AND IT'S DESIGNED TO BRING
JUSTICE TO ASSESS THE ACT OF
VIOLENCE AND PROVIDE CLOSURE FOR
A FAMILY.
HAD THEIR YOUNG SON TAKEN AWAY.
FROM THE. TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
ELEVEN YEAR OLD CHILD AMY
EVERITT LOVER INTO PROPOUNDING
WAS KILLED. IN THE FATAL HIT AND
RUN ACCIDENT. IN THE CITY OF EL
CENTRO.
PERPETRATOR RESORTED TO EXTREME
MEASURES TO COVER UP THE CRIME
NOT ONLY DID THE CORPORATE FLEE
THE SCENE AND HIDE THEIR CAR IN
THE. COUNTRYSIDE OF THE COUNTY
FOR OVER A WEEK BUT FALSE
STATEMENTS WERE GIVEN TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS DURING THE
INVESTIGATION.
PACIFIC IS SUSPECT STATED THAT
THE VEHICLE IN QUESTION HAD BEEN
SOLD.
THE MORNING PRIOR TO THE
ACCIDENT ACCORDING TO CHP.
INVOLVED IN THE CASE OF BROKEN
PIECE OF HEADLIGHT LEFT BEHIND
THE SCENE OF THE CRIME FIX WITH
THE SERIAL NUMBER. ALLOWED CHP
INVESTIGATORS IDENTIFY. THE MAKE
AND THE MODEL OF THE VEHICLE
INVOLVED IN A FATAL ACCIDENT.
WAS NOT UNTIL A NEIGHBOR
CONTACTED ALL CENTRAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT TRYING TO. FIND THE
VEHICLE TO HIS NEIGHBOR THAT THE
SUSPECT WAS ARRESTED.
NOT FOR THE BROKEN PIECE OF HAD
LIKE LEFT BEHIND THE GUILTY
PARTY MAY HAVE NEVER BEEN.
CONNECTED TO THIS CRIME.
DESPITE EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES THE OFFENDER
RECEIVED THE MIDDLE PRISON TERM.
OF THREE YEARS INSTEAD OF A
MAXIMUM OF FOUR YEAR SENTENCE.
FAMILY FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY ARE
STILL STRUGGLING TO CARRY ON IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THIS TRAGEDY.
I WOULD PERSONALLY LIKE TO THANK
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER.
CHAPTER OF IMPROVE COUNTY FOR
THEIR HELP AND SUPPORT DURING
THIS ORDEAL TO THE FAMILY IN THE
COMMUNITY.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I INTRODUCED
THIS BILL BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
WILL LEAD TO A GREATER REDUCTION
AND IT RUNS.
INTRODUCED THIS BILL BECAUSE
AFTER TALKING WITH AVERY
GLOVER'S MOTHER AFTER SEEN.
THE PAIN SHE CARRIED THREE YEARS
AFTER THE ACCIDENT AFTER HEARING
ABOUT ALL OF THE EXTERNAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT THE PERPETRATOR WENT
THROUGH TO ESCAPE JUSTICE
MY THOUGHTS TURN TO MY OWN
CHILDREN.
EVERY PARENT KNOWS HOW PRECIOUS
OUR CHILDREN ARE.
HOW? IRREPLACEABLE THEIR LIVES
ARE AND THOUGH NO LAW CAN BRING
A CHILD THAT'S GONE BACK TO
LIFE.
THESE TYPES OF CIRCUMSTANCES
SHOULD BE HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE RECKLESSNESS.
THE RECKLESSNESS AND SELFISHNESS
OF THE PERPETRATOR KILLED EVERY
GLOVER AND HE WAS ALMOST ALLOWED
TO GET AWAY WITH IT.
THIS BILL WOULD CHANGE IN TERMS
OF IMPRISONMENT FOR FLEEING THE
SCENE OF A VEHICULAR ACCIDENT.
THAT RESULTS IN DEATH OR SERIOUS
PERMANENT INJURY.
TWO FOUR OR SIX YEARS THE BELT
INCREASES START TO HOLDING THESE
INDIVIDUALS ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THE
RECKLESSNESS PENALIZE THEM FOR
TRYING TO EVADE JUSTICE AND
HOPEFULLY SPARE OTHER MOTHERS
FROM THIS TORMENT.
WITH ME I HAVE A.
WITNESS THE.
THAT IS ACTUALLY.
TESTIFY ON A PERSONAL LEVEL AND
DONE.
SHE'S HERE TODAY AT MRS GIPSON.
I WHO WILL TESTIFY ON THIS BILLS
WELL.
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS MY NAME IS A CRUCIAL
GIPSON.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR MINUTES I
PRETEND TO SPEAK BEFORE YOUR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOURTEEN.
WHICH SEEKS TO INCREASE THE
TERMS OF IMPRISONMENT FOR THOSE
CONVICTED OF A HIT AND RUN
CRIME.
MANY OF YOU.
KNOW THAT MY HUSBAND IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON BUT MANY DO NOT
KNOW.
THAT I AM A MOTHER OF TWO BOYS
ONE WHICH WAS TRAGICALLY HIT AND
KILLED BY A HIT AND RUN DRIVER
RIGHT BEFORE MY EYES IN FRONT OF
MY HOME.
ON MARCH TWENTY FOURTH NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE I HAVE TO DIFFICULT
DAY OF MY LIFE I HAD TO BURY MY
THREE YEAR OLD SON AS RESULT OF
A HIT AND RUN.
YOU SEE WAS ON THE EVENING OF
MARCH EIGHTEENTH WHEN MY SON.
WAS STRUCK BY A VEHICLE BY A
WOMAN.
SHE GOT HER VEHICLE AFTER THE
IMPACT HE WENT TO THE AREA WHERE
MY SON LIVES IN THIS STREET LIKE
BLISS FOR ABOUT TEN SECONDS.
JUMP BACK IN HER VEHICLE AND SHE
TOOK OFF.
THIS PERSON NEVER CAME FOR TO
ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY OF OUR
ACTIONS FOR KILLING MY SON.
MY LIFE WILL NEVER BE THE SAME I
HAVE A BOY THAT CANNOT BE FIELD.
I AM SO GRATEFUL TO MY FAMILY MY
FRIENDS MY SUPPORT GROUPS
JUSTICE FOR MYRNA CHILDREN.
PARENTS OF MURDERED CHILDREN.
BECAUSE OF THE WEATHER FOR THEM.
I'M REALLY NOT SURE BOBBY BEFORE
YOUR TODAY.
THIS BILL OF STAYS THE CURRENT
LAWS AND CHANGE THE TERMS OF
IMPRISONMENT FROM TWO THREE OR
FOUR YEARS AND INCREASES IT TO
TWO FOUR OR SIX YEARS.
I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO MARK
YOU WANT US TO EVEN BEGIN TO
TOUCH ON THE HEARTBREAK OF
LOSING A CHILD.
BUT WHEN A PERSON TAKE A LIFE BY
HIDDEN RUN.
LOOK AT THEM AND TAKE OFFICE
IT'S AMAZING TO ME HOW THE GO
WILD DATA DAY IN THIS LIFE.
THE YEARS ADDED TO THIS BILL
CANNOT ERASE THE YEARS OF
HEARTBREAK THAT HAS BROUGHT ME
MY FAMILY BUT IT IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP TO ENSURING JUSTICE WHICH I
HAVE YET TO RECIEVE.
CAN BE DONE WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ACTS WERE YOU AYE VOTE ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOURTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MRS GIPSON
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
ARE A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SHOP WITH CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
COR SAYS IT WILL BE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALERT.
ANY WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION
.
I'M MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION I WANT
TO SAY FIRST THAT MY HEART GOES
OUT TO YOU I'M SO SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS. ON.
BUT THIS BILL IS BAD PUBLIC
POLICY. ON VEHICLE CODE SECTION
TWENTY THOUSAND AND ONE. WHICH
IS COMMONLY KNOWN AS HIDDEN RUN.
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO EVEN HAVE
CAUSED THE ACCIDENT TO BE
PROSECUTED UNDER THE SECTION
IT'S MERELY FLEEING THE SCENE OF
THE. ACCIDENT.
AND.
THERE ARE COUNTLESS REASONS WHY
IT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE NOW. TO.
CHANGE THE TREND IN CALIFORNIA
TO RE EXAMINE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE WE HAVE
INCARCERATED?
I. MASS INCARCERATION HAS NOT
MADE OUR CITIES AND STATES
COMMUNITIES SAFER.
IT HAS ONLY BURDEN THE
TAXPAYERS.
AND OUR SCARCE RESOURCES NEED TO
BE USED FOR OUR CHILDREN AND FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES AND WE ASK YOU
TO VOTE NO THANK YOU.
IT'LL WITNESSES.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA AND I ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS. MY SYMPATHY AND I.
I CAN'T IMAGINE.
I WISH THERE WERE A CHANGE TO
THE LAW THAT THAT WOULD KEEP
THIS FROM HAPPENING IN THE
FUTURE AND SPARE OTHER FAMILIES
THAT THAT KIND. OF SUFFERING BUT
BUT THIS BILL WON'T DO THAT.
.
AND I JOIN IN THE THE COMMENTS
OF OF.
MISS GEORGE I INCREASING THE
TERM OF IMPRISONMENT FOR LEAVING
THE SCENE OF AN ACCIDENT.
.
WILL DO NOTHING TO DETER
FURTHER INCIDENTS OF RECKLESS
DRIVING OR EVEN TO DETER DRIVERS
FROM LEAVING THE SCENE OF AN
ACCIDENT ON THERE ARE BETTER
USES FOR THE STATE'S RESOURCES
THAT WILL BETTER INCREASE THE
PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE.
ALRIGHT ANY. OTHER WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION.
ANNOUNCER HERNANDEZ MAY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA TREES ARE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
OPPOSED TO BILL FOR THE REASON
STATE OUR LETTER.
THANK YOU.
OUR EARLY. MILIC COMMITTEE BILL
GREG QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE YOU MAY CLOSE.
WELL IT WAS SHARED AND.
COLLEAGUES AND OF COURSE OF
THOSE WHO HAVE TESTIFIED BOTH
AND SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS I
THINK THIS IS A MEASURE THAT
RAISES THE BAR ON.
THE ACCOUNTABILITY.
OF INACTION.
THAT RESULTS IN THE FATAL.
.
HOW COME OF OF AN INDIVIDUAL?
?
I ALONG WITH MANY OF YOU HERE.
.
WELL SAW PROCLAIM. YOU KNOW.
OF BEING A ADVOCATE.
FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE ISSUES.
FOR.
THE DECRIMINALIZATION OF US YOU
KNOW PEOPLE OF COLOR.
WHO LIVE UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT REALLY LIMIT THEIR
ABILITIES TO?
OUT BE SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
AND I FOR ONE YOU KNOW I BELIEVE
ALSO THAT IT ISN'T ABOUT.
INCARCERATING PEOPLE THAT'S
GOING TO TURN AROUND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT. I I I CITY
YOU CHAIR IN AND COLLEAGUES IN
AND THOSE WHO ARE HERE. I'M HOW
DO YOU LOOK AT.
.
SOMEONE IN THE EYES.
MOTHER OF FATHER WHO HAS LOST
THEIR SON OR DAUGHTER IN THESE
TYPES OF TRAGIC CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND YET. YOU KNOW SOMEONE IS
ABLE TO GET AWAY.
IN THE CASE OF MRS GIPSON NO
ONE'S EVER BEEN HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
IN THE CASE OF MISTER GLOVER
THIS YOUNG MAN.
WHO WAS TAKEN AWAY? TRAGICALLY.
THIS INDIVIDUAL. DID EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO EVADE.
BEING HELD RESPONSIBLE AND
ACCOUNTABLE AND SO.
FOR ME IT'S ABOUT JUSTICE
WITHOUT A DOUBT.
AND ALSO.
A COMFORTING FOR A FAMILY
KNOWING THAT YEAH.
THE CHILD WILL NEVER.
BE BACK WITH US BUT THE FACT IS
THAT SOMEONE WAS HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR ACTION AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT IT BOILS
DOWN TO ITS ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY.
.
ANYONE.
WHO FLEES FROM A ACCIDENTALLY
HIT AND RUN ACCIDENT AND THE
OUTCOME IS FATAL I MEAN I CAN
IMAGINE? THE CONSCIENCE
OF THAT INDIVIDUAL WHO IS GIVEN
AWAY.
KNOWING OR NOT KNOWING THAT
THEY'VE.
HARM SOMEONE.
AND THAT.
IN.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO REMORSE
FOR THAT TYPE OF ACTION YOU
KNOW.
A TWO YEAR PRISON IMPRISONMENT
FOR THAT TYPE OF SITUATION IS.
NOT JUSTICE
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT SO I RESPECTFULLY.
IN A REQUEST THAT WE WORK WITH
YOU AND AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
AND FOLKS WERE. IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS AND PERHAPS.
THE SENSE HERE IS THAT. YET THIS
WILL DETER. THESE TYPES OF
THINGS FROM HAPPENING BUT THE
FACT THE MATTER IS THAT. YOU
KNOW PEOPLE WELL BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE AND ACCOUNTABLE. FOR
THEIR ACTIONS AND I THINK. THAT.
FOR FAMILIES I THINK WOULD BE
JUSTICE IN CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE
THESE I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO. THIS MATTER. AND
AND I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW.
WANT ONE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR.
DOING TESTIMONY ONLY BECAUSE I
REALLY REALLY AND IT'S COMMITTEE
REALLY WANTS TO WORK WITH YOU ON
A SOLUTION.
.
IT IS DIFFICULT. LISTENING TO
THE STORIES.
IS EVEN MORE DIFFICULT ONE INCH
WHEN YOUR COLLEAGUES ONCE YOUR
FRATERNITY BROTHER. WHO TELLS
YOU ABOUT?
?
THEIR CHILD.
SOMEONE YOU ACTUALLY KNOW.
AND IT'S HARD FOR ME TO LISTEN
TO THE STORIES.
AND ON MRS GIPSON YOUR VERY
ELOQUENT.
AND STATING.
THAT WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
AND SO I'VE MADE A COMMITMENT
NOT ONLY AS A AFTER AMERICAN. A
FATHER AND I KNOW MR.
GARCIA IS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED IN HIS COMMUNITIES
QUESTION AFTER AMERICAN
COMMUNITY.
AND DOES HE HAS BEEN.
A TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR COMING
UP WITH A SOLUTION FOR THIS.
BUT THIS PROBLEM ON AND IS IT
THERE'S PROBABLY TWO OR THREE
AREAS I THINK.
WE MIGHT BE ABLE.
BRING.
.
BRING SOMETHING TO THE TABLE SO
THAT. WE CAN HOPEFULLY CURTAIL
PEOPLE FROM FLEEING.
BUT ARE LEAST MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO DO THAT
AND I WANT TO HAVE THAT.
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT.
I DIDN'T WANNA.
DO IT HERE AND AND AND THE OPEN
PUBLIC BUT I GUARANTEE YOU AS
CHAIR OF
FORMER CHAIR THE BLACK CAUCUS
FORMER CHAIR. OF AN AND CHAIR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
WERE GAUCHE.
WORKAWAY HOPEFULLY TO A SOLUTION
AND SOMEONE A THANK YOU ON FREE
COMMITMENT THING TO GIPSON
FAMILY FROM SHARING MATCHES.
AND I KNOW IT'S GONNA BE
DIFFICULT TO TO SHARE.
A PAIN.
THAT WILL NEVER GO AWAY.
AND SO IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO MAKE SURE WHATEVER WE CAN DO
TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN.
SO I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TAX.
THANK YOU.
ADMINISTERED.
CHIU.
FOR DOCTOR WEBER.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
I HOPE.
CHECK YOU MET A SECOND MISTER
CHAIRS ARE MEMBERS.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON HATE CRYING.
RIGHT I AM VERY HAPPY TO PRESENT
DISPUTE THEY'LL AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN.
A BILL THAT I HELP PART OF.
PARTNERED WITH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. OF
FELLOW SELECT COMMITTEE MEMBER
TO PROVIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
ADDITIONAL TOOL. TO.
ACCURATELY ACCURATELY ADDRESS
TODAY A WOULD BE A DOCUMENT A
HATE CRIME IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. TO MAKE A
SIMPLE UPDATE TO THE PROM PAGE
ALL THERE CRYING AND INCIDENT A
REPORT. WAS THE FOLLOWING
QUESTION.
IS DEAR ANY INDICATION DE IDEA
OFFENDER WAS MOTIVATED.
IN WHOLE OR APART BY THE BIAS
AGAINST ONE. OR MORE OF THE
FOLLOWING PERCEIVED OR ACTUAL
CHARACTER CHARACTERISTICS OF
TIBETAN.
THAT INCLUDE RACE RELIGION.
A SEXUAL ORIENTATION DISABILITY
GENDER. ETHNICITY NATIONAL
ORIGIN OR ASSOCIATED WITH A
PERSON OR A GROUP WITH ONE OR
MORE OF THOSE ACTUAL. OR PRIEST
TO A PREACHER YOU.
CHARACTERISTICS.
S. RESOLVE AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WILL CREATE A. A
UNIFORMITY WITH THING THEIR WAY
INCLUDES A CRIME BECOME.
DOCUMENTED AND REPORTED.
DOES ALLY SING TO YOU A
DISCRETION.
AND IN IN THIS STRUCTURE
EMPLACEMENT.
ELEVATE HIS SERIOUSNESS OF GOOD
DOES HATE.
CRIME CASES AND ALSO PRO PROVIDE
MORE ACCURATE TRACKING OF TOOLS
HAY CRIME.
I JUST FEEL HOUSE.
OR DO SUPPORT FOR ANTI. IF I'M
ITCHING A DEFAMATION LEAGUE.
AND THEN DOUBLE ACP.
THE ARC AND YOU'D. UNITED PART
PART. ETCETERA HOPE OF POP THEIR
POSH POSSIBLE AND CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND CONSOLE OFF
AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS AND
AUDITOR'S WAS STRAT I RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EYEBALLS.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANY.
YEAH IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH THANK YOU
TERESA ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ARK IN UCP CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ERIC HARRIS SOME BATH FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NAACP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE A WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION OF WRECKER
SUPERVISORS I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY.
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS AYE MEASURE
WAS SET FOR DUPLICATIVE AND UNDO
FISCAL MANDATE ON OVER FIVE
HUNDRED LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WHO WILL HAVE TO CHANGE
THEIR.
CURRENT SOFTWARE SYSTEM.
TO.
ACCOMMODATE THIS REQUEST ON
THAT'S IN THIS BILL.
SO AND WE ARE TO BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS.
REPORTING IS ARE BEING DONE.
AND THEREFORE IT'S NOT NECESSARY
AND THAT'S WHY I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
CORSO'S ALONE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION.
AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED WELL
FIRST WE'RE OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL AS MY COLLEAGUE GOOD LAW
ENFORCEMENT ALREADY REQUIRED BY
STATUTE TO REPORT A CRIMES.
OF DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
PRODUCES AN ANNUAL REPORT. ON
THAT REPORT INCLUDES THE NATURE
OF THE BIAS AND HEARING IN EACH
PARTICULAR CRIME. VICTIM
CHARACTERISTICS.
OFFENSE TYPE AND LOCATION JUST
TO NAME A FEW DATA POINTS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE IN THAT REPORT
THAT IS ALREADY. PRODUCED UNDER
EXISTING LAW.
THIS BILL AS A NEW STEP BUT IT'S
UNCLEAR AND WHAT RELEVANT INFO
IT PROVIDES OR FACILITATES.
IT'S FRANKLY UNFUNDED MANDATE
THAT APPEARS UNLIKELY TO REMEDY
ANY ACTUAL OR PERCEIVED PROBLEM
IT'S A CHECK BOX ON THE FRONT A
REPORT.
FOR REPORT THAT OSTENSIBLY WILL
INCLUDE INFORMATION ABOUT ANY
SORT OF HATE CRIME THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN COMMITTED OR
ANY NATURE OF THE NATURE OF ANY
BIAS INHERENT IN THE ACT SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NOVA THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
UP ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
BUT MR QUIRK.
WHEN YOU.
COURT SO.
FIRST OF ALL ON IF IT'S A
FINANCIAL BURDEN.
THAT'LL BE TAKEN UP IN
APPROPRIATIONS WILL WE DON'T
HAVE THAT EXPERTISE HERE.
SECOND PART THOUGH IS. UP TO
THE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
SO THE POINT HERE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
REPORT IS FLAGGED.
AND I THINK THE CONCERN OF THE
AUTHOR.
IS THAT.
THE REPORT MAY NOT BE FLAGGED IN
MAY NOT GET OUT.
MISTER CHIU DO YOU WANT TO SAY
A LITTLE BIT MORE DO YOU HAVE
EXAMPLES OF.
THINGS THAT DON'T GET FLAG DO
YOU HAVE REASONS TO BELIEVE
THINGS ARE THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
LABELED HATE CRIMES I DID NOT.
GO FORWARD.
DR AS THANK YOU DOCTOR KIRK GO
CORD YES STUFF IN THE YEAR.
I KNOW THEY'RE IN MANY
DISTRICTS
OR THE JURISDICTION THAT SLOT
MAIN FLAK BUT SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AS.
IN THE THE ON THE FRONT PAGE SO.
.
IT IT IT THE COST TO BE REALLY
MINOR APPRECIATED YOUR COMMENT
THAT THIS IS A GROUP OF WHO
SHOULD BE A USUAL AND
APPROPRIATIONS. BECAUSE MOST
OFTEN DOCUMENT USE A COMPUTER
YOU KNOW HOW COMPUTERS TO
PROCESS THIS REPORT. SO IT IT IS
REALLY. A VERY SIMPLE CHANGE
THAT WE CAN.
PUT THAT ON THE ON ON THE ON
THE FRONT PAGE OF THE INCIDENT
REPORT OKAY BUT DO YOU HAVE.
DO YOU HAVE EXAMPLES IN OTHER
COUNTIES WHERE THINGS THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN FLAGGED WORKED.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW
REDUCE THE?
ARE DO CONTINUE TO SH THEY
SHOULDN'T BE FLAK YEAH ANOTHER
WAY TO BE FLAT HOLY DOIN OF THIS
TYPE.
IS THAT.
YOUR CONCERT YOU WANT THAT CHECK
BOX TO MAKE SURE THAT SO.
ALRIGHT LETS THEM THERE'S A
REPORTING OFFICER AND THEN THE
REVIEWING OFFICER NIGHTYOUR
CONCERN IS THAT.
THERE MAY NOT.
THINGS MAY NOT HAVE GOTTEN TO A
REVIEWING OFFICER AND THEREFORE
IT WOULDN'T BE I'D LIKE TO SEE A
HATE CRIME SUCH ITEMS FROM MY
CHILDREN'S YOU HAVE EXAMPLES.
OF WHEN THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN OR
YOU KNOW JUST WHAT IS THE
CONCERN HERE IS THEREA PROBLEM
THAT NEEDS TO BE STOPPED. DO YOU
HAVE EXAMPLES I MEAN WELL I OKAY
THAT CAN SHARE WITH YOU MY
EXPERIENCE HAVE TO SELL THE CITY
COUNCIL WANTS WE. ADDED THOSE
CHUCK BOX IN THE INCIDENT
REPORT.
DE DOO HAY CRYING REPORTING
DIVERT A GREAT ONE UP SO.
OKAY WELL THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR
ME.
ALL MOVED TO BILLS I I'LL MOVE
THE BELL.
AYE I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU.
TRYING GET SOME EXAMPLES OF
THINGS THAT WEREN'T REPORTED OR
SUCH TO TO BUILD YOUR CASES YOU
GO FORWARD. THANK YOU ARE THANK
YOU.
THINK ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
NONE YOU MAKE CLOTHES.
I'LL CHECK YOU JUST WANT A IN
FACT FOR THE QUESTIONS.
AND NOTE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL.
SHARES RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE CALL
RULE.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
CARILLO. PATIO AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
SO
SANTIAGO YOU WON'T GO NOW.
ITEM NUMBER.
I DON'T REMEMBER THREE A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY NINE SANTIAGO
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON AB
NINETEEN OF FORTY NINE REAL
SIBEL.
THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE THAT
CALLS FOR BREVITY BUT I BUT I
MUST SAY THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL.
AND TO IT AND FLAME THROWERS
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO BE REGULATED.
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA AYE WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
THOUSAND WHO HAVE NOW BEEN SOLD.
TO A STRONG FOLLOWING THE
MUSKETEERS AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE OUGHT TO BE A PERMITTING
PROCESS. IN PLACE.
I HAVE A WITNESS WITH US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AFFECT
VARGAS FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO PEOPLE HAVING
FLAMETHROWERS.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
EDIT WITNESSES PET PROJECT.
RT QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THIS IS A TIME OR JUST PASSING
OUT SOME A INFORMATION SO THAT
FOLKS KNOW WHAT A FLAMETHROWER
LOOKS LIKE.
AND.
SOME BACKGROUND INFORMATION AS
TO WHY.
DE A FIRE POLICY.
COALITION OF WOULD BE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL COULD THINK THEY
WOULD RECOGNIZE THIS BILL ALSO
TO BE A WEAPON. UNTIL I KNOW THE
BILL THE.
FLAMETHROWER COULD BE
POTENTIALLY USED AS A WEAPON AND
WE.
WE REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
UP CHAIRS RECOMMENDED I. MEANT.
CRITICAL ROLE AB NINETEEN FORTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE HAVE. ONE VOTE ONLY ITEM.
I DON'T KNOW BUT THIRTY SEVEN.
A. B. NINETEEN NINETEEN WOULD.
CALL THE ROLL.
WELL I NEED A MOTION TO APPROVE.
VOTE ON THE ISLAND ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN WOULD.
MOVE THE BELL.
AB NINETEEN NINETEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
CARILLO.
COUNTY YOUR AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY.
EIGHT.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER A. B..
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN.
HALL.
FAIRNESS IN THE VILLAGE.
SEC
AND MANY SECOND YEAH.
THANK YOU THIS IS THE.
CLEAN UP BILL TO TO.
CLEAN UP OUR A. B. E. THIRTEEN
POST CONVICTION RELIEF BILL FROM
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND I HAVE A FEW
WITNESSES WERE GOING TO SHORT
PRESENT.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROSE CON FROM
THE IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER RIGHT POUNDED INTRACT TO
IMMIGRANT POST CONVICTION RELIEF
PROJECT LET ME BEGIN BY THANKING
YOU FOR HELPING THE PAST EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTEEN WHICH ENACTED
PENAL CODE SECTION FOURTEEN
SEVENTY THREE POINT SEVEN. AND
SINCE IT HAS BEEN ENACTED ITS
PROVIDED A CRITICAL LEGAL VIA
CALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. DARWIN CRABTREE FOR
EXAMPLE LACK A RESIDENT OF BUTTE
COUNTY A U. S. CITIZEN WAS ABLE
TO VACATE HIS CONVICTION BY
PROVING TO THE JUDGE AND THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. THAT HE WAS
ACTUALLY INNOCENT OF THE CRIME
FOR WHICH HE SPENT NINE YEARS IN
PRISON FOR BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE. JULIA RAMIREZ HAD
GREEN CARD HOLDER A MOTHER OF
TWO U. S. CITIZEN. WAS ABLE TO
VACATE HER UNCONSTITUTIONAL
CONVICTION FROM SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY RE PLEAD TO A NEW OFFENSE
THAT ENABLED HER TO OBTAIN HER
U. S. CITIZENSHIP.
BUT AND SO THESE ARE JUST TWO OF
THE HUNDREDS OF SUCCESS STORIES
WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST YEAR.
BUT IN THE PAST YEAR WE'VE ALSO
SEEN SOME INDIVIDUALS LEFT
BEHIND INDIVIDUALS WHO I KNOW
AND NONE OF US INTENDED TO LEAVE
BEHIND. BECAUSE I TESTIFIED AT
EVERYONE OF THE HEARINGS FOR
THIS BILL AND THIS IS JUST A
SIMPLE CLEAN UP BILL THAT
PROVIDES SOME VERY BASIC TWEAKS
TO ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT OF AB EIGHT THIRTEEN
THAT'S FULLY REALIZE. IT WILL
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE LIKE JOSE A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY A
MEMBER OF UNITE HERE A GREEN
CARD HOLDER FOR OVER THREE
DECADES. CAN CHALLENGE HIS
CONVICTION WITHOUT FIRST
PLACING HIMSELF IN DEPORTATION
PROCEEDINGS IN IMMIGRANT
DETENTION FACILITY AND
SEPARATING HIMSELF FROM HIS
THREE U. S. CITIZEN KIDS.
I THESE
CHANGES WILL ENSURE UNIFORM
IMPLEMENTATION ACROSS THE STATE.
AND SAVE COURT RESOURCES BY
ELIMINATING THE MANDATORY
HEARING REQUIREMENTS.
PLEASE VOTE I.
YES ANY OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT
OF ARGO GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THIS IS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN
DOES NOT MAKE DRASTIC CHANGES TO
THE CURRENT PENAL CODE SECTION
FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE POINT
SEVEN THAT SIMPLY FIXES THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ENCOUNTERED ACROSS THE STATE. SO
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION AYE ANGER
I'M A CA OF CALIFORNIA CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANGELINA ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIAN
CHUNKS PART. THANK YOU.
PAUL SO YOU'VE JUSTICE COALITION
FROM SUPPORT.
YOU.
CHRIS KELANA FROM THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
NOT SURE HERNANDEZ WE HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE A CO SPONSOR OF
THE ORIGINAL BILL AND THE STUFF.
THANK YOU.
THE HAPPY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WHO TWEENER NOT IN OPPOSITION
SHOPPING WITH CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
WITH SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE WORKED WITH THE
AUTHOR STAFF AND SPONSORS WERE
GETTING THAT RESOLVED SO? HAPPY
TO BE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I JUST NOTICED A KILEY. THANK
YOU SECURE BY DEFAULT ON MISTER
HOFFMAN'S COMMENT COULD YOU GIVE
US AN UPDATE ON WHERE I WHAT THE
STATUS IS OF THE PREJUDICIAL
ERROR LANGUAGE.
WE'RE WORKING ON IT'LL IT'LL BE
WORKED OUT I THINK WE'RE
CONFIDENT.
TO HIS SATISFACTION.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
ARE SUCH CLASS FOR MY VOTE THOSE
ENJOYS IN AYE RECOMMENDATION
FROM A CHAIR RECALL WORLD. AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
CARILLO. CALLIOPE ICONS ON HIS
FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT BOATING QUIRK
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER FLORA.
THE LONG DAY UPS ARE.
.
I AM BEFORE YOU START BY ONE
ANNOUNCED THAT.
.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY AND AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY EIGHT.
ITEMS.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY WILL PULL BY
TRAVIS ALLEN.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
ALRIGHT THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY.
THANK YOU.
HERE PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTEEN.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS TO CARRY CCW WHILE
ATTENDING RELIGIOUS SERVICES
LOCATED ON SCHOOL PROPERTY ONLY.
AFTER RECEIVING WRITTEN
PERMISSION FROM A SCHOOL
AUTHORITY.
AB TWENTY THREE T. STEMS FROM A
CHURCH IN MY DISTRICT.
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO HIRE SECURITY OR OFFICERS.
IS UNABLE TO PROTECT MEMBERS
DURING CHURCH SERVICES BECAUSE
OF THEIR LOCATION.
THIS BILL MAKES CLEAR THAT EACH
AND EVERY PERSON WOULD RICK BE
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN APPROVAL TO
CARRY ONLY DURING TIMES
DESIGNATED BY THE BILL AND THE
SCHOOL.
IT ALSO MAKE CLEAR THE AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTEEN IS NARROWLY
FOCUSED ONLY PLAYS A RELIGIOUS
SERVICES HELD ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES.
IT DOES NOT IMPACT EVERY SCHOOL
NOR OUR SCHOOLS REQUIRE TWO
PERCENT PER
TO PARTICIPATE
TWENTY THREE TEN WOULD SIMPLY
INSURE THE CONGREGATIONS. OF ALL
FACE HAVE THE ABILITY PROTECT
THEMSELVES AS THEY SEE FIT
REGARDLESS OF THE PHYSICAL
LOCATION OF THEIR BUILDING AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
WELL.
YOU MAY CLOSE IT IS TO FLOOR.
COLLEAGUES THIS.
I KNOW THIS BILL IS IS ONE OF
THOSE BILLS THAT THAT COUNTS FOR
THAT'S THAT'S NOT EASY FOR SOME
OF YOU IN A IN THIS IS ACTUALLY
BILL THAT.
.
IT'S QUITE FRANKLY KINDA RENEWED
MY FAITH IN THIS INSTITUTION
BECAUSE WORKING WITH A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF COLLEAGUES.
ON THIS BILL TWO MAKE IT NARROW
ENOUGH TO WHERE WE CAN GET IT
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE AND HAVE AN
HONEST CONVERSATION ABOUT
FIXING.
AND ISSUE.
IS ACTUALLY QUITE REFRESHING TO
SEE SO I JUST WAS A THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND IT'S BEEN A
PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS PARTICULAR BUILDING
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I DON'T.
THINK YOU.
KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS ON AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTEEN JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NOT VOTING LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE CAVIAR.
CARILLO NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NOT VOTING
KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SUB LOCAL.
SANTIAGO AYE.
SORRY TO MAIL
FAILED
S. RECONSIDERATION YES.
BUT WHAT WHAT BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT.
SO MUCH.
HAS ANYONE SEEN BUT MISTER TING.
I THINK RESTRICTING SHOWED UP.
WITH A NEW HAIRCUT.
ITEM SEVENTEEN.
AB TWENTY SIX LETTERS ONE
NOTICES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY IS A SIMPLE
BUILT THE PILOT BILL THAT
SUPPORTS THE PROCESS OF
REPORTING A RENTAL CARS AND
BASIL TO EASE THE PROCESS OF
RECOVERING. STOLEN VEHICLES ARE
MOVED TO BALLOTS CAR COMPANIES
ON EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I DO HAVE ONE WITNESS
CIRCULAR GOOD TO TELL. HIS STORY
WHICH IS WHAT INSPIRED THE BILL
AND I ENCOURAGED HIM TO BE BRIEF
AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A COMMITTEE FOR THE
HEARING THANK YOU CHAIRMAN FOR
GIVING US THE TIME.
BASICALLY I'M A WASHED UP
MUSICIAN.
WHO?
?
WASHED OUT OF THE MUSIC
BUSINESS AND I WOUND UP STARTING
IN A VAN RENTAL COMPANY CATERING
TO MUSICIANS.
AND.
IT WAS JUST A SINGLE VAN PARKED
FOR MY APARTMENT TO AND SLOWLY
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE GROWN TO
HAVE.
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE U. S..
OVER THE PAST TWO TO THREE
YEARS WE'VE SEEN A DRAMATIC
UPTICK IN IDENTITY THEFT.
SO WE ALSO RENT TO NON
MUSICIANS AS TIME WENT BY.
AND.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF OUR CARS
BEING STOLEN.
AND WHAT WE'VE OBSERVED AS WHEN
THESE VEHICLES ARE STOLEN.
THEY'RE OFTEN USED TO COMMIT.
FURTHER CRIMES THAT'S BEEN
CONFIRMED BY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THAT WE'VE
SPOKEN TO AS YOU KNOW IN OUR.
WHERE WERE HEADQUARTERED IN SAN
FRANCISCO THERE'S BEEN?
MASSIVE UPTICK IN A CAR BREAK
INS.
SO WHAT BASICALLY HAPPENED TO
ME WAS I CUT BY PURE CHANCE US
COMING BACK FROM A DENTAL
APPOINTMENT AND.
ONE OF OUR STOLEN VANCE HAPPEN
TO PULL RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME ON
THE HIGHWAY.
I WOUND UP FOLLOWING THE VAN I
TRIED TO CALL THE POLICE TO GET
THEM TO.
ENGAGE.
WITH THESE FOLKS UP BY THE WAY
THESE PEOPLE WERE FIVE DAYS PAST
DUE.
AND WE HAD KNOWN EVEN BEFORE
THEY WERE PAST DUE THAT WAS
IDENTITY THEFT.
THERE'S JUST A NUMBER OF
INDICATIONS.
SO.
.
THE POLICE COULDN'T HELP
BECAUSE.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
LAWS.
THAT.
PREVENT US FROM BEING ABLE TO.
TAKE CARE OF THE THE SITUATION
OURSELVES IDEALLY WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO USE GPS TRACKING STE
WHEN A VEHICLE SLATE SO THAT WE
CAN GO RECOVER THE VEHICLE
OURSELVES WITHOUT INVOLVING THE
POLICE.
SETTING THAT ASIDE AS IT IS
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO SEND A
CERTIFIED LETTER.
IN WAIT FIVE DAYS AFTER THE END
OF THE CONTRACT BEFORE WE CAN.
GET THE POLICE TO HELP US.
MY STORY WAS UNUSUAL WE GOT TO
THE END OF IT I MANAGED TO TRICK
THE THIEVES INTO GIVING US THE
VEHICLE BACK SO IN THIS CASE WE
DID GET THE VEHICLE BACK BUT.
SOMETIMES WE DON'T GET THE
VEHICLE BACK.
AND SO.
THIS LEGISLATION IN FRONT OF
YOU HERE.
NOW CURRENTLY.
WILL REDUCE THE.
EMBEZZLEMENT PERIOD OF FROM
FIVE DAYS TO THREE DAYS UMPS
HAVE JUST A LITTLE.
SOMETHING TO KEEP IN THE BACK
YOUR MINDS.
SO OFTEN ARE RENTALS ARE FOR
MULTIPLE WEEKS AND SOMETIMES
MONTHS YOU KNOW BANDS GOING ON
TOUR.
IF SOMEBODY RENTS A VAN FOR
THIRTY DAYS AND WE DISCOVER ON
DAY ONE.
THAT IT'S PROBABLY FRAUD BUT
CAN'T PROVE IT. WE HAVE TO WAIT
THIRTY FIVE DAYS BEFORE WE CAN
REPORT THE VEHICLE STOLEN SO.
WORK WERE TRYING TO GET.
THAT GAP NARROWED A LITTLE BIT
AND THEN HOPEFULLY DOWN THE
ROAD.
ADDRESSED THE. GPS TRACKING
ISSUE AS WELL.
AYE WE DON'T WANT ANYTHING TO DO
WITH.
INVADING A CONSUMER PRIVACY.
BUT OBVIOUSLY IF THE VEHICLES
MORE THAN A DAY OR TWO.
LATE BEING RETURNED I THINK
IT'S REASONABLE FOR US TO KNOW
WHERE VEHICLES.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE WITH SITTING.
WITHOUT A RESPECT FAST FIVE.
A CHAIRS RECOMMEND AYE VOTE I'M
GLAD.
CLEARED UP THAT YOU READ TO MORE
MUSICIANS.
I WOULD HATE TO THINK YOU
DISPARAGE EVERY MUSICIAN IN
CALIFORNIA BUT I'M GLAD YOU
CLEARED THAT UP.
CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE I TOLD HER I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE CAMEO.
CARILLO ARTICLES ON HIS FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK. QUIRK AYE SUB
CACKLE.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THEY MAKE
YOU.
AND LAST BUT CERTAINLY A LOT NOT
LEAST ITEM TWENTY TWO A. B.
TWENTY SEVEN TEN.
LACKEY FOR MISTER OBERNOLTE.
WARRANTS.
DEAR.
QUICK.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY
I'M PRESENTING AB TWENTY SEVEN
TEN A BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE. AND A BEHALF OF HIM
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THINK THE CHAIR.
AND STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THIS BILL LINES THE ARREST AND
SEARCH WARRANTS STATUTE TO MAKE
MORE PROCEDURES MORE EFFICIENT.
PACIFIC LEAD THE BILL ALLIANCE
SEARCH WARRANT PROCEDURES WITH
THE REST MORE PROCEDURES ADOPTED
BY THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TEN GAMES THE
WARRANT SIGNED BY THE MAGISTRATE
RECEIVED BY THE OFFICER AS YOU
ORIGINAL WAR REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE MAGISTRATE
TO PRINT THE WARRANT.
REQUIRES A LOT ELECTRONIC OATH
RATHER THAN ORAL OATH MORE
ANSWER. A REQUEST
ELECTRONICALLY.
AND MAINTAINS THE MAGISTRATE'S
DISCRETION TO CALL THE OFFICER
ON THE PHONE TO DISCUSS THE WAR.
REQUEST WHEN APPROPRIATE WITH ME
TODAY OUR REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE SPONSORED A FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. JUDGE CAL
BRODY.
DECEMBER DINO SUPERIOR COURT
AND SHARON RILEY WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THEIR BRIEF
STATEMENTS.
SHARON RILEY.
VERY BRIEFLY I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO THANK. MR LACKEY AND.
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING.
WITH THIS ON AMENDMENTS.
ALSO.
I KNOW THAT THE PUB PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ARE LISTED. IN
OPPOSITION HOWEVER OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL DAYS. WE HAVE HAD VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
WORK THINGS OUT.
I HANDED OFF TO DETROIT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO DISCUSS THIS
BILL.
THE.
BILL IS DESIGNED TO MAKE A
FAIRLY SIMPLE TECHNICAL CHANGE
TO CALIFORNIA LAW.
MY NAME IS KYLE BRODY AND THE
JUDGE IN SAM DID YOU KNOW COUNTY
I ALSO SIT ON THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THEIR TECHNOLOGY COMMITTEE. I
ALSO CHAIR OUR LOCAL COURTS
TECHNOLOGY COMMITTEE AS WELL.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS
CONSISTENTLY TRIED TO.
IMPROVE THE WAY THAT THE STATE'S
JUDICIARY DOES BUSINESS USING
TECHNOLOGY TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IMPROVE THE ABILITY OF.
USERS OF THE COURT TO GET THERE
GET THE WORK DONE GET THE WORK
OF THE COURT DONE MORE EASILY
AND EFFICIENTLY THIS BILL WOULD
HELP ACCOMPLISH THAT IT WOULD
ELIMINATE. A REDUNDANT
REQUIREMENT IT DATES FROM A
DIFFERENT TIME BEFORE WE HAD THE
TECHNOLOGICAL ABILITY TO HAVE
OFFICERS SUBMIT SEARCH WARRANTS
AND ARREST WARRANTS
ELECTRONICALLY.
THERE ARE CERTAINLY A NUMBER OF
WAYS THAT DIFFERENT COUNTIES
HAVE OFFICERS SUBMIT SEARCH
WARRANTS AFTER HOURS WHEN THE
JUDGES ON CALL.
CRAP UNDER CURRENT LAW THE.
PROCESS REQUIRES THAT THE JUDGE
REACH
THE OFFICER BY TELEPHONE.
THIS IS DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THE OFFICER IS ALREADY SUBMITTED
A SWORN DECLARATION UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY.
ATTESTING TO THE FACT THAT WOULD
SUPPORT THE ISSUANCE OF THE
WARRANT THESE ARE.
RECORDS THAT ARE MAINTAINED BY
THE COURT FULLY.
REVIEWABLE BY THE PUBLIC LATER
OFFICERS STILLER ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT THEY SAY IN THOSE WRITTEN
AFFIDAVITS
THE REQUIREMENT OF A TELEPHONE
CONVERSATION RELIEF ADDS NOTHING
MORE. THEN A DELAY AND IT'S NOT
JUST A THEORETICAL PROBLEM IT'S
A REAL PROBLEM HAS HAPPENED. TO
ME AS A JUDGE.
MANY TIMES HAPPENS TO MY
COLLEAGUES ROUTINELY WHERE THIS
IS A REAL PROBLEM.
IT'S A PROBLEM THAT THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS THE ABILITY TO
SOLVE AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I WOULD ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LEXY HOWARD ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
SEAN OFTEN THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OUR EIGHT ANY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION ARM WE ARE CONFIDENT
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THE JUDICIAL.
COUNCIL AND COMMITTEE STAFF TO
REMOVE OUR OBJECTION TO THE BILL
SO THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD TO HEAR THANK YOU.
OF.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE ASSURER YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SHARES RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE CALL
THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. AYE AYE LACKEY AYE
KALLIO CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES COMBAT.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO ADD ON.
WHAT OTHER OTHER HOUSEKEEPING WE
NEED TO DO?
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM ONE WAS PULLED. BY THE
AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TO AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO.
ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FORTY NINE LACKEY.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB NINETEEN
FORTY NINE.
LACKEY LACKEY AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
KILEY.
KILEY NO
ITEM NUMBER FOUR WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WAS TESTIMONY
OWNING.
ITEM NUMBER SIX WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ON CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT ON CONSENT.
I DON'T REMEMBER NINE.
WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER TEN ON CONSENT. ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY THREE OH
TO BAKER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE.
I TO NUMBER TWELVE IT'S BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN WITHOUT
CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY TWO BY MISTER HARPER.
GAVIOTA.
KILEY. GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE THAT
MEASURE FAILS.
IT.
WITHOUT YOU.
UNANIMOUS.
THAT.
THAT BILL'S BEEN GIVEN
RECONSIDERATION.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY THREE.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE.
I UNDER SIXTEEN WAS ON CONSENT.
AND NUMBER SEVENTEEN HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTEEN NINE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
SANTIAGO.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY NINE BY
MISTER COOLEY.
SANTIAGO AYE.
I AM NINETEEN ON CONSENT. ITEM
TWENTY ON CONSENT ITEM TWENTY
ONE ON CONSENT.
I AM TWENTY TWO HAD JUST BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM TWENTY THREE THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. LACKEY.
LACKEY NO GOTTA YOUR.
CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY KNOWN SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE THAT MEASURE PATH THAT.
I DON'T TWENTY FOUR WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR ITEM TWENTY FIVE
WITH. PULLED BY COMMITTEE.
ITEM TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY ONE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
I AM TWENTY SEVEN WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR.
ITEM TWENTY. EIGHT AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN LACKEY.
LACKEY NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM TWENTY NINE
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY WHEN BY
MISTER PATTERSON GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE SANTIAGO.
SUBJECT KNOW THAT MEASURE FAILS.
ITEM.
BY UNANIMOUS.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THIS MEASURES
PEOPLE BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM THIRTY ONE AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY TWO GOVERNOR EURO.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE AB TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY TWO. GOTTA YA GOTTA
YA I.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE PATH.
ITEM THIRTY TO AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO CAVIAR. CAVIAR AYE.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I AM THIRTY THREE WAS ON
CONSENT.
ITEM THIRTY FOR THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL A. B. THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN
BY MISTER GIPSON LACKEY.
LACKEY NOCARDIA. CAVIAR AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
I AM THIRTY FIVE AB THIRTY ONE
EIGHTEEN CAVIAR.
COVER YOUR AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM THIRTY SIX WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN LACKEY.
THERE'S THIRTY SEVEN AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN BY MISTER WOOD.
LACKEY I.
THAT CONCLUDES A VISIT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE STANDS ADJOURNED